ALL PUBLIC SAFETY IS READY TO
BEGIN ONCE WE BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND WE NEED SOME AUTHORS.
SOME SENATE AUTHORS
.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE SENATOR
WINNER -- SINCE WE ARE.
WE HAVE SEVERAL ITEMS AND WE ARE
PRESSED FOR TIME -- WE'RE GOING
TO BEGIN AS A SUB COMMITTEE --
UNTIL.
ALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS GET HERE.
AND IF YOU DON'T MIND IF WE DO
GET TO A POINT WHERE WE HAVE A
QUORUM I MAY INTERRUPT YOU.
SO INSTEAD IS A QUORUM AND THEN
CONTINUE -- BUT FOR RIGHT NOW --
AS YOU KNOW IN SENATE'S.
PUBLIC SAFETY IS SOMETIMES.
DIFFICULT TO GET A QUORUM
[inaudible]
SO -- WE HAVE THREE FOUR MEMBERS
HERE WHEN YOU.
READ SHY IS NEED ONE MORE.
SO WHENEVER YOU'RE READY YOU MAY
BEGIN YOUR ITEM NUMBER TWO SB
ONE FOUR FIVE SEX OFFENDERS
REGISTRATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WANT TO THANK YOU --
YOU AND YOUR CREW SUFFER WORKING
WITH US WE ARE HAPPY TO ACCEPT
THE AMENDMENTS THEY CAME OUT OF
WORK.
WORK THEM OUT AFTER THE
COMMITTEE -- AND NOW SAYS.
AND THOSE ARE AMENDMENTS WILL
DELETE -- THE THE PROVISION IN
THE BILL RELATING TO JESSICA'S
LAW -- AND REMOVE THAT ENTIRELY --
FROM THE BILL -- I'LL BE HONEST
THAT ARE -- THAT AMENDMENT --
NEVER SHOULD HAVE GONE AND IN
THE SENATE AND I APOLOGIZE TO
PEOPLE WHO WERE UNDERSTANDABLY
CONCERNED ABOUT AND I'M HAPPY TO
REMOVE IT -- JESSICA'S LAW WHICH
AYE OPPOSED -- IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND NOTHING
FROM JESSICA'S Là EVER SORT OF
GONE IN THIS THAT'LL BE REMOVED
IN ITS ENTIRELY I SAY THIS JUST
TO BE CLEAR WITH MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC -- SO COLLEAGUES.
SENATE BILL -- ONE FORTY FIVE
PUTS AN END TO A SIGNIFICANT --
DISCRIMINATION AND IRRATIONALITY --
IN CALIFORNIA AS A SEX OFFENDER
REGISTRY AS IT RELATES -- TO
YOUNG PEOPLE.
CURRENTLY AND THIS IS THE
CURRENT STRUCTURE IN THE LAW --
IF A IF STATUTORY RAPE OCCURS IN
THIS BILL DOES NOT IN ANY WAY
CHANGE.
WHAT'S A CRIME OR WHAT'S NOT A
CRIME OR WHAT'S THE PUNISHMENT
FOR CRIMES ONLY ABOUT WHO.
MUST GO ON THE REGISTRY IN WHO --
A JUDGE MAY KEEP OFF.
I'M CURRENTLY IF I STATURE
RIPPER KERR'S AND THE YOUNGER
PERSON AT AGE.
FOURTEEN TO SEVENTEEN THE OLDER
PERSON -- IS WITHIN TEN YEARS NO
MORE THAN TEN YEARS OLDER -- IF
IT IS -- VAGINAL PENILE
INTERCOURSE -- THE JUDGE HAS THE
DISCRETION WHETHER TO PUT THE
PERSON ON THE REGISTRY OR NOT
BUT THE PERSON ON THE REGISTRY
BASED ON THE FACTS.
OF THE CASE OVER EXAMPLE AN
EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD.
HAVING -- INTERCOURSE WITH HIS
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD GIRLFRIEND --
IS PROBABLY NOT VERY LIKELY TO
BE PUT ON THE REGISTRY TWENTY
FOUR YEAR OLD HAVING SEX WITH A
FOURTEEN YEAR OLD IS PROBABLY
GOING TO BE MORE LIKELY TO BE
PUT ON ON HOWEVER.
ON FOR EVERY OTHER FORM OF
INTERCOURSE.
A JUDGE IS MANDATED TO PUT THE
PERSON ON THE REGISTRY -- CANNOT
TAKE ANY OF THE FACTS OF THE
CASE INTO A CAL HAS NO
DISCRETION.
I THE REASON FOR THIS
DISTINCTION WHICH IS BOTH
DISCRIMINATORY AND IRRATIONAL IS
BECAUSE ON THE SEX OFFENDER
REGISTRY WAS CREATED IN NINETEEN
FORTIES -- THE ONLY LEGAL FORM
OF INTERCOURSE WAS VAGINAL PL
INTERCOURSE EVERYTHINGELSE WAS
BANNED -- SO WE HAVE THIS
BASICALLY LEFT OVER FROM THE
NINETEEN FORTIES -- AND THE
PROBLEM WITH THAT -- IS IT WHAT
IT MEANS.
IS THAT -- YOU HAVE
IRRATIONALITY SO THE EIGHTEEN
YEAR OLD HAS VAGINAL INTERCOURSE
OF THE SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD
GIRLFRIEND THE JUDGE DOESN'T
HAVE TO PUT HIM ON THE REGISTRY.
BUT IF SHE PERFORMS ORAL SEX ON
HIM -- I'M SORRY TO BE EXPLICIT
BUT THAT'S WHAT SIX HUNDRED
STREET ABOUT.
SHE PERFORMS ORAL SEX ON HIM THE
JUDGE MUST PUT HIM ON THE
REGISTRY THAT IS BEYOND
IRRATIONAL -- AND THE BILL ALSO
OR EXCUSE ME THAT THIS STATE OF
THE LAW ALSO CREATES A
SIGNIFICANT DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST LGBT.
YOUNG PEOPLE -- WHO ARE MUCH
LESS LIKELY TO BE ABLE TO ENGAGE
AND -- VAGINAL PENILE
INTERCOURSE -- AND SO WE ARE
SEEING -- YOUNG LGBT PEOPLE WHO
WERE BEING FORCED ON THE SEX
OFFENDER REGISTRY IN SITUATIONS
WHERE THERE ARE NINE LGBT --
COUNTERPARTS WOULD NOT BE FORCED
ONTO THE REGISTRY -- AND SO WHAT
SB ONE FORTY FIVE DOES -- IS IT
TREATS ALL FORMS OF INTERCOURSE
EXACTLY THE SAME WAY THAT WE
CURRENTLY THREE UNDER THE LAW --
VAGINAL INTERCOURSE I DOES NOT
CREATE ANY KIND OF NEW STRUCTURE
OR NEW TEST IT JUST SAYS LET'S
TREAT ALL FORMS OF INTERCOURSE
THE SAME WAY THAT WE CURRENTLY
TREAT.
VAGINAL INTERCOURSE -- I WILL
NOTE -- AND I SAID THIS AND
SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY -- TO THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT STRUCK
DOWN THIS -- THE STATION AS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL AS AN EQUAL
PROTECTION VIOLATION -- IN THE
HAWKS SIRE CASE IN TWO THOUSAND
AND SIX THAT WAS THE CORRECT
RULING -- AND UNDER THE RULING I
WOULD NOT HAVE NEEDED TO BE HERE
TODAY -- IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT --
I THINK SHAMEFULLY OVERTURNED --
IT'S TWO THOUSAND SIX RULING AND
SAID THAT IT WAS OKAY TO HAVE
THIS DISCRIMINATION -- THIS.
ARE BILL AND I KNOW THE CHAIR
HAS ALSO WORKED ON THIS ISSUE
AND I THANK YOU FOR THAT.
OUR WILL AND THIS IS
DISCRIMINATION ONCE AND FOR ALL
AND THIS ORIGINALITY -- AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE I
WITH ME TODAY -- IS OUT --
DENTAL SADO FROM THE LOS ANGELES
DA'S OFFICE -- ONE OF OUR
SPONSORS I WILL NOTE THAT BOTH
THE THE LA DA IS IS ONE OF OUR
SPONSORS ALONG WITH THE QUALITY
CALIFORNIA.
I'M THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION AND THE
POLICE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION BOTH A
SUPPORT THE BILL.
I IN ADDITION JANET NEARLY ON A
LAWYER WHO SPECIALIZES IN THE
SEX OFFENDER REGISTRY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
YES YOU MAY BEGIN.
MR MEMBERS SAMPLES OUT ON BEHALF
OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
PLEASE SPONSOR SB ONE FORTY FIVE
ALONG WITH THAT QUALITY
CALIFORNIA.
AS A SENATOR POINTED OUT FOR THE
BETTER PART OF A DECADE -- THE
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA.
THE CULTURE OFFENSES VOLUNTARY --
SEX ACTS BETWEEN AN ADULT AND A
MINOR -- WITHIN TEN YEARS OF AGE
ONE ANOTHER -- WE'RE NOT RICH
FULL OFFENSE HOWEVER IN THE
JOHNSON DECISION THE SUPREME
COURT DID NOTE THAT THERE WAS A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN STATUTORY
RAPE AND THESE OTHER ACTS.
THE DIFFERENCE IS THAT STATUTORY
RAPE CAN RESULT IN PREGNANCY AND
THAT'S WHERE THEY LEFT IT.
WHAT THE COURT FAILED TO NOTE
THOUGH IS THAT?
IN A CRIMINAL ACT.
IF A PREGNANCY A CURSE PREGNANCY
IS CONSIDERED TO BE A SERIOUS
BODILY INJURY.
THEREFORE THE COURT WAS SAYING.
EVEN THOUGH STATUTORY RAPE THAT
RESULTS IN PREGNANCY IS A MORE
SERIOUS OFFENSE WE'RE GONNA
TREATED MORE LENIENTLY.
THAT IS IRRATIONAL BOTH FROM A
POLICY STANDPOINT AND FROM AN
EQUAL PROTECTION STANDPOINT
WHICH IS WHY WE'RE SPONSORING SB --
ONE FORTY FIVE I WOULD NOTE THAT
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY.
ATTORNEY GENERAL CITY ATTORNEY'S
STILL HAVE ALL OF THEIR CHARGING
DISCRETION. TO YOU CHARGE
APPROPRIATELY ACTS THAT ARE NOT
VOLUNTARY NOT CONSENSUAL -- ALSO
UNDER EXISTING LAW UNDER PENAL
CODE SECTION TO NINETY POINT
ZERO ZERO SIX THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY THE COURTS HAVE THE
DISCRETION TO SEEK REGISTRATION
FOR ANY OFFENSE.
THAT DOES NOT CHANGE UNDER SB
ONE FORTY FIVE AS A SENATOR
NOTED IF WE HAVE INSTANCES WITH
A A TWENTY FIVE YEAR OLD --
HAVING RELATIONS WITH A FIFTEEN
YEAR OLD THOSE CASES ARE GOING
TO BE LOOKED AT AND SEEK
REGISTRATION WE CURRENTLY DO
THAT.
DAY IN LA THAT IT WILL NOT
CHANGE -- I WILL ALSO NOTE THAT
THE WHOLE PURPOSE OF THE
REGISTRY.
IS TO ACT AS AN INVESTIGATORY
TOOL WHEN THERE ARE NEW SEX
CRIMES THAT OCCUR WE DON'T HAVE
SUSPECTS.
IT'S ALSO SUPPOSED TO BE A TOOL
TO USE TO KEEP TRACK OF
PREDATORY OFFENDERS.
IN THESE CASES.
THEY'RE THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
COMMIT THESE OFFENSES.
DON'T COMMITTEES OTHER TYPES OF
CRIMES THAT'S ONE TWO ONE
OFFENDERS UNDER OUR SEX OFFENDER
REGISTRATION STATUTE.
THERE'S NO STRANGER YOU KNOW
CRIMES INVOLVED IN HERE THEY ARE
NOT PREDATORY.
THEY DON'T THE THE SOLVE ANY NEW
CRIMES SO EVEN INCLUDING THESE
PEOPLE ON THE REGISTRY AND JUST
AS A GENERAL PRINCIPLE.
DOES NOT COMPLY WITH WHAT THE
PURPOSE OF OUR REGISTRY IS.
AND THE COURTS HAVE COMPLETELY
TOLD.
GROUPS COULD REPORTEDLY TOLD US --
THAT IF WE DO NOT USE THE
REGISTRY FOR ITS INTENDED
PURPOSE THEY WOULD STRIKE IT
DOWN.
PASSING THIS BILL WILL NOT ONLY
DO THE RIGHT THING COULD HELP
PRESERVE OUR EXISTING REGISTER.
THANK YOU.
YES MA'AM.
GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS JANET NEARLY I AM A
LEGAL CONSULTANT TO CAL CASA
CALIFORNIA COALITION AGAINST
SEXUAL ASSAULT.
PART OF THE DATA BEFORE -- MY
RETIREMENT I REPRESENTED THE
CALIFORNIA SEX OFFENDER REGISTRY
AS THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL
FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS AND I
CHAIRED THE CALIFORNIA STATE
COMMITTEE ON SEX AND A RISK
ASSESSMENT. FOR TEN YEARS.
ON AND IN MY CAPACITY THERE I
WROTE MANY OF THE LAWS IN
CALIFORNIA PERTAINING TO THE
REGISTRATION MANAGEMENT AND
ASSESSMENT OF SEX OFFENDERS.
IN MY OPINION THIS CHANGE IN THE
REGISTRY LAW IS LONG OVERDUE.
THE PURPOSE OF OUR REGISTRY.
IS TO HELP LAW ENFORCEMENT.
CATCH PEOPLE WHO IT MAKE.
HAVE HAVE HAVE MADE.
UP A GROUP REGIS OFFENSES
AGAINST STRANGER VICTIMS BUT THE
GROUP OF PEOPLE THAT THIS BILL
CONCERNS HAVE NOT ATTACKED
STRANGERS.
THESE PEOPLE ARE VERY LOW RISK
OFFENDERS.
AND I'M LIKELY TO COMMIT A
SECOND OFFENSE AT ALL ONCE
THEY'VE BEEN CAUGHT AND
SANCTIONED FOR THE OFFENSE THAT
THEY COMMITTED IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
BUT IF THEY DO RE OFFEND IT IS
HIGHLY UNLIKELY IT WILL BE THE
TYPE OF STRANGER OFFENSE THAT
REQUIRES THEM TO BE IN THE
REGISTRY.
SO PUTTING PEOPLE IN THE
REGISTRY WHO REALLY AREN'T GOING
TO HELP LAW ENFORCEMENT SOLVE
STRANGER PERPETRATED CRIMES.
ACTUALLY MAKES IT HARDER FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO DO THEIR JOB
WHICH IS SOLVING THOSE TYPES OF
CASES -- FOR THOSE REASONS I
SUPPORT SENATE BILL ONE FOUR
FIVE AND I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MARK -- GEORGE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT
[inaudible]
WHO?
IT'S NOT YOUR HERNANDEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION CALL
OFFENSE ATTORNEYS IN SUPPORT.
GEN MEMBERS JONATHON FELDMAN ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
TAMMY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
COLIN QUICK BAY AREA STERN
ACTIVISTS IN SUPPORT.
ROGER HUNNICUTT BUSINESSMAN FROM
MODESTO STRONGLY SUPPORT.
CHANCE OVERSTAYING ALLIANCE FOR
CONSTITUTIONAL SEX SENSE LAWS IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CHELSEA FERAL FROM LOS ANGELES
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
RUSSELL ATKINSON SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS RICHARD NICHOLAS AND
I SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
NAME IS JOSHUA CLUB AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THEIR MIND SACRAMENTO SPORT AND
SPILL.
I'M RENTAL OFFERED FROM
SACRAMENTO AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
WILLIAM THE REALIST LIGHT HOUSE
NIGHT CONSULTING A SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
MICHAEL MATANYA FROM ACROSS
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT THE BILL.
ELIZABETH FREEZE FROM PASADENA
CALIFORNIA.
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL
[inaudible]
MAYBE PALMER.
FROM CALIFORNIA -- ORANGE COUNTY
SUPPORT THIS WAY.
FRANK ARNETT MARINO VALLEY I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
SHERRI HER -- SACRAMENTO MOTHER
ABUSE SURVIVOR AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
KERRY POSEY REAL IN THE
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
FRANCIS POSEY SACRAMENTO I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
BLESSED LOW ZAINAL SAN MATEO
COUNTY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
DAVE HOW GAY MALE I SUPPORT SB
ONE FORTY FIVE ON THE ACCOUNT.
MANY HAD CALIFORNIA CIVIL
RETREAT THE STUFF SORRY GOT A
LITTLE TONGUE TIED CIVIL
LIBERTIES ADVOCACY IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
JANICE BALLOU TO EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE ALLIANCE FOR
CONSTITUTIONAL SEX OFFENSE FLAWS
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING MR TERM MEMBERS
LIKE A DOCTOR OFF ON BEHALF OF
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
INCREDIBLY FROM CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING I'M DAN FROM EL
DORADO COUNTY AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'M DAVID HERON FROM EL DORADO
COUNTY I URGE YOU TO STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MARY HARRON ELDORADO COUNTY
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING.
I WILL BE BRIEF AND I FEEL QUITE
LONELY UP HERE -- MY NAME IS
HEIDI FELDSTEIN.
AND I'M HERE FROM LOS ANGELES
AND I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME I
FEEL -- AS THOUGH I HAD TO SPEAK
UP ON BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY
BECAUSE I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
EQUAL PROTECTION UNDER THE LAW.
I DON'T THINK THERE SHOULD BE A
DISTINCTION.
AND HOW THE LAW TREATS DIFFERENT
KINDS OF SEXUAL ACTIVITY.
WHETHER IT BE MINOR OR MAJOR
HERE IS MY PROBLEM.
EVEN IF THIS BILL PASSES THERE
ARE TWO AREAS WHERE WE DO NOT
HAVE EQUAL PROTECTION UNDER THE
LAW.
STATUTORY RAPE UNDER TO SIXTY
ONE POINT FIVE STILL HAS A ROMEO
AND JULIET CLAUSE.
WHERE? TWO SIXTY ONE POINT FIVE
WHICH IS SEXUAL INTERCOURSE
VAGINAL PENILE INTERCOURSE.
STILL HAS WHAT'S CALLED A ROMEO
AND JULIET CLOCKS.
MINERS WITHIN THREE YEARS OF ONE
ANOTHER.
ARE NOT GUILTY OF STATUTORY RAPE
UNDER TO SIXTY ONE POINT FIVE
IT'S STE THERE'S A DISTINCTION
BETWEEN A MISDEMEANOR AND FELONY.
THAT DOES NOT CARRY OVER FOR
ANAL INTERCOURSE ORAL COPULATION
OR PENETRATION WITH AN OBJECT
OTHER THAN A **** AND AGAIN I'M
SORRY TO BE SO BLUNT BUT THE
PENAL CODE IS THAT BLUNT.
OKAY.
SOMETIMES I AM BUT NOT HERE --
SO THERE IS STILL NOT EQUAL
PROTECTION UNDER THE LAW SO THIS
IS NOT REALLY ABOUT EQUAL
PROTECTION.
THE SECOND THING IS THAT
STATUTORY RAPE.
DISCRETION IS NOT GIVEN TO THE
JUDGE IRRESPECTIVE OF THE AGE
DIFFERENCE.
SHE COULD HAVE A FIFTY YEAR OLD
MAN.
WITH A FOURTEEN YEAR OLD GIRL.
AND REGISTRATION IS NOT REQUIRED.
SO AS FAR AS I AM CONCERNED THIS
BILL IS FLAWED.
IT ISN'T ABOUT EQUAL PROTECTION.
BECAUSE I'M HERE BECAUSE OF
EQUAL PROTECTION FOR THE MINERS.
I DON'T CARE ABOUT EQUAL
PROTECTION FOR THE ADULTS.
WHO ENGAGE IN SEXUAL ACTIVITY
WITH OUR FOURTEEN TO SEVENTEEN
YEAR OLDS?
I THINK THE DA'S ATTORNEYS
OFFICESCORRECT.
OKAY IF SOMEONE IS FOURTEEN OR
UNDER WE HAVE OTHER AREAS OF THE
LAW WITH WHICH TO PROTECT THEM.
AND TO REGISTER THEM I THINK THE
DA'S ATTORNEY IS WRONG.
IN SAYING THAT THIS REGISTER IS
ONLY FOR USE BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
OUR PARENTS.
USED THIS REGISTERED TO PROTECT
OUR COMMUNITIES FOURTEEN TO
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS ARE THE MOST
HEAVILY TRAFFICKED HUMANBEINGS
IN THIS COUNTRY WITH JEFFREY
EPSTEIN IN THE NEWS EVERY DAY
WITH THE NEWS COMING OUT ABOUT
SIXTEEN YEAR OLD BOYS ANNOUNCING.
THAT THEY BASICALLY RAPED A
SIXTEEN YEAR OLD GIRL AND A
JUDGE SAYING THE BECAUSE THEY
CAME FROM A GOOD FAMILY AND GOT
GOOD GRADES.
THEY'RE GOING TO GET LEFT OFF
THE HOOK.
THIS IS THE WRONG TIME. TO BE
PASSING THIS KIND OF A BILL THAT
IS CANDIDLY BEING PERCEIVED BY
PRIVATE CITIZENS LIKE ME.
AS EXPOSING OUR DAUGHTERS TO
WHAT'S KNOWN AS THE TRIPLE
CHERRY IN HUMAN TRAFFICKING
PLEASE I URGE YOU.
FIND A WAY TO GIVE EQUAL
PROTECTION TO OUR MINERS.
YES CRIMINALIZE AND REGISTER ALL
KINDS OF SEXUAL ACTIVITY AT THE
SAME RATE BUT DO IT IN A WAY
OTHER THAN DECLARING OPEN SEASON
ON OUR TEENAGERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS [inaudible]
MR QUIRK.
I'M LET'S SEE WOULD YOU --
ESTABLISH CORN SO I CAN MOVE THE
BALL.
THE STEPS OF CORN.
JONES SAWYER HERE LACKEY.
BARRICADE HAND.
DEEP.
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
QUIRK YOUR SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WICKS [inaudible]
FORMS PRESIDENT.
MOVE THE BELL [inaudible]
THE YOU HAVE A QUESTION.
THE RK THREE JUST I'M CENTER WE
ARE CAN YOU CLARIFY THE
AMENDMENT THE YOU MENTIONED THE
BEGINNING I WAS TRYING.
TO GET A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT
JUSTICE LA SURE ON AND THIS IS
AYE.
THIS IS OF I'VE BEEN A PROCESS
BETWEEN US AND LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL AND WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF IN BOTH HOUSES
FOR WORKING WITH US.
ON THEIR IT HAS TO DO WITH
JESSICA'S LAW THAT WAS PASSED.
TWELVE FOURTEEN YEARS AGO THE
BASICALLY PROVIDED THAT -- SEX
OFFENDERS CAN'T LIVE IN CERTAIN
AREAS WITHIN CERTAIN DISTANCE OF
A PARK SCHOOL IT CETERA -- IT'S
BEEN A LOT OF IT'S BEEN STRUCK
DOWN AS UNCONSTITUTIONAL BECAUSE
IT EFFECTIVELY MADE IT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR SEX OFFENDERS IN
MANY CITIES TO LIVE ANYWHERE.
ON SO FOR SOME IN THE
HOMELESSNESS IN WHICH OF COURSE
CAUSES PEOPLE -- TO BE MORE
LIKELY TO REOFFEND IF THEY DON'T
PLACE TO LOOK -- SO THE WE THERE
WAS SOME LANGUAGE OF WE HAVE
PLAYED AND ABOUT EVEN IF PEOPLE
WERE NOT ON THE REGISTRY BUT
COMMITTED THE OFFENSES THEY
WOULD HAVE TO COMPLY WITH
CERTAIN ASPECTS OF JESSICA'S LAW --
WE SHOULD I SHOULD NEVER HAVE
GONE INTO THE BILL AND SO WE'RE
TAKING IT OUT OF SOMEONE'S ON
THE SEX OFFENDER REGISTRY --
THEY'RE NOT BOUND BY JESSICA'S
LAW IT ONLY AFFECTS THE THE
ALLEGATION THE CRIMES THAT
YOU'RE ADDRESSING HERE YEAH SO
IT.
YES OKAY YEAH EXACTLY EXACTLY
DOESN'T CHANGE ANYTHING ELSE
ABOUT US BECAUSE ALL THE COURTS
ARE HANDLING NOT.
AND STRUCK DOWN QUITE A FEW
ASPECTS OF JESSICA'S LAW BUT AS
FOR THESE OFFENSES THAT ONLY FOR
PEOPLE RIGHT ONLY FOR THESE
OFFENSES AND FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
NOT ON REGISTER ON THE REGISTER
WE'RE NOT CHANGING ANYTHING
ABOUT JESSICA ALL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUICK THIS
COME OUT OF THANK YOU -- SENATOR
WIENER SO CAN YOU SORT OF
RESPOND I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE
GONNA DO THIS IN YOUR CLOTHES OR
NOT BUT COULD YOU ALL RESPOND TO
SOME OF THE CONCERNS RAISED BY
THE OPPOSITION I THINK THE BILL
DOESN'T SPECIFY.
IT'S FOR LGBT Q. ONLY AND SO AS
A RESULT.
THERE.
COULD BE SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE LANGUAGE TO SUGGEST YOU KNOW
ESPECIALLY SINCE YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT MINERS.
THAT -- IT WILL KIND OF OPEN A
DOOR FOR FOLKS TO ENGAGE IN
PREDATORY BEHAVIOR SO.
I'M HAPPY TO RESPOND -- THE
FIRST PART OF WHAT THE OPPONENTS
SAID -- I THOUGHT SHE WAS
ACTUALLY SPEAKING AND AND AWAY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL --
BECAUSE SHE POINTED THERE ARE
MANY OTHER THERE ARE OTHER AREAS
DISCRIMINATION IN THE JUST THE
DEFINITION OF STATUTORY RAPE --
DISCRIMINATES AGAINST -- LGBT.
YOUNG PEOPLE.
SO THAT'S BUT YOU CAN'T SOLVE
EVERYTHING ON ONE BILL -- THE
THE OPPONENT THE IDEA THAT THIS
BILL.
QUOTE ON QUOTE CREATES OPENS THE
SEASON OR WHATEVER SHE HOWEVER
SHE PHRASE -- ON PREYING ON
TEENAGERS -- IS -- I I COULD NOT
DISAGREE WITH THAT MORE THIS
BILL DOES NOT CHANGE WHAT'S A
CRIME OR WHAT IS IT A CRIME.
IT DOESN'T CHANGE WHAT THE WHAT
THE PUNISHMENT IS FOR ANY CRIME
THAT'S ALL GOING TO BE THE SAME.
I A IF THIS PASSES ON JANUARY
FIRST AS IT IS TODAY -- SO THE
THE THE DEFINITION OF A CRIME
THE PUNISHMENT FOR THE CRIME.
DOESN'T CHANGE -- WHAT THIS BILL
DOES PROVIDE IS IT GIVES JUDGES?
DISCRETION. TO THE SIDE IF
SOMEONE SHOULD BE ON THE
REGISTER OR NOT.
AT ALL WE ARE SAYING IS THAT AND
WE TALK ABOUT YOUR JEFFREY
OBSCENE OR WHATEVER WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT LET'S TALK ABOUT YOU
KNOW TEENAGE GIRLS WHO WERE --
ABUSED.
RIGHT TODAY [inaudible]
TODAY.
IF THAT INTERCOURSE AGAIN
DISCIPLINE TWELVE YEARS SINCE
I'VE SEEN AS FAR OLDER THAN THAT --
TODAY.
I IF IT'S VAGINAL INTERCOURSE
AND IT'S FOURTEEN TO SEVENTEEN
YEAR OLD THE OLDER PERSON IF
WITHIN TEN YEARS TO THAT.
THE JUDGE HAS DISCRETION TO
EITHER PUT THE PERSON ON OR NOT
BUT THE PERSON ON ALL WE'RE
SAYING IS THAT OTHER FORMS OF
INTERCOURSE.
SHOULD BE TREATED EXACTLY THE
SAME AS WE CURRENTLY AND FOR
MANY YEARS HAVE TREATED VAGINAL
INTERCOURSE WHY ON EARTH ARE WE
GONNA SAY.
OKAY IF YOU HAVE BAD JOURNAL IF
THE TWENTY YEAR OLD HAS VAGINAL
INTERCOURSE WITH THE SIXTEEN
YEAR OLD WE'RE GOING TO DECIDE
WHETHER OR NOT TO PUT.
HIM ON THE REGISTRY.
BUT IF SHE PERFORMED ORAL SEX ON
HIM.
AUTOMATIC BECAUSE THAT'S BECAUSE
ORAL SEX IS SOMEHOW WORSE THAN
VAGINAL INTERCOURSE I MEAN ON
ITS FACE WHEN YOU ACTUALLY LOOK
AT WHATTHE LAW DOES.
IT'S IT'S COMPLETELY IRRATIONAL --
AND AT IN ADDITION TO HAVING A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT.
ON LGBT USE SO THIS WILL NOT
DEPRIVED JUDGES OF THE ABILITY
SO YOU KNOW WHAT.
OKAY YOU'RE JUST YOU'RE HAVING
SEX WITH YOUR GIRLFRIEND WHO'S
ELEVEN MONTHS YOUNGER THAN THAN
YOU I'M NOT PUTTING YOU ON THE
REGISTRY.
YOU ARE PRAYING ON A FOURTEEN
YEAR OLD I'M PUTTING YOU ON THE
REGISTRY -- SO WE WE STILL GIVE
THE JUDGES ALL THE TOOLS THEY
NEED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND I IS
THAT YOUR CLOSER.
I I JUST WANT TO YOU KNOW THE
THIS THIS IS A HARD TOPIC --
ANYTIME YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
THESE ISSUES IT'S REALLY HARD --
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE WHO ARE WHO ARE ABUSING
AND PREYING.
ON PEOPLE AND YOUNG PEOPLE THAT
THEY ARE PUNISHED.
AND THAT WE USE ALL THE TOOLS
THAT WE CAN USE -- BY.
WAY THOUGH THOSE SCOPE OF THE
REGISTER RIGHT NOW.
IS PUTTING PEOPLE ON TO THE
REGISTRY SHOULD NOT BE ON THE
REGISTRY.
AND WE ARE TELLING JUDGES YOU'RE
NOT EVEN GOING TO HAVE THE
ABILITY. TO EXERCISE ANY
DISCRETION.
I'M GOING ON TO THE REGISTRY --
CAN HELP TRUST RACK SOMEONE'S
LIFE THIS IS A BIG DEAL AT ALL
WE'RE SAYING IS LET'S.
TREAT EVERYTHING THE WAY WE
CURRENTLY CHIU BASIL INTERCOURSE.
AND LET'S GIVE THE JUDGES SOME
DISCRETION I ASK FOR A VOTE.
IN AN HOUR THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AS SOMEONE
ADDED AB [inaudible] SIXTEEN
FORTY BACK IN -- TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN WHICH WE LOST
ON THE FOR THE ASSEMBLY -- AS A
AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
WHO IS NO LONGER HERE?
I WILL MENTION HIS NAME BECAUSE
HE RAN FOR GOVERNOR BUT I'M NOT
GONNA MATCHES NAY -- GOT UP AND
ASKED ME TO NAME EVERY SEX ACT
THAT WAS INVOLVED ON THE FLOOR
WITH CHILDREN [inaudible]
INDIA.
AND A GALLERY WHICH I REFUSED TO
DO -- IS INAPPROPRIATE -- ONE I
COMMEND YOU.
IT IS A HARD TOPIC.
AND YOUR ELOQUENT IN EXPLAINING.
ALL OF THE AXE IN IN IN A WAY
THAT WAS RESPECTFUL AND I WISH I
HAD THAT SKILL BACK IN -- TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN FOURTEEN BUT
YOU STILL HAVE PEOPLE COME UP
AND SO I I'M RECOMMENDED AYE
VOTE AND I WILL ALSO RECOMMENDED
YOU'D SPEND SOME TIME.
WITH MEMBERS THAT.
ARE AFFECTED BY KIND OF THE
HYSTERIA COME FROM THIS.
AND I THINK WAS JUST.
JACKIE LACEY AND IDEAS.
THE KELLY COUNTY -- D. A. AND I
WERE THE ONLY ONES PUSHING. FOR
THIS AND AND SOME OTHERS AND IS
IT IS DIFFICULT AND SO I CAN SEE
YOU HAVE.
A STRONG COALITION -- I FELT
LIKE I WAS BY MYSELF ALLIES
TIMES IN.
MY FRIEND HERE AND I WE'RE
SITTING ALONE A LOT OF TIMES --
AND SO I I HOPE WE GET THIS THIS
DONE THIS TIME BECAUSE IT'S
IMPORTANT ONE AND TWO IT'S
ALMOST LIKE TELLING PEOPLE WE
NEED TO GO BACK TO PHONE BOOKS
AGAIN -- DISS TWO THOUSAND WE
NEED TO MOVE ON AND WE NEED TO
NEW DEAL WITH THE NEW NORMAL --
SURVIVE.
RECOMMEND I GO INTO.
ON SB ONE FORTY FIVE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER.
CHEN SIR I LACKEY.
LACKEY NO BARRICADE HAD
BARRICADE HAD I DEEP
[inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK.
QUIRK I SANTIAGO.
WICKS WICKS I THANK YOU THE
MEASURE PASSES.
THANK YOU.
BUY DIRECT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
SO WE'LL HAVE A COUPLE
ANNOUNCEMENTS -- BOB CALENDAR.
ABOUT ITEM NUMBER ONE SB FIFTY
FIVE JACKSON PULLED BY AUTHOR.
ITEM NUMBER SIX SB THREE SIX
ZERO HILL.
PULLED BY AUTHOR.
NOT A PROPOSED CONSENT CALENDAR.
SO LET ME TELL YOU WHICH YOU
JUST.
PROVED AND SECONDED.
ITEM NUMBER THREE SB THREE SIX
NINE BRADFORD WRONGFUL
CONVICTIONS WE HAVE A MOTION.
THREE TO SIX NINE I'M SORRY --
EIGHT THANK YOU.
I HAVEN'T HAD MY COFFEE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SB TWO SIXTY
NINE JONES SAWYER -- JONES
SAWYER HI LACKEY LACKEY AYE
BARRICADE HAN.
HE HAD I DEEP [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE KAMLAGER-DOVE I
QUIRK QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
WICKS.
WICKS I OKAY THAT CALENDARS ARE
CONSENT COUNTERS ADOPTED WE'RE
LOOKING FOR SENATOR RUBIO.
SENATOR PORTANTINO.
SENATOR BELLOW [inaudible]
SENATOR MITCHELL.
AND IN SENATOR WAYS -- BOB ABOUT
[inaudible]
THERE -- THE FIRST
.
THE ANSWER. TO MAYBE IT WAS LIKE
MAYBE A COMPRESSED [inaudible]
YEAH YEAH -- YEAH [inaudible]
PEOPLE HAVE
BURKE CENTER NUMBERS
HERE SO WE WILL TAKE YOU NOW
SINCE THERE ARE NO OTHER
SENATORS.
JUST AN FYI TO THE OTHER
SHE MISSED NUMBER JUST SIGNED IN
AND HE'S NOW GETTING READY TO
PRESENT.
SINCE THERE ARE NO OTHER
SENATORS HERE THAT WERE BEFORE
HIM [inaudible]
YEAH.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY MISTER.
AND MEMBERS ARE FOR YOU YEAH SB
FOR THE TIME [inaudible]
THE BILL -- THIS IS A BILL THAT
LAYS THE FORM OVERSIGHT ON LONG
WORKING ON THIS LIST AND LIVE.
RUSSIAN.
WITH.
AND I WORK WITH -- LAW.
UNDER EXISTING LAW -- USUALLY
FONG RISING WATER. FOR CERTAIN
SPECIFIED CRIMES -- YOU CAN'T
USE THE INFORMATION OTHER
SERIOUS FELONIES COULD BE USED
IN A PROSECUTION.
OF THOSE WHOSE INFORMATION IS IS
COLLECTED BY A WIRE TAP -- I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE COMMITTEE
HAS AMENDMENTS AND WHILE WE
BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD --
INCLUDE ALL.
SIXTEEN A SERIOUS OFFENSES I
UNDERSTAND THE COMMITTEE'S
CONCERNS AND AND I'M WILLING TO
ACCEPT THOSE AMENDMENTS HERE TO
TESTIFY IS DAN -- FELICITY
ALTHOUGH FROM THE LOS ANGELES
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND
MARK BURNLEY.
OF ASSISTANT HEAD DEPUTY A MAJOR
NARCOTICS DIVISION.
YES MISTER FIELDS I KNOW.
SHERMAN MEMBERS -- DEVILS OUT ON
BEHALF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE WE
ARE PLEASED TO SPONSOR -- CENTER
ON BIRDS BILL -- AS A SENATOR
INDICATED UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW
WE ARE ONLY ALLOWED TO OBTAIN
WIRETAPS FOR CERTAIN SPECIFIED
TYPES OF CRIMES BASICALLY MAJOR
NARCOTICS OFFENSES.
MURDERS GANG CRIMES -- HUMAN
TRAFFICKING --WEAPONS OF MASS
DESTRUCTION.
HOWEVER WHILE WERE INVESTIGATING
THOSE CRIMES.
WE ARE LISTENING IN ON THE
INTERCEPT MEDICATIONS.
AND WE OFTEN -- WE'LL HEAR
INDIVIDUALS START TALKING ABOUT
OTHER CRIMES THEY'VE COMMITTED
THESE ARE.
YOU KNOW THESE PEOPLE ARE
CRIMINALS THEY COMMIT OTHER
CRIMES -- UNDER EXISTING LAW IF
AN INDIVIDUAL -- TALK ABOUT
COMMITTING A VIOLENT FELONY.
IF WE GET THE PERMISSION OF THE
COURT WE CAN USE THAT STATEMENT
REGARDING THE VIOLENT FELONY
AGAINST THAT.
HOWEVER IF WE HEAR EVIDENCE OF
ANYTHING OTHER THAN A VIOLENT
FELONY OR ONE OF THE PREDICATE
OFFENSES.
WE ARE NOT ALLOWED TO USE THAT
INFORMATION AGAINST INDIVIDUAL
AT ANY TIME -- AS AMENDED SP
FOUR THIRTY NINE WOULD MAKE
WOULD ADD TWO NEW OFFENSIVES.
GUN VIOLENCE IS A SERIOUS CRIME
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND OBVIOUSLY IF WE HEAR
SOMEBODY WHO'S TALKING ABOUT
PLANTING A DESTRUCTIVE DEVICE A
BALL -- IN YOU KNOW FOR EXAMPLE
PUBLIC BUILDING OF THESE ARE
VERY SERIOUS CRIMES AND WE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO USE THAT
INFORMATION.
IN A CRIMINAL PROSECUTION SO
LONG AS THE COURT APPROVED THE
USE OF THAT INFORMATION -- THIS
BILL I SAY IT IS IT'S A MORE
NARROW THEN -- HAS INTRODUCED
HOWEVER WE STILL THINK THAT IT
IS AN IMPORTANT BILL --
ESPECIALLY FOR RBC QUE SE GUN
VIOLENCE AND BOMBINGS.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK THANK YOU THANKS A GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS MARK BURNLEY
I'M THE ASSISTANT HEAD DEPUTY OF
THE MAJOR COLLEGE DIVISION. FOR
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE MY DIVISION
HANDLES ALL OF THE WIRE TAPS IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AS FAR AS
PROCESSING THEM.
AND SENDING THEM TO THE COURT.
WHAT THIS BILL REALLY TALKS
ABOUT IS WHAT I CALL INCIDENTAL
INTERCEPTS AS MR FELLOWS ARE
JUST EXPLAINED?
WHY WERE UP ON A LAWFULLY
OBTAINED WIRE TAP WE FREQUENTLY
INTERCEPT OTHER CRIMES THAT THE
WIRE TAP WAS NOT OBTAIN?
FOR WITH THIS LEGISLATION WOULD
DO WOULD ALLOW THE USE OF THOSE
INTERCEPTS IN A CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION.
WHAT THIS LEGISLATION DOES NOT
DO IS IT DOES NOT EXPAND?
IN ANY WAY THE LIST OF
ENUMERATED OFFENSES FOR WHICH
YOU COULD INITIALLY OBTAIN A
WIRETAP SO THAT LIST WHICH IS IN
THE STATUTE DOES NOT GET
EXPANDED THIS ONLY.
WOULD APPLY TO INCIDENTAL
INTERCEPTS IT ALSO DOES NOT
CHANGE ANY OF THE PROTECTIONS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY IN THE
STATUTE -- WE WOULD HAVE TO
STILL MINIMIZE CONVERSATIONS AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY WE WOULD HAVE
TO SEEK JUDICIAL AUTHORIZATION.
IF WE WANTED TO USE THESE
INCIDENTAL INTERCEPTS IN ANY
MANNER.
AS A SENATOR JUST EXPLAINED.
WITH GUN VIOLENCE CURRENTLY IF
WE INTERCEPTED ANY CALLS
REGARDING GUNS THAT.
LAW ENFORCEMENT COULD USE THOSE
CALLS ONLY TO PREVENT THE
COMMISSION OF A PUBLIC OFFENSE
HOWEVER.
THE CONTENT OF THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WOULD NOT BE
ALLOWED TO BE USED TO PROSECUTE
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO HAD ACTUALLY
STONE THOSE FIREARMS.
AND I'M MORE THAN HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT ANYONE
MIGHT HAVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OF THE AREA.
JOHN OF THE FILM OF THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION WE DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS WITH REPORTING LANGUAGE
THAT WAS DRAFTED AND WE SENT TO
US FOR OF YOU LAST NIGHT BUT WE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK FOR THE
SENATE IS OFFICE AND THE
SPONSORS MOVING FORWARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MR QUIRK.
UP MOVE THE BELL -- THANK YOU
FOR TAKING THE AMENDMENTS -- WE
ALWAYS HAVE TO BALANCE --
PRIVACY.
AGAINST -- GETTING THE BAD GUYS.
AND I THINK THIS IS A VERY
AMBITIOUS -- LAW TO TAKE ON AS
ONE OF YOUR FIRST LAWS I APPLAUD
YOU FOR THAT AND COURSE I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU YES MISS CONNELLY DOVE --
YES I TOO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THE BILL SO THE HEAT I
WOULD LIKE FOR A TO GET A LITTLE
MORE CLARITY WITH THEM WHAT I
HEARD FROM THIS GENTLEMAN --
BECAUSE I THINK ONE OF THE
CONCERNS WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT WIRE TAPPING -- IS A SORT
OF AN INVASION OF PRIVACY AND
ONCE YOU HEAR SOMETHING.
YOU CAN'T ERASE THAT FROM YOUR
MEMORY AND SO THERE ARE SOME
CONCERNS -- THAT IT WILL SORT OF
CREATE AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO AN
END RUN AROUND -- THE LAW SO
THAT YOU CAN CATCH THE CRIMINAL --
BECAUSE YOU KNOW ONCE YOUR WIRE
TAPPING YOU GET INCIDENTAL
INFORMATION YOU SAY HEY THERE'S
ANOTHER CRIME EVEN THOUGH WE
WEREN'T AUTHORIZED TO WIRE TAP
FOR THIS PARTICULAR INCIDENT NOW
THAT WE KNOW HOW DO WE CREATE AN
INFERENCE SO THAT WE CAN GO
AHEAD AND GET IT.
AND THAT IS JUST.
YOU KNOW.
NOT RIGHT SO THAT'S HOW I SO
THEN WHEN I HEARD YOU SAY.
YOU KNOW YOU'RE PROVIDE YOUR
TESTIMONY AND ACTUALLY SOUNDED
LIKE THIS WAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
DO THAT SO I'M HOPING THAT I
MISS HEARD BECAUSE YOU KNOW THAT
HAPPENS AT LEAST TWICE A DAY FOR
ME -- SO CAN YOU CENTER PROVIDE
SOME CLARITY AS TO HOW THIS DOES
NOT OPEN THE DOOR TO ALLOW FOR
AN IN RUN -- IF FIRST OF ALL IF
I A MADE AN IMPRESSION IT WAS
COMPLETELY -- UNINTENTIONAL. TO
OBTAIN A WIRETAP I LIKE TO REFER
TO AS A WIRE TAP AFFIDAVIT AS A
SEARCH WARRANT ON STEROIDS.
BECAUSE IN ADDITION TO PROBABLE
CAUSE THAT THERE WAS A
COMMISSION OF ONLY CERTAIN
ENUMERATED DEFENSES THAT ARE
LISTED IN THE STATUTE.
SO WHEN WHEN THE WIRETAP
AFFIDAVIT IS SUBMITTED TO THE
JUDICIAL OFFICER FOR APPROVAL.
WE HAVE TO ESTABLISH PROBABLE
CAUSE THAT SPECIFIC OFFENSES
SUCH AS NARCOTICS TRAFFICKING
OVER THREE POUNDS WAS COMMITTED.
AND WE ALSO HAVE TO ESTABLISH
NECESSITY.
WHICH IS THAT OTHER TRADITIONAL
INVESTIGATIVE TECHNIQUES HAVE
BEEN TRIED.
OR HAVE FAILED OR ARE NOT
FEASIBLE.
SO THE INITIAL APPLICATION FOR
THE WIRE TAP IS ONLY FOCUSED ON
CERTAIN SPECIFIC CRIMES
[inaudible]
HOWEVER.
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS NOT IN
CONTROL OF WHAT.
THE TARGETS TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW
ONE MURDER SUSPECT COULD
SUDDENLY START TALKING ABOUT
NARCOTICS TRAFFICKING.
THE CODE IS SET UP SO.
IF THEY IF THE TARGET START
TALKING ABOUT NON CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY.
WE HAVE TO MINIMIZE THAT WE HAVE
TO BASICALLY NOT LISTEN TO THOSE
CONVERSATIONS.
AND IN FACT.
THE MONITORING EQUIPMENT THAT IS
USED.
ONCE A CALL IS BEGINS WE
INTERCEPTED HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH -- WITH THE OFFENSE AND
THAT MONARCHY EQUIPMENT IS
TURNED OFF.
FIRST OF ALL THAT CALL IS NOT
RECORDED ANYMORE SO IT
ESSENTIALLY IS A RACIST IT.
CANNOT BE OBTAINED IT'S NOT
RECORDED ON THE ON THE LISTENING
DEVICE.
THE FACT THAT THE CALL IS MADE
IS RECORDED SO WE DO KNOW THAT I
CALLED DâN.
HOWEVER WHAT DAN AND I TALKED
ABOUT IS NOT ACTUALLY RECORDED.
AND THE EQUIPMENT IS METERED SO
SUBSEQUENT LITIGATION WE CAN
SPOT CHECK AND MAKE SURE THAT
THE OFFICERS WHO WERE DOING THE
MONITORING ACTUALLY FOLLOW THE
LAW.
AND FAILURE TO MINIMIZE.
IS THE GROUND FOR SUPPRESSION SO
THERE'S A LOT OF BUILT IN
PROTECTIONS. FOR A DEFENDANT WHO.
MAKES THE MOTION THAT HIS OR HER
CONVERSATIONS WERE ILLEGALLY
RECORDED.
LIMIT LET ME FOLLOW UP I'M NOT
SURE THAT FIGHTING ANSWERED YOUR
QUESTION SO LET ME.
LET ME GIVE AN EXAMPLE.
SO IT IN THE ORIGINAL BILL THERE
WERE SIXTEEN SERIOUS OFFENSES
THAT WERE LISTED WEEK WE'VE STE
OF STRUCK.
MOST OF THEM.
BUT ONE OF THEM ITEM NUMBER FIVE
HOLDING A HOSTAGE BY PERSON
CONFIDE IN STATE PRISON.
SO IF YOU HAVE A WIRE TAP THAT
EXISTS.
AND FOR A LEGITIMATE REASON AS
WAS AUTHORIZED IN THE ORIGINAL
STATUTE AND SOMEONE SAYS IN THE
COURSE OF THAT OH BY THE WAY
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD A HOSTAGE.
IN A STATE PRISON.
ALL RIGHT THAT THAT CAN'T BE
USED IN EVIDENCE IN AND TO THE
EXTENT THAT THEN THAT BECOMES --
OTHER OTHER EVIDENCES DERIVATIVE
THAT IS THROUGH THE POISONOUS
TREE.
SO. TO TO YOUR POINT IT DOESN'T
PROVIDE AND AND RUN.
NOW FOR ME NOT THAT I DO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT ELIMINATION OF
THAT BUT I UNDERSTAND THE
COMMITTEES COULD.
THE COMMITTEE'S VIEW AND THAT'S
NO LONGER -- IN ENUMERATED --
ITEM THAT THAT CAN BE COLLECTED
[inaudible]
YES IT.
THROUGH THE CHAIR.
THERE'S ALSO AN ADDITIONAL
PROTECTION IN CALIFORNIA LAW.
WHEN YOU OVER HERE A?
NON TARGETED CRIMINAL OFFENSE --
FOR SHIP TODAY THE THE SAID THE
VIOLENT FELONY -- BEFORE JUST
BECAUSE I HERE.
THOUGH.
JOHN DOE SAY THAT THEY'RE
PLANNING TO COMMIT A ROBBERY OR
THEY'VE COMMITTED CERTAIN
ROBBERIES -- I STILL CAN'T
AUTOMATICALLY YOU [inaudible]
THAT.
AND HAVE TO GET THE PERMISSION
OF THE COURT.
SO.
IF IT WAS FOR A NON TARGET A
CHECK FROM [inaudible]
THE ONE YOU'D HAVE TO GO.
NOT USE THAT INFORMATION BUT AS
THE SENATOR AND MY COLLEAGUE
POINTED OUT.
THERE'S THE PROTECTIONS IN THE
EQUIPMENT SO THAT YOU CAN
DETERMINE WHAT WAS TO LISTEN TO
WHAT WAS NOT LISTEN.
TO AND THEN EVEN IF I COME AWARE
OF IT.
I HAVE TO FIND OTHER EVIDENCE
OUTSIDE OF THAT WATER.
IN ORDER TO PROSECUTE THE CASE
OTHERWISE ALL THAT WOULD GET
SUPPRESSED IN THE CASE WILL BE
DISMISSED.
OKAY THANK YOU ARE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
YOU MAY CLOSE MISSED ON BURKE --
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WOULD
URGE AYE VOTE.
AND AND I WANT TO THANK HIM
STONE BURKE AT THE NOTE IT WAS
DIFFICULT TO TAKE THE MEMBERS
BUT THE CHAIR.
THE REST COMMITTEE REALLY DO
APPRECIATE IT -- SOMETIMES I
WISH OTHER COLLEAGUES WOULD TAKE
YOUR EXAMPLE OF WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO IS COMMENDABLE AND
THAT'S WHY I WANTED TO GET THIS
OUT IS COMMITTEE IT IS TO FLOOR
SO HE BEGAN.
THIS PROCESS BECAUSE YOU HAVE
SOME REALLY ADMIRABLE PARTS OF
THIS BILL THAT WE REALLY NEED TO
CONSIDER AND SO GUY JUST
PERSONALITY.
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS AND CHURCH RECOMMEND
AN AYE VOTE.
ON SB FOUR THIRTY NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER HI
LACKEY.
BARRICADE HAND BACKHAND I DEEP.
DEEP I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK
[inaudible]
I SANTIAGO.
WICKS WICKS I THAT MEASURE
PASSES THANK YOU MUCH.
I MISS RUBIO ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR SB TWO SEVEN THREE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
MOVE THE BELL.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
SENT TODAY I'M PRESENTING SB TWO
SEVENTY THREE THE PHOENIX ACT.
TWENTY FIRST THANK THE CHAIRMAN
HAS COMMITTEE FOR WORKING SO
HARD WITH MY STAFF. FIVE TO MOVE
THIS BILL FORWARD I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WHICH INCLUDES
SLOWING THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS TO EIGHT YEARS.
SB TWO SEVENTY THREE IS CRITICAL
AND IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT PIECE
OF LEGISLATION BECAUSE IT WOULD
EXTEND THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS. FOR SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WHO NEED
ADDITIONAL TIME TO HEAL FROM
THEIR TRAUMA.
FEEL SAFE AWAY FROM THEIR
ABUSERS [inaudible]
SORRY.
SB TWO SEVENTY THREE INCLUDES
ADDITIONAL TRAINING. FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO KNOW HOW TO
HANDLE DIFFERENT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE CIRCUMSTANCES IN A
CULTURALLY SENSITIVE MANNER.
DATA SHOWS A MULTIPLE REASONS
WHY SURVIVORS OF ABUSE MAY NOT
COME FORWARD WITHIN THE STATURE
LIMITATION INCLUDING.
THEIR AGE AT THE TIME OF ABUSE
ONGOING TRAUMA THREATS FROM
THEIR PERPETRATOR FOR LACK OF
EVIDENCE.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS A HORRIBLE
CRIME THAT AFFLICTS A HEAVY TOLL
ON ITS VICTIMS AND WHEN IT COMES
TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE THE
STATISTICS ARE GRAHAM.
MANY VICTIMS REPORT ONLY AFTER
THEY LEARN THAT THEIR ABUSER IS
ALREADY ABUSING SOMEONE ELSE.
SOME COME FORWARD WITH VIDEO.
AUDIO RECORDINGS AND FORDER
GRAPHS.
HOWEVER NOTHING COULD BE DONE
BECAUSE THERE THREE YEARS ARE UP.
IN AMERICA AN AVERAGE OF FIFTY
WOMEN ARE SHOT TO DEATH BY THEIR
ABUSERS.
EVERY MONTH AND MANY MORE ARE
INJURED.
THIS ISSUE IS VERY PERSONAL TO
ME.
AS I TOO AM A VICTIM OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
WHEN I STORY BECAME PUBLIC IN
THE MEDIA HUNDREDS OF WOMEN FELT
COMPELLED TO TELL THEIR STORIES?
AND SHARE THEIR PERSONAL TRAUMAS.
THE ONE THING THEY ALL HAD IN
COMMON WAS THAT.
DEEP ROOTED TRAUMA AND
PARALYZING FEAR.
THAT TAKE THE MANY YEARS TO
OVERCOME.
AND MANY WERE NEVER ABLE TO TELL
ANYONE EVEN AFTER THE
RELATIONSHIP ENDED.
ON AVERAGE NEARLY TWENTY PEOPLE
PER MINUTE ARE VICTIMS OF
PHYSICAL VIOLENCE BY AN INTIMATE
PARTNER IN THE UNITED STATES.
UNFORTUNATELY IN RECENT YEARS WE
HAVE WITNESSED THE ESCALATION OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
CASES RESULT IN DEATH.
TRAGICALLY WE JUST EXPERIENCE
THE RECENT DEATH OF A YOUNG
POLICE OFFICER.
SOLOMON.
IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY WHO IS
ANSWERING A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
CALL.
THIS IS THE HEART OF THE BILL.
VICTIMS NEVER KNOW IF THE ABUSE
WILL ESCALATE TO MURDER EVEN
AFTER THE RELATIONSHIP HAS ENDED.
SO FEAR RUNS DEEP AND PUSHES
VICTIMS AND TO SILENCE SOMETIMES
FOREVER.
AT TIMES ABUSES WILL END UP
TAKING IT OUT ON THEIR CHILDREN
OR THEIR LOVED ONES.
AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN IN MY
DISTRICT A FRIEND OF MINE DOWN I
A STATUS.
LOST HER FIVE YEAR OLD SON.
WHO WE ON US PEAKING?
ON A LEFT HER ABUSER.
AND FOUGHT DESPERATELY TO GAIN.
SOLE CUSTODY OF HER SON
[inaudible]
SHE FELT.
PK BELIEVE THE DOW WAS TAKING
HER TO DISNEYLAND.
HER EX HUSBAND MURDERED HIM TO
HURT HER.
ANOTHER VICTIM WHO SPOKE AT A
RECENT PRESS CONFERENCE TALKED
ABOUT HOW HER EX PARTNER
AMBUSHED HER.
AND TERRORIZED HER AND HER
FAMILY.
HE STOCKED -- SO MUCH SO HE
FOUND HER SHOT INTO HER HOME
SHOOTING HER FATHER.
AND HER WITH HER FOUR YEAR OLD
SON WATCHING.
IT'S THE BEST MORE REALITY.
A FEAR THAT DOMESTIC.
VIOLENCE VICTIMS FACE.
AND IT PUSHES THEM.
AND TO SILENCE.%
AND THE SHAME CONTINUES FOR A
LIFETIME.
MEMBERS LET'S NOT MAKE THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS ONE MORE
HURDLE THAT AND ALREADY BROKEN.
TRAUMATIZED VICTIM HOUSE TO
INDOOR.
SOMETIMES IT TAKES YEARS BEFORE
VICTIMS EVEN REALIZE WHAT THEY
WERE EXPERIENCING WAS ABUSE.
ANOTHER VICTIM TESTIFIED THAT
HER FIRST PUNCH HER FIRST CáC.
WAS AT THIRTEEN SHE WAS A LITTLE
GIRL.
SHE DIDN'T KNOW ANY BETTER.
IT TOOK FOR TWENTY SEVEN YEARS
TO HEAR FOR FEEL FROM THAT
TRAUMA.
IDENTIFY AS A VICTIM OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND FEEL SAFE ENOUGH TO
COME FORWARD.
NOW SHE HAS TO SEE HER ABUSER
AROUND TOWN.
AND THERE'S NOTHING SHE CAN DO
TO REMEDY THAT.
THIS IS WHY SB TWO SEVENTY THREE
IS SO CRITICAL.
WHEN THEY DO FIND THE COURAGE TO
SEEK JUSTICE WE MUST ALLOW THEM
TO DO SO?
VICTIMS DESERVE THE TIME TO HEAL
FIND THEIR VOICE AND MUSTER THE
STRENGTH TO COME FORWARD.
TODAY WITH ME I HAVE TWO
COURAGEOUS INDIVIDUALS.
FIRST ASK MAYBE UNCLE SURVIVOR
AN ADVOCATE FOR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ISSUES.
ALAIN WHITE FEATHER THE CEO OF A
COMMUNITY FOR PEACE LOCAL
SACRAMENTO NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION FOCUSING ON TV'S.
THANK YOU HAVE A TO TOGETHER YET
FIVE MINUTES BUT WILL WORK WITH
YOU GOOD.
THE MORNING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS AS MAY BE
ACKERMAN I'M A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SALIVA AND ADVOCATE.
BEFORE HE SUCCEEDED IN HIS
DEDUCTION MY ABUSE A CAREFULLY
GROOMED ME MANIPULATING A GAS
LIGHTING ME OVER A NUMBER OF
YEARS OF FRIENDSHIP.
HE KNEW THE TIE WAS EASY PREY I
HAD NEITHER POWER NOR CONTROLLER
FOR MY LIFE.
THE PREVIOUS INTIMATE
RELATIONSHIP WITH STREET NEAR
BIRTH AND SO I WAS LED FROM THE
FRYING PAN INTO THE FIRE.
INITIALLY HE WAS CHARMING
INTELLIGENT FUNNY HE TOLD ME I
WAS HIS SOULMATE.
BY THE TIME I WAS LIVING WITH
HIM HE CONTROLLED EVERY ASPECT
OF MY LIFE.
HE HAD THE DRESS CODE I WAS
EXPECTED TO ABIDE BY HE
CONTROLLED RETALIATES DECIDED IF
MY FRIENDSHIPS WERE ACCEPTABLE
WHEN I CALLED MY FAMILY I DO I
DID SO HIDING INSIDE A CLOSET.
I WAS NOT ALLOWED TO KEEP THE
HOUSE AND I WOULD OFTEN BE
LOCKED IN THE BEDROOM.
HE CONTROLLED WHEN AND IF I
SLEPT AND I WAS OFTEN VIOLENTLY
SHAKEN AWAKE SHOULD I GO TO
SLEEP WITHOUT PERMISSION.
VERBAL ABUSE OF NAME CALLING WAS
A DAILY OCCURRENCE THE PHYSICAL
VIOLENCE IS MOST OFTEN DESCRIBED
IN ACTS OF INTIMACY WAS NOT
CONSENTED.
TO IN ONE INSTANCE I WAS BITTEN
INTO MY BODY WAS COVERED IN
BRUISES ANOTHER OCCASION CUT
WITH A KNIFE DURING SEX.
HE TOOK PHOTOS OF MY NAKED
MUTILATED BODY AND POSTED THEM
ONLINE WITHOUT MY KNOWLEDGE.
I STILL HAVE THESE PHOTOS ALONG
WITH PHOTOS OF MY BODY COVERED
IN WELTS INFLICTED WITH THE WHIP.
ON ONE OCCASION AFTER FOUR DAYS
MOSTLY P. BECAME VERY ANGRY WITH
ME HE STARTED SMASHING HOLES IN
THE WALLS WITH AN ACCENT AS I
TRIED TO CALM HIM DOWN HE BEGAN
TO CHASE AFTER ME WITH THE
WEAPON.
IT WAS AT THIS STAGE I REALIZED
MY LIFE WAS IN DANGER.
I WAS A PRISONER IN HIS HELL AND
YET I THOUGHT I'D DONE SOMETHING
TO DESERVE THIS SO I JUST TRIED
HARDER TO PLEASE HIM.
MY TRUMP HAD NORMALIZE THESE
HORRIFIC EVENTS TO ENABLE ME TO
SURVIVE.
IT TOOK ME SEVEN YEARS TO GET TO
STAY DRY COULD SEE THESE ACTS
FOR WHAT THEY WERE.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
AFTER A DIAGNOSIS OF PTSD THE
SYMPTOMS OF WHICH I STILL SUFFER
ON A DAILY BASIS.
I START TO THEINCREDIBLY
PAINFUL PROCESS OF HEALING FROM
MY TRAUMA
THE NIGHT TERRORS OF THE WORST
PART I WAKE FROM THESE STREAMS
SCREAMING CERTAINS WERE SWEPT
MID PANIC ATTACK ONCE A PANIC
SUBSIDES TO IS REPLACED WITH A
CRIPPLING SHAME.
THE SAME IS OVERWHELMING THE FOR
THE TIME MIGHT SOMEHOW REPEAT
PAST PATTERNS AND FIND MYSELF
BACK IN THE CYCLE.
WHEN I FINALLY FOUND THE COURAGE
SEVEN YEARS LATE TO SEEK LEGAL
ADVICE I WAS TOLD DESPITE HAVING
PHOTOGRAPHIC VIDEO WHEN WRITTEN
EVIDENCE IT WAS TOO LATE?
NOTHING COULD BE DONE.
SO I LIVE.
SO I LIVE WITH THE DAILY
KNOWLEDGE BY ABUSE IS STILL
INFLICTING A REPAIRABLE DAMAGE
ANOTHER WOMEN.
THE PHOENIX AT GIVE SURVIVORS
THE TIME THEY NEED TO BREAK THE
CYCLE FOR BOTH THEMSELVES AND
THEIR REFUSES.
WHO WE KNOW STATISTICALLY MOST
LIKELY CAUGHT COULD CONTINUE
ABUSING IF LEFT UNCHECKED?
I KNOW I WILL NEVER SEE JUSTICE
FOR HAPPEN TO ME.
BUT I AM HERE RISKING MY SAFETY
AND THAT OF MY FAMILY. TO
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO VOTE YES
ON THIS BILL GIVE THOUSANDS OF
SURVIVORS A CHANCE TO SEEK THE
JUSTICE THEY DESERVE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
I AM ELAINE MY FEATHER THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND CEO OF A
COMMUNITY FOR PEACE.
A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVOR OF
FAMILY VIOLENCE SURVIVOR.
AND I HAVE PROVIDED TV ADVOCACY
FOR OVER THIRTY EIGHT YEARS.
WHEN SOMEONE DECIDES TO THREATEN
STOCK HARASS OR ABUSE HIS OR HER
PARTNER?
WHAT MIGHT A VICTIM DO?
THE ANSWER SEEMS OBVIOUS TO MANY
OF US TELL SOMEONE TELL A FAMILY
MEMBER A GOOD FRIEND A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ADVOCATE OR POLICE.
SOMEONE WHO CAN HELP YOU.
EXCEPT IT DOESN'T HAPPEN IN OVER
50% OF THE TIME FOR MOST VICTIMS
AND A HIGHER PERCENTAGE FOR
MARGINALIZED VICTIMS OF COLOR
[inaudible]
WHY?
THE FIRST BARRIER IS THE VERY
TRAUMA ITSELF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
IPV AFFECTS ONE IN FOUR WOMEN
ONE IN SEVEN MEN.
IT IS 3250% HIGHER IN BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES AND 60% HIGHER
IN MARGINALIZED LGBT Q. AND
TRANSGENDER COMMUNITIES.
IT IS A SOCIETAL ISSUE ROOTED IN
GENDER BASED VIOLENCE FOR
GENERATIONS AN ISSUE OF POWER
AND CONTROL WITH MANY FORMS OF
ABUSES USED TO MAINTAIN THAT
CONTROL.
AND IT'S ONLY BEEN CRIMINALIZED
SINCE.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR THE IMPACT
OF THIS BEHAVIORAL CRIME IS THE
COMPLEX TRAUMA THAT VICTIMS AND
SURVIVORS INDOOR AND AFFECTS
THEM AND THEIR CHILDREN FOR A
LIFETIME.
CRIME VICTIMS OF ALL TYPES OF
CRIME MAY EXPERIENCE TRAUMA.
PHYSICAL DAMAGE TO THEIR BODIES
OR EMOTIONAL WOUNDS OR SHOCKED
BECAUSE MY VIOLENCE AGAINST THEM.
REACTION TO TRAUMA VARIES FROM
PERSON TO PERSON AND CAN LAST
FOR HOURS DAYS WEEKS MONTHS.
OR YEARS.
VICTIMS MAY EXPERIENCE PHYSICAL
TRAUMA FROM A SERIOUS INJURY OR
SHOT TO THE BODY.
AND THEY MAY HAVE CUTS BRUISES
FRACTURED ARMS LEGS OR INTERNAL
INJURIES.
VICTIMS MAY I X. EXPERIENCE
EMOTIONAL TRAUMA EMOTIONAL
WOUNDS ARE SHOCKED THAT A LONG
LASTING EFFECTS.
EMOTIONAL TRAUMA MAY TAKE MANY
DIFFERENT FORMS SHOCK OR
NUMBNESS FEELING FROZEN AND CUT
OFF FROM YOUR OWN EMOTIONS.
VICTIMS MAY NOT BE ABLE TO MAKE
DECISIONS OR CONDUCT THEIR LIVES
AS THEY DID ONCE BEFORE THE
CRIME.
TRAUMATIC MEMORIES ARE HARSH AND
FROZEN IMPRINTS THESE FROZEN
IMPRINTS MUST BE THAWED AND
ENVIRONMENT OF SAFETY.
BEFORE THEY CAN BE TOLD.
VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE DO
NOT EASILY FEEL SAFE ANYWHERE.
IT THAT IT MAY TAKE YEARS TO
ESCAPE INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE
AND MANY MORE TO FINALLY FEEL.
SKEWS ME FEEL SAFE ENOUGH TO
TALK ABOUT IT.
EVEN WHEN VICTIMS DO BEGIN TO
TELL THEIR STORY THE THOUGHTS OF
PAST ABUSE MAY SHUT DOWN THE
FRONTAL LOBE OF THE BRAIN.
THIS VERY PART OF THE BRAIN IS
WHAT WE NEED TO PUT OUR FEELINGS
INTO WORDS.
WHEN THE FRONTAL LOBES SETS DOWN
THE IMPRINTS OF TRAUMATIC
EXPERIENCES ARE NOT ORGANIZED AS
COHERENT LEGAL NARRATIVES
LOGICAL NARRATIVES?
BUT IN FRAGMENTED SENSORY
EMOTIONAL TRACES IMAGES SOUNDS
AND PHYSICAL SENSATIONS.
ADDITIONALLY WHEN VICTIMS DO NOT
RECEIVE THE SUPPORT AND HELP
THEY NEED AFTER THE CRIME THEY
MAY SUFFER SECONDARY INJURIES.
THEY MAY BE HURT BY A LACK OF
UNDERSTANDING FROM FRIENDS
FAMILY AND THE PROFESSIONALS
THEY COME IN CONTACT WITH.
PARTICULARLY IF OTHERS SEEM TO
BLAME THE VICTIM FOR THE CRIME
SUGGESTING THAT THEY SHOULD HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO PREVENT IT OR AVOID
IT.
BASED ON NATIONWIDE SURVEY OF
ADVOCATES ATTORNEY SERVICE
PROVIDERS A NONPROFIT WORKERS
WHO SUPPORT AND REPRESENT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT VICTIMS. 88% OF THE
RESPONDENTS REPORTED THAT POLICE
SOMETIMES OR OFTEN DO NOT
BELIEVE VICTIMS OR BLAME VICTIMS
FOR THE VIOLENCE.
WHICH IS WHY I BELIEVE THE
ADDITIONAL TRAINING FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THIS BILL IS
VERY HELPFUL AND WILL ADDRESS
THOSE ISSUES.
WOMEN OF ALL RACES AND
ETHNICITIES WEAPON DOOR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE HAVE TO MAKE THAT
CHOICE AT SOME POINT IN TIME TO
STAY OR LEAVE THE ABUSERS. FOR
MANY WOMEN OF COLOR ESPECIALLY
BACKGROUND AND LGBT Q. THE FIRST
RESPONSE IS OFTEN TO NOT REPORT.
NOT TELL ANYONE WE WANT TO
PROTECT OUR PARTNERS IT IS NOT
EASY TO TURN THEM OVER TO THE
POLICE THE COURTS AND OTHER
INSTITUTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
HISTORICALLY BY US.
PEOPLE WITH IMMIGRANT STATUS MAY
FEAR BEING DEPORTED IF THEY LACK
DOCUMENTATION.
EXTENDING THE LIMITATIONS TO THE
MAXIMUM YOU WILL ALLOW IS A
TRAUMA INFORMED PIECE OF
LEGISLATION.
THAT SUPPORTS BOTH THE VICTIM
SURVIVOR AND THE FIRST RESPONDER.
THE SURVIVOR WILL GET TIME TO
HEAL ACCESS HELP AND RESOURCES
IN ORDER TO REDUCE THE FEAR AND
STRESS OF ESCAPING THE TEAR.
BEFORE.
RE EXPERIENCING THE TRAUMA OF
REPORTING AND THE PROCESS OF
SEEKING JUSTICE BEFORE HE SHE OR
THEY ARE READY.
FAILURE IS A MEMORY THAT LEAD TO
NOT BE BELIEVED OR WORSE VICTIM
BLAMING SELF BLAME TREAT
TRIGGERS THE FEAR OF RETRIBUTION
BY THE ABUSER.
BECAUSE NO CONSEQUENCES WERE
GIVEN FOR THE DVD CRIME OF TV
AND I PAVE A THIS IS WHAT IMPACT
SURVIVORS OF TV THE MOST.
NOT BEING BELIEVED NOT BEING
UNDERSTOOD.
AND MANY MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES DO NOT EVEN KNOW
IT'S A CRIME.
THE TRAINING PIECE OF THIS BILL
WILL PROVIDE FOR TOM INFORM
TRAINING TO REDUCE THESE
BARRIERS AND INCREASE THE
OVERALL SAFETY AND EFFECTIVENESS
FOR OFFICER RESPONSE.
TRAINING BEYOND ACADEMY AND POST
TRAINING THAT ENGAGES EXPERT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SERVICE
PROVIDERS THERE ARE WELL OVER A
<c.red>UNDRED OF THEM FUNDED KELLY AS</c>
DOMINANT CULTURE AND CULTURALLY
SPECIFIC ORGANIZATIONS IN OUR
STATE.
WE WILL ADDRESS THIS CRITICAL
BARRIER THAT EXISTS WITH WITH
WHICH CONTRIBUTES TO THE TRAUMA
OF TV.
THESE COLLABORATIONS WILL
INCREASE THE OVERALL
INTERVIEWING AND FOLLOW UP THE
COOPERATION OF THE SURVIVOR.
WHEN SUPPORTED BY CONSULTATION
AND COLLABORATION WITH TV EXPERT
ORGANIZATIONS?
THIS IS TRUE ESPECIALLY WHEN
RESPONDING TO SURVIVORS OF COLOR.
OF MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES LIKE
LGBT Q. IMMIGRANTS NON ENGLISH
SPEAKING AND MALE VICTIMS.
THIS BILL PROVIDES THE TIME AND
SUPPORTS THE VICTIMS SURVIVORS
ABILITY TO HEAL.
AND CHOOSE TO REPORT FILE
CHARGES AND GET THE JUSTICE HE
OR SHE OR THEY SEE.
IT IS TRAUMA INFORMED SOCIAL
JUSTICE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
DON CAP KEY MCCUE CAP CAN%
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF CRIME
VICTIMS UNITED OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
SURE MEMBERS JONATHON FELDMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THIS GERMAN MEMBERS STAND FLOWS
OUT OF THIS MORNING ON BEHALF OF
CRIME VICTIMS ACTUAL LICENSE
SUPPORT.
SHAVE RECORD CLASS. FOR THE
WITNESS WHO SPOKE LAST TIME AND
I'M VERY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
I'M MORE QUICK ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR OF A COMMUNITY FOR
PEACE I'M IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS ALVIN OLIVER IS.
SACRAMENTO LEGAL ADVOCATE IN A
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I'M ACTUALLY GORE RESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIA AND A SURVIVOR OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND VIOLENCE
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS PRINCE RAHMAN I'M A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVOR AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS A SILLY HOW ON BEHALF
OF SURVIVOR LINES WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS BENNY OF LOS AND
SURVIVOR OF A GUNSHOT -- POLICE
INCOMPETENCE AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE I'M HERE BECAUSE I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MIKE A DOCTOR OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA
HERE IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO
SB TWO SEVENTY THREE UNLESS IT
IS AMENDED TO REMOVE THE
EXTENSION OF THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS.
WE CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE GOAL OF
PROMOTING JUSTICE FOR SURVIVORS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
HOWEVER WE FEAR THAT THE
EXTENSION OF THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS PROPOSED BY THIS
BILL EVEN TAKE EIGHT YEARS
MOBILE THREATEN DEFENDANT'S
RIGHTS AND REMOVE THE INCENTIVE
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
PROSECUTORS. TO MORE SWIFTLY
ADDRESSED REPORTS OF DOMESTIC
PLANT PARTNER VIOLENCE IN THE
FIRST INSTANCE.
AT A FUNDAMENTAL LEVEL STATUTES
OF LIMITATIONS HELP TO ENSURE
THAT DEFENDANTS RECEIVE A FAIR
TRIAL.
AS THE UNITED STATES SUPREME
COURT HAS STATED STATUTES OF
LIMITATIONS PROTECT INDIVIDUALS
FROM HAVING TO DEFEND THEMSELVES
AGAINST CHARGES WHEN THE BASIC
FACTS MAY HAVE BECOME OBSCURED
BY THE PASSAGE OF TIME.
THESE ISSUES SURROUNDING TIME
PASSAGE AND FACTS -- APPLY
EQUALLY TO ALL PARTIES INVOLVED
IN A CRIMINAL PROSECUTION
DEFENDANTS DETECTIVES WITNESSES
AND VICTIMS ALIKE AND AS SUCH
BOTH DEFENDANT AND VICTIM MAY
SUFFER THE CONSEQUENCES.
OF THESE DEFICITS OFTEN LEADING
TO UNJUST OUTCOMES.
IN ADDITION TO ENSURING FAIRNESS.
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT HAS
ALSO NOTED THAT STATUTES OF
LIMITATIONS ENCOURAGE THE SWIFT
AND EFFECTIVE ENFORCEMENT OF THE
LAW HOPEFULLY PRODUCING A
STRONGER DETERRENT EFFECT.
AS YOU HAVE HEARD SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ALREADY FACE
SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS WHEN
ATTEMPTING TO ACCESS CRIMINAL
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
IN A STATEWIDE STUDIED MORE THAN
30% OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CASES
INVOLVING AGGRAVATED PHYSICAL
ASSAULT WERE NOT PROSECUTED.
OTHER RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT
WHILE POLICE TEAM JUST A
FRACTION OF SEXUAL ASSAULT CASES
WORTHY OF INVESTIGATION.
PROSECUTORS HAVE APPROACHED
SUSPICIOUSLY EVEN THOSE CASES
THAT POLICE DEEMED TO HAVE THE
STRONGEST EVIDENCE OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
EXTENDING THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS IN THESE CASES WILL
NOT IMPROVE THESE OUTCOMES.
AND MAY SERVE ONLY TO FURTHER
DISCOURAGE THE SWIFT AND
EFFECTIVE ENFORCEMENT OF THE LAW.
THERE BY WEAKENING THE THREAT OF
PROSECUTION FOR THOSE WHO COMMIT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CRIMES.
SO FOR ALL OF THESE REASONS WE
ARE AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL UNLESS IT IS AMENDED TO
REMOVE THE EXTENSION TO THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MARCO GEORGE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION --
I WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
MISTER OCT ROTH FOR THE ACLU BUT
I ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT THE
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S ASSOCIATION
AGREES.
THAT ON DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS A
PLAGUE THAT AFFECTS EVERY CLASS
AND RACE IN THIS SOCIETY.
AND I HAVE REPRESENTED
PERSONALLY A NUMBER OF WOMEN WHO
HAVE FOUGHT BACK AGAINST THE MEN
WHO ABUSE THEM I REPRESENTED ONE
WOMAN.
WHO SHOT HER ABUSER IN THE LEG?
AND SHE WAS PROSECUTED.
I REPRESENTED ANOTHER WOMAN WHO --
HAD KILLED HER ABUSER AND THEN --
AND AND FACED ABUSE FROM A
SECOND MAN.
AND POURED BOILING WATER ON HIM.
I AGREE THE POLICE NEED TO BE
TRAINED.
BUT I THINK WHAT'S MORE --
IMPORTANT.
AND WHERE WE SHOULD PUT OUR
RESOURCES IS NOT BEEN EXTENDING
THE STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS.
NOT IN ON HIM AND JAILING MORE
PEOPLE BUT THIS IN PROVIDING
RESOURCES. FOR WOMEN AND
CHILDREN AND MEN WHO ARE ABUSED.
AND PART OF THE PROGRAM THE THE
THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN PROVEN TO
WORK.
M. IN THE STUDIES THAT HAVE BEEN
DONE WORLDWIDE.
IS TO START IN SCHOOL.
AND THE CENTER -- FOR FOR
COMMUNICABLE DISEASES CDC HAS
SUCH A PROGRAM THAT THEY HAVE --
ACTUALLY TRIED OUT IN OAKLAND.
AND IN OTHERS -- CITIES AROUND
THE COUNTRY.
AND THE RESULTS SHOW THAT
STARTING WITH CHILDREN AND
EDUCATING THEM ABOUT ONE THAT
YOU DON'T RESORT TO BIND.
IS THE FIRST STEP.
IN ENDING THIS PLAGUE SO FOR
THOSE REASONS THE A CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ARE.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MR REBEKAH POWER QUE AND THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST WANT TO
THANK MS BIANCO AND SENATOR
RUBIO FOR BEING HERE AND GIVING
VOICE TO THE MANY VICTIMS IN
CALIFORNIA WHO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP TODAY.
AND HAS A TASTE FOR WORDS THE
PROPONENTS MOUTHS BUT I THINK
THAT THE EDUCATION THAT YOU ARE
SUGGESTING -- IT'S PROBABLY
SOMETHING THEY WOULD ALSO
SUPPORT I THINK THAT WE NEED TO
BE DOING MORE TO PROTECT VICTIMS
AND NOT LASTS AND SO IT SHOULD
BE AN EITHER OR AND THAT MEANS
GIVING.
THESE VICTIMS A CHANCE TO GET
JUSTICE IT MEANS PREVENTING
VIOLENCE SET POSSIBLE AND MAKING
SURE THAT WHEN THEY ENTER THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM THEY'RE TREATED
WITH THE DIGNITY THE RESPECT AND
SECURITY THAT THEY NEED. TO GET
THE JUSTICE THEYDESERVE SO I AM
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING
IT ON THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU.
MISS KAMLAGER-DOVE.
YES I WANT TO THANK.
THE SENATOR FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD AND FOR THAT
PERSISTENT ADVOCACY -- YOU KNOW.
WE DON'T TALK ENOUGH ABOUT A LOT
OF THINGS WE DON'T TALK ABOUT
SORT OF SEXUAL OFFENSE IT JUST
CAME UP AND KIND OF DE
STIGMATIZING.
WE DON'T TALK ENOUGH ABOUT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
AND WE DON'T REALLY FRAME IT IN
A WAY THAT ALLOWS FOR FOLKS TO
HAVE EQUITABLE CONVERSATIONS
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT VIOLENCE
AGAINST WOMEN -- AND IT'S NOT
JUST ABOUT VIOLENCE AGAINST
CERTAIN KINDS OF WOMEN.
I WOULD HOPE THAT -- THE AUTHOR
IN THE ADVOCATES CAN RESPOND TO
MY QUESTION BECAUSE I THINK THAT
SOME OF THE OPPOSITION IN THE
ANALYSIS -- IS LEGITIMATE -- AND
I'M GONNA SHARE THE QUESTION
FROM MY OWN EXPERIENCE BECAUSE
OFTENTIMES WHAT WE LIKE TO DO IS
WE DISCOUNT SOMEONEELSE'S
EXPERIENCE BECAUSE IT'S NOT OUR
OWN.
AND SOUND PUBLIC POLICY.
TAKES INTO ACCOUNT ALL
EXPERIENCES BECAUSE YOU'RE
HAVING A CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT
IS BEST FOR THE ENTIRE STATE.
SO -- MAYHEM ASSAULT BATTERY
MURDER MANY OF THE THINGS THAT
WERE SHARED IN THE TESTIMONY ARE
ALREADY CHARGEABLE OFFENSES AND
IF THEY ARE NOT.
THE NOT THE CONVERSATION THAT WE
SHOULD BE HAVING WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT ABOUT WHY WE DO NOT
SEE VALUE IN THAT VICTIM COMING
FORWARD.
BECAUSE EITHER THEY'RE DEAD OR
BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN HURT -- AND
THAT THE ALLEGED PERPETRATOR IS
NOT CHARGED.
BUT I THINK IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT
TO RECOGNIZE THAT.
PEOPLE DO LIKE.
REVENGE.
AND PEOPLE DO LIKE TO RETALIATE
AND THERE ARE INSTANCES DIVORCE.
ADD SEPARATION THAT ARE NOT
AMICABLE.
WHERE FOLKS ARE LOOKING FOR
THEIR POUND OF FLESH?
AND MY QUESTION IS HOW DO WE
PROTECT.
AGAINST THOSE SITUATIONS FROM
HAPPENING FROM SOMEONE SAYING
HEY BECAUSE NOW WE HAVE EXTENDED
THE STATUTE OF LIBERTY
LIMITATIONS.
AND I HAD A LESS THAN DESIRABLE.
EXPERIENCE WITH THIS PERSON I'M
GOING TO USE THIS LAW. TO SEEK
THAT KIND OF A RANGE I ASKED
THAT QUESTION BECAUSE IT
HAPPENED TO ME.
IT HAPPENED TO ME -- AND I AM
CERTAINLY NOT TRYING TO AFFORD
SOMEONE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CONTINUE.
TO SEEK WAYS TO TRAUMATIZE ME
AND THOSE WAYS YES AND SO I'M
JUST CURIOUS TO SEE HOW WE CAN
BOTH PROTECT.
TRUE LEGITIMATE VICTIMS -- OF
THESE KINDS OF ASSAULT.
WHILE STILL SORT OF PROTECTING
AGAINST SOME OF THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES AND I RECOGNIZE
SOME OF THAT WAS -- ATTEMPTED TO
BE ADDRESSED IN THE AMENDMENTS --
BUT I WOULD CERTAINLY WANT TO
GIVE YOU ALL TIME TO TALK ABOUT
THIS BECAUSE IT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT IN BE IT'S VERY
PERSONAL.
I'LL START OUT WELL THANK YOU
FOR FOR THAT QUESTION AND I DO
SHOW YOUR CONCERN -- AND I'M
SENSITIVE TO TO THAT ISSUE AND
THAT IS WHY THIS BILL REQUIRES --
THAT IT'S EVIDENCE BASED.
THAT WHEN THEY DO COME FORWARD --
THERE HAS TO BE EVENTS SUCH AS
VIDEO AUDIO -- AS WE HEARD FROM --
THE TESTIMONY EVEN WITH THE
AUDIO VIDEO OF THREATS OP SHE
WASN'T ABLE TO BRING HER ABUSER
TO JUSTICE SO THERE IS A
COMPONENT THAT WAS THAT IT.
THAT MAKES IT EVIDENCE BASED
VERSUS JUST SOMEONE ACCUSING
SOMEONE AND JESSE SO WE WANTED
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT WAS IN
THERE.
IS THERE ANYTHING YOU WANT.
TO THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION.
THERE'S A COUPLE WAYS THAT I
WANT TO ADDRESS THAT FIRST OF
ALL JUST IN MY EXPERIENCE OF
THIRTY EIGHT YEARS AND WORKING
WITH WOMEN WHO ACTUALLY.
I HAVE BEEN IN PRISON FOR
KILLING THEIR ABUSER.
WHAT I WANT TO SAY TO THAT IS
THAT THAT IS OFTEN THE VERY LAST
OPTION FOR ANY SURVIVOR AND
USUALLY BECAUSE SYSTEMS HAVE
FAILED HER REPEATEDLY AGAIN AND
AGAIN?
SO THAT'S ONE SIDE OF IT AND A
SMALL PIECE BUT WE CAN LOOK INTO
ALL THE DATA THAT SUPPORTS THAT
PARTICULAR -- STATEMENT BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT TODAY AND BECAUSE THIS IS
NOW THE FOURTH FIFTH SIXTH
GENERATION OF VIOLENCE IN OUR
FAMILIES.
WHICH IS A LEARNED BEHAVIOR AND
SO WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS IS LEARNED AND WE LIVE IN A
VIOLENT VIOLENT COMMUNITY
LIFELINE.
WORLD WHERE POWER AND CONTROL IN
THE USE OF VIOLENCE TO CONTROL
SOMEONE OR TO SOLVE PROBLEMS IS
ALSO SYSTEMIC.
SO WHAT WE'RE ALSO UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT THERE IS A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE PRIMARY AGGRESSOR.
AND A DOMINANT AGGRESSOR TRAIN
IS WHAT REQUIRES THAT ALL OF US
IN OUR FIELD AND THE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE FIELD.
AS IT CONTINUES TO EVOLVE
UNDERSTAND MORE MORE ABOUT THE
IMPACT OF TRAUMA TO THE BRAIN.
UNDERSTAND WHAT AN INJURY IN
DOMESTIC BONDS ACTUALLY DOES DUE
TO A VICTIM.
WE UNDERSTAND THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN COERCIVE CONTROL AND
PRIMARY DOMINANT AGGRESSOR AND
SO WHEN YOU START TO TRAIN THE
SALON FOR MEANT.
THAT WE AS ADVOCATES WE CAN BE
CONSULTANTS COLLABORATE WITH
THESE THINGS FIRST OF ALL YOU
ELIMINATE THAT REVENGE PIECE
WHICH I AGREE.
I AGREE AND SUPPORT YOU WITH
THAT THAT THAT IS PRESENT BUT
THERE IS A WAY TO FILTER THAT
OUT TO BE ABLE TO SAY FROM OUR
EXPERT POINT OF VIEW WHAT IS A
TRUE.
VICTIM RESPONSE AND REACTION.
VERSUS WHAT IS A PRIMARY
DOMINANT POWER AND CONTROL USE
OF ABUSE.
DEBT TO TO GET THE EXACT EVENTS
OR HAVE POWER AND CONTROL OVER
SOMEONE INDEFINITELY THERE IS
THAT IT'S AN EDUCATIONAL PIECE
THAT.
TRAUMA SURVIVORS LIKE AS AND D.
V. D. V. EXPERTS HAVE TO DEAL
WITH EVERY DAY WHEN WE DO LEGAL
WORK WHEN WE'RE TRYING TO FILL
OUT AN RO.
OR ANYTHING ELSE FOR SURVIVORS
WE HAVE TO SIFT THROUGH THAT TOO
AS ADVOCATES IT'S BEEN
CHALLENGING FOR OUR MOVEMENT BUT
IT IS WHERE WE ARE NOW.
SO WE ARE CONSTANTLY IN THIS
THIS FIELD OF EDUCATING
OURSELVES AND UNDERSTANDING THAT.
IN ORDER FOR THERE TO BE JUSTICE
YOU DO HAVE TO HAVE THIS PIECE
BECAUSE THIS IS NOT JUST A CRIME
IT'S BEHAVIORAL IT'S LEARNED AND
GENERATIONAL.
AND ITS HISTORICAL AND IF WE
DON'T TAKE ALL OF THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION.
WHAT THIS WHAT EVEN ARE MY THE
THE RESPECTFUL OFFICES BY
POSITION I CAN CONCUR WITH MANY
ELEMENTS OF WHAT THEY SAID?
BUT HERE'S THE THING 450% OF
SURVIVORS WHO DON'T EVEN REPORT
IT TO BEGIN WITH IT'S BECAUSE WE
HAVE SYSTEMIC BARRIERS THAT
DON'T EVEN LET US GO THERE IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
SO HOW MANY OF US ARE TOLD DON'T
EVEN CALL THE COPS.
THAT IS WHAT WILL GET YOU THE
WORST BEATING OF YOUR LIFE.
DON'T EVEN REPORTED TO ANYONE
THAT WILL YOUR DIPPY TRAIN YOUR
COMMUNITY YOUR BILL TO BE
TRAINED YEAR.
YOUR YOUR RELIGION YOU'RE
BETRAYING ALL OF THESE PIECES SO
THAT'S KEEPING US TRAPPED WE
NEED TIME TO WORK THROUGH ALL OF
THOSE PIECES.
AND AN ADVOCATE AND THE VICTIM
CAN NEVER EVER STAND FOR HERSELF
ABOUT THAT HELP.
THANK YOU RIGHT ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
MR LACKEY.
YEAH CENTER RUBIO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS SO. TO THE
FOREFRONT HERE TODAY -- AND
WITNESSES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
VERY POWERFUL TESTIMONIES.
YOU KNOW THIS -- DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ISSUES I THINK ONE OF
OUR THE BIGGEST.
TOXINS TO OUR ENTIRE SOCIETY.
AND IT'S QUITE COMPLEX.
BUT THIS IS JUST ONE VERY
PIVOTAL TOOL VERY POWERFUL TOOL.
IN ALLOWING REMEDY TO TAKE PLACE
AND I THINK EVEN PREVENTION.
BECAUSE I I THINK THE GOAL WOULD
BE.
I MEAN THE MOST IDEAL SITUATION
IS PREVENTION BUT WE HAVE TO
KNOW IN REALITY THAT THAT IS NOT.
POSSIBLE IN EVERY CASE.
IT'S JUST NOT GONNA HAPPEN.
SO WE NEED TOOLS WHEN IT DOES
HAPPEN. TO SUPPORT VICTIMS.
VICTIMS ARE THE ONES THAT
DESERVE THE SUPPORT AND WE NEED.
TO TRY TO HELP THE PEOPLE HAVE
THE PROBLEMS BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY.
AND THE PERSON WHO DESERVES THE
MOST SUPPORT IS THE VICTIM.
AND SO I AM VERY THANKFUL FOR
THIS PARTICULAR TOOL IT'S
ALARMING TO ME THAT YOU EVEN
HAVE TO BRING THIS FORWARD.
IT IT IT SHOCKS THE CONSCIENCE.
THAT WE HAVE.
THIS LIMIT TO REPORT WHAT ARE WE
DOING AS A SOCIETY WHEN WE HI
SHOULD PROTECT THOSE WHO HAVE NO.
DESERVES CIRCUMSTANCE IN THAT
REGARD IS SHAMEFUL.
AND IN MY OPINION IT SHAMEFUL
THERE'S ANY OPPOSITION TO THIS --
BECAUSE IT'S INSENSITIVE TO
THOSE WHO TRULY NEED.
THIS AVENUE TO BE ABLE TO
EXPRESS.
WHAT'S HAPPENED TO THEM.
AND HOPEFULLY STOP IT TOO FROM
CONTINUING AND OTHER
RELATIONSHIPS BECAUSE THIS IS
EXTREMELY [inaudible]
VOLATILE.
AND VERY VERY TOXIC PROBLEM THAT --
ABUSERS CARRY WITH THEM.
AND SO THANK YOU.
FROM THE BOTTOM MY HEART I'M
VERY VERY THANKFUL AND I I WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE.
A REQUEST ON RECORD TO BE A CO
AUTHOR.
AND TO TO BE A A PERSON TO
ADVOCATE IN ANY WAY I CAN FOR
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
SO THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
YES SOUTH THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
A FOR HEARING US HERE TODAY BUT
I DO WANT TO ADDRESS A COUPLE OF
POINTS THAT ARE OPPOSITION TO
STATED -- IT IT REALLY HITS HARD
WHEN I HEAR -- AND THEIR WORDS
IT THREATENS DEFENDANT'S RIGHTS.
BUT I DID NOT HEAR VICTIMS
RIGHTS AND I BELIEVE MR LACKEY
SAID IT BEST THIS IS NOT ABOUT.
US BECAUSE OUR TIME IS UP IT'S
ABOUT PROTECTING THE NEXT
GENERATION OF VICTIMS WERE
PROBABLY CURRENTLY EXPERIENCING
A WE DID.
AND THEY ALSO CITED [inaudible]
DEFICIENT MEMORY.
IN EIGHT YEARS I CAN ASSURE YOU
WE REMEMBER EVERY PUNCH EVERY
CáC EVERY ASSAULT.
AND THEY ALSO CITED THE SUPREME
COURT CASE THAT TALKS ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF STATUTES OF
LIMITATIONS AND WHY THEY'RE
THERE BUT WE HAVE EVOLVED AS A
SOCIETY.
JUST LAST YEAR I BELIEVE WE
REMOVE THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS ON SEXUAL ASSAULT
BECAUSE RESEARCH KEEPS SHOWING.
THAT TRAUMA CAUSES WOMEN TO TO
GOING TO THE SHUTTLE'S.
MORE AND MORE -- INFORMATION'S
COMING OUT THAT STATES THAT
WOMEN NEED THAT TIME TO FEEL
SAFE AND IT'S ALL ABOUT SAFETY I
WHICH
FATHER WAS SHOT AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO AVOID.
AND SO I I DO RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE WITH THE OPPOSITION I
THINK THAT IT'S IMPORTANT I
THINK IT IS TIME. THREE YEARS IN
AN ALREADY COMPLICATED OBSTACLE
COURSE.
IS NOT ENOUGH. THREE YEARS IS
JUST ENOUGH TO GET AWAY AND FEEL
SAFE AND THEN IT TAKES THREE
FOUR MORE YEARS TO FIGURE OUT
THAT IT'S OKAY TO SPEAK UP.
AND SO I WANT TO THINK AS ME AND
DOM AND MISS WHITE FEATHER FOR
BEING HERE BECAUSE THESE ARE
PERSONAL STORIES THAT NO ONE
TELLS AND IT TAKES A LOT OF
COURAGE FOR SOMEONE LIKE ME.
WHO IS IN THE PUBLIC EYE TO
SHARE WHAT HAPPENED TO ME I KNOW
HOW HARD IT WAS FOR ME?
I CAN ONLY IMAGINE HOW MUCH
HARDER IT WAS FOR HER AND SO
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR RIFLE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND I BY TWO IS
CHAIRMAN OF THANK BOTH -- THE
WITNESSES FOR FOR BEING HERE
TODAY ARE NOT ONLY WERE YEAR.
TESTIMONY COMPELLING -- IT
REALLY KINDA EXEMPLIFY WHAT WHAT
IS GOING ON IT.
AND I THINK THE AUTHORAND I
WANT TO THANK HER FOR TAKING.
A DE AMENDMENTS IT'S REALLY
DIFFICULT -- LOOK I I KNOW.
I PERSONALLY KNOW.
OF A A YOUNG BOY AND AND IS AND
A SISTER WHO WITNESSED THE
MOTHER B. AND B..
AND I FIVE YEARS -- PULLING
[inaudible]
HIS.
HIS FATHER OFF OF HIS MOTHER.
EVEN TAKING PICTURES WITH A
POLAROID CAMERA AND YOU SEE THE
MOTHER WITH TWO BLACK EYES BUT
THE KIDS WITH THEM.
WHICH ALSO SHOWS HOUSE
INSTITUTIONALIZED -- AND THEN.
NOT SEEN THEIR FATHER FOR TWENTY
YEARS.
HI FATHER HAPPY CHILD SUPPORT
ANYTHING.
BUT BEEN SEEN A FATHER TWENTY
YEARS LATER THAT THAT YOUNG BOY
MET HIS FATHER.
WHO HAD BEEN IT WAS A DIFFERENT
PERSON?
AND THIS IS KIND OF PART OF THE
DAY IT.
WHAT WHAT PEOPLE GOING BACK AND
FORTH ON -- THAT'S WHY TWENTY
WAS A LITTLE DIFFICULT FOR
STATURE LIMITATIONS BECAUSE THAT
PERSON WAS NO LONGER AN
ALCOHOLIC PERSON WAS A CHRISTIAN.
THE PERSON WOULD NO LONGER THAT
SAME PERSON.
AND THAT BOY DECIDED THAT HE
WOULD.
TRY NOT TO CONTINUE TO HATE THAT
BOTHER FOR THE LAST TWENTY YEARS --
BUT TRY TO GET TO KNOWN FOR THE
NEXT -- TWENTY WHICH KIND OF
WORKED OUT FOR HIM -- AND THEN
WHEN.
AND THEN WHEN MY FATHER ASKED ME
WHY I WASN'T ANGRY WITH HIM.
AND I TOLD HIM THAT MY MOTHER
TAUGHT ME HOW TO FORGIVE.
AND TO SEE A GROWN MAN CRY IN
FRONT OF YOU.
BECAUSE OF WHAT HE DID -- IT
ALSO SHOWED ME THAT WE'VE GOT TO
GET TO THE OTHER PART. FOR MEN.
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN TRAINED. TO BE
A DOMESTIC.
VIOLENCE ABUSER.
BECAUSE THAT'S THE WAY I FIRST
SAW IT FIVE YEARS OLD HOW TO
INTERACT.
WITH A WIFE FOR SPOUSE SO THAT'S
WHY.
CENTER RUBIO I KEPT TALKING
ABOUT WHAT CAN WE DO.
ONE GET THESE INDIVIDUALS.
OUT OF THAT SITUATION AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE I DON'T THINK WE
PROVIDE ENOUGH -- PROTECTION
PROVIDING OF HOUSING WILL
PROVIDE ENOUGH MONEY RESOURCES
SO THAT.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE PEOPLE ARE IN
THAT SITUATION CAN GET OUT AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE.
AND THEN PROVIDING.
ENOUGH.
MONEY RESOURCES SHELTER IN JOB
TRAINING SO THEY CAN MOVE AWAY
FROM THAT MY MOTHER HAD THE
COURAGE TO GET OUT OF IT.
AND AND AND AND I WILL ALWAYS BE
THANKFUL FOR THAT I KNOW WHAT
IT'S LIKE TO SIT.
AND WAIT FOR THAT PERSON TO COME
HOME.
THAT NOT.
IN YOUR STOMACH COULD YOU DON'T
KNOW IF THEY'RE GOING TO RUN
LIKE A VOLCANO.
OR NOT.
I KNOW IT'S LIKE DELAY IN YOUR
BED WONDER WHAT'S GOING TO GO ON
IS NOT A GOOD FEELING.
IS REALLY NOT MY SISTER TODAY I
THINK MENTALLY HAS NOT BEEN ABLE
TO HAVE A RELATIONSHIP.
WITH ANY MAIL BECAUSE OF THAT --
WITH A LITTLE -- MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS.
I'VE BEEN ABLE TO MAKE SURE I
MOVE I NEVER BECOME.
WHAT MY FATHER WAS?
BUT IT'S BUT IT TAKES A LOT OF
HELP -- AND I KNOW I CAN.
LIKE A VOLCANO VERBALLY BY THINK
I LEARNED THAT FROM MY FATHER SO
I'VE LEARNED AS Y. TALKIN
MEASURED.
TONES WHEN I GET ANGRY.
I'VE HAD TO TEACH MYSELF NOT TO
BE THAT PERSON.
AND SO -- I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR TAKING THE MEN'S BECAUSE IT
IS DIFFICULT.
WHETHER IT'S TWENTY YEARS
FIFTEEN YEARS CAN YOU -- TO TRY
TO GIVE ENOUGH TIME SO THAT FOR
FOR ME THIS IS ALSO PART OF
HEALING.
COULD YOU MAYBE CHILDREN
INVOLVED THIS FAMILIES INVOLVED.
THEY MAY NOT EVER COME BACK
TOGETHER.
BUT THEY MAY AFTER RAISING
CHILDREN TOGETHER.
AND WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
MAKE THAT HAPPEN IN THE MOST
SAFE ENVIRONMENT AND SO.
BACK TO THE OPPONENTS THE I WAS
WILLING TO TO RAISE IT BECAUSE I
JUST THOUGHT WE NEED TO GET MORE
TIME MANY BECAUSE WE DON'T
PROBABLY DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
RESOURCES RIGHT NOW TO DO ALL
THAT WE NEED TO DO.
AND SO I THINK WE'RE ALL IN IT
WE'RE ALL AGREEING.
ON ON THE STATUES LIMITATION --
THAT'S WHY I WENT DOWN FROM.
TWENTY WEST WITH FROM UNLIMITED
DOWN A TWENTY DOWN TO WHERE WE
ARE SO WE MADE.
AND AGAIN I WANT TO THANK CENTER
RUBIO E'VE MADE SOME TREMENDOUS
PROGRESS IN AND AND SHORTENING
THE TIME SO THAT MEMORIES.
AND THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY HANDLE
THAT AND SO I WILL NOT ONLY
SUPPORT THIS.
BUT IF THERE'S ANY SUBSEQUENT
FUNDING OR IDEAS.
THAT WE CAN DO. TO HELP WITH
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE -- AND AND AND
REALLY HELP THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
INVOLVED IN THAT -- FOR BOTH
SIDES MALE AND FEMALE SO THAT WE
CAN WE CAN IN DISCOURAGE ONCE
AND FOR ALL WE'RE NOT ATTACKING
THE PROBLEM.
AND WE KEEP.
KEEP READING MORE MORE THESE
ABUSERS.
WE'VE GOT TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
STOP THAT.
AND SO I RESPECTFULLY ASH -- FOR
MICHAEL.
ON SB TWO SEVENTY THREE THE
MOTION IS DO PATH AS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I LACKEY AYE LACKEY
AYE BARRICADE HAND.
BARRICADE HAND I DEEP.
DEEP I KAMLAGER-DOVE OF QUIRK
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
WICKS HI WICKS I THE MEASURE
PASSED [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MR PORTANTINO ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
SB [inaudible]
SEVEN THREE SEVEN SIX PORTANTINO
FIREARMS TRANSFER
[inaudible]
CHAIRMAN.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY MISTER
KALRA SENATOR PORTANTINO.
THANK YOU -- MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- SB.
THREE SEVEN SIX WOULD REDEFINE
THE WORD INFREQUENT. TO ME IN
LESS THAN SIX FIREARMS
TRANSACTIONS.
PER CALENDAR YEAR REGARDLESS OF
THE TYPE OF FIREARM FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO SELL LEASE OR
TRANSFER FIREARMS WITHOUT
LEGALLY BEING REQUIRED TO OBTAIN
A LICENSE.
THERE'S A DISPARITY IN THE PENAL
CODES DEFINITION OF THE TERM AND
FREQUENT.
WHICH RESULTS IN A DISPARITY IN
THE WAY IN WHICH I'M LICENSED
SELLERS OF FIREARMS ARE TREATED
UNDER THE LAW.
INDIVIDUALS MAY OR MAY NOT BE
REQUIRED TO OBTAIN A LICENSE TO
SELL FIREARMS DEPENDING ON THE
TYPE OF FIREARM BEING TRANSACTED.
IN SOME INSTANCES THIS MAKES
THEM -- FOR EXAMPLE NON PROFITS
FROM HAVING TO GO THROUGH A
LICENSED DEALER WHEN ROUGHLY ARE
AUCTIONING OFF A FIREARM.
THE DISPARATE TREATMENT CAUSES
CONFUSION A MAKES UNCLEAR IF AND
WHEN SELLERS ARE REQUIRED TO AND
SHOULD OBTAIN A LICENSE TO
ENGAGE IN THE BUSINESS OF
TRANSACTING FIREARMS.
THIS IS A PROBLEM BOTH FOR THE
PUBLIC AS WELL FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE THERE'S A
LACK OF A BRIGHT LINE.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS TO
STANDARDIZE THE DEFINITION OF
THE TERM INFREQUENT IT IS ALSO
INTENDED TO REDUCE THE FREQUENCY
AND NUMBER OF FIREARMS.
AN SINCE WHICH MAKES SENSE YOU
SHOULDN'T HAVE A LOOPHOLE WHERE
PEOPLE CAN SELL MORE GUNS THAN
THEY SHOULD.
UNDER NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES THE
BILL WOULD CREATE A SINGLE LIMIT
FOR THE NUMBER OF TRANSACTIONS
AND I'M LICENSE INDIVIDUAL IS
AFFORDED ANY YEAR REGARDLESS OF
THE TYPE OF FIREARM.
BEING TRANSACTED THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT CONSIDERATION WHERE
TRANSACTIONS MAY BE A MIXTURE OF
VARIOUS TYPES OF FIREARMS THE
BILL WOULD ALSO LIMIT THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF FIREARMS INDIVIDUALS
ARE ABLE TO SELL.
LEASE FOR TRANSFER TO NO MORE
THAN FIFTY PER YEAR WITHOUT
HAVING TO OBTAIN A LICENSE AND
WITH ONLY UP TO FIVE SEPARATE.
TRANSACTIONS THAT INDIVIDUALS BE
REQUIRED TO ATTAIN A LICENSE IF
THEY ARE SELLING LEASING
TRANSFERRING OR MANUFACTURING
MORE THAN FIFTY FIREARMS YEAR
REGARDLESS OF THE TYPE OF
FIREARM.
CALIFORNIA WOULD NOT BE THE
STATE FIRST STATE INSTITUTE
LICENSING REQUIREMENTS SUCH AS
THESE CONNECTICUT RETURN
REQUIRES INDIVIDUAL SELLING MORE
THAN TEN HANDGUNS TO GET A
LICENSE MASSACHUSETTS --
GENERALLY REQUIRES AND EVEN
INDIVIDUAL SUMMING UP OR LEASING
A FIREARM TO OBTAIN A LICENSE
TROOP -- THOUGH DOES DOES
PROVIDE FOR SOME EXEMPTIONS
TODAY I HAVE ACTUALLY IRES FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS.
AND YOU SEE THAT I'VE BEEN
JOINED ALSO BY -- NGUYEN -- AND
IRWIN TELLS TO BE AND I DON'T
KNOW IF THIS IS FOR PUBLICATION
BUT WE NEED TO GIVE HIM A SHOUT
OUT.
THAT -- HE'S FINALLY GOING TO GO
THROUGH ON HIS -- THREATEN
RETIREMENT AND HE SAYS THIS MAY
BE THE VERY LAST TIME.
HE'S HERE BEFORE THIS COMPOSITE
VICIOUS COMMITTEE AS A SENATE
STAFFER AND SO I WANT TO MAKE
SURE AND I DON'T SEE MISTER
PAGAN HERE BUT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ACKNOWLEDGE ALL THE
WORK THAT ARE ONE IS DONE FOR
GUN SAFETY IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THIS MAY BE IS VERY LAST
APPEARANCE BEFORE YOU MISTER
CHAIR SO DO WITH IT AND THAT
INFORMATION THAT YOU WILL AND
WITH THAT I HAVE MY EXPERTS TO
TESTIFY OKAY THANK YOU.
MY GOODNESS SO MUCH PRESSURE
ONES LAST HEARING.
OUR HOME WE HAVE THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL LIKE TO THANK SENATOR
PORTANTINO FOR OFFERINGS VERY
IMPORTANT MEASURE.
AS SEEN IN RECENTLY PUBLISHED A
TWO PART ARTICLE SERIES THAT
DEMONSTRATES THE NEED IN THE
NECESSITY FOR THIS BILL.
THE INVESTIGATION INTO THE
UNREGULATED SALE OF FIREARMS
FOUND THAT UNLICENSED DEALERS
FOUGHT THE NATION'S GUN LAWS
PROVIDE A STEADY FLOW OF WEAPONS
TO PEOPLE WHO ARE EITHER BARRED
FROM OWNING GUNS OR WAN GUNS I
CANNOT BE TRACED BACK TO THEM.
I'M LICENSE DEALERS ARE
DIFFICULT TO DETECT TOUGH TO
PROSECUTE IN OFTEN RECEIVE
LENIENT SENTENCES EVEN WHEN THEY
ARE CONVICTED ACCORDING TO
INTERVIEWS WITH MORE THAN A
DOZEN CURRENT AND FORMER FEDERAL
AGENTS AND PROSECUTORS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
SEEN IN REVIEW DOESN'T THE CASES
OF ILLEGAL DEALING INCLUDE SOME
OF WHAT'S ALREADY FOR WARRANT BY
A TF THAT THEY MIGHT BE BREAKING
THE LAW.
THE CONTINUED SELLING FIREARMS
NONETHELESS GUNS THAT PASSED
THROUGH THE HANDS OF UNLICENSED
DEALERS HAVE TURNED UP AT CRIME
SCENES AND IN POLICE
INVESTIGATIONS FROM COAST TO
COAST.
INCLUDING IN CASES OF ARMED
ROBBERY CARJACKING AND MURDER.
THE SERIES DISCUSSES THE
FIREARMS PROTECT FIREARMS OWNERS
PROTECTION ACT A DECADES OLD
FEDERAL STATUTE ORIGINALLY
PROPOSED BY THE NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION DICTATING WHO WAS
REQUIRED TO HAVE A LICENSE TO
SELL GUNS.
AND WHO IS NOT.
THE LAWS FUZZINESS ON THAT
DISTINCTION IT PROVISION THE
DEFENDANT WAS WILLFULLY VIOLATE
THE LAW IN ORDER TO FACE
PROSECUTION HAS FRUSTRATED
EFFORTS BY LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
ORDER TO COMBAT THE PROBLEM OF
UNLICENSED GUN DEALING IN
AMERICA.
UNLICENSED GUN DEALERS ARE THE
GO TO SOURCE OF FIRE AND FOR
CRIMINALS AND OTHERS YOU CAN'T
PASS SORT OF REQUIRED BACKGROUND
CHECKS THAT LICENSED DEALERS ARE
REQUIRED TO PERFORM.
ORDINARY CITIZENS WHO DECIDE TO
SELL WEAPON OR WEAPONS BUT DO
NOT FIT THE DEFINITION OF DEALER
FACE NO REQUIREMENTS UNDER
THE FUNDAMENTAL PROBLEM WITH THE
CURRENT LAW ACCORDING TO CRITICS
AS WHAT CONSTITUTES A DEALER
ISN'T ALWAYS VERY CLEAR CUT.
THE STATUTE SAYS THAT ANYONE WHO
IS ENGAGED IN THE BUSINESS OF
SELLING A FIREARM REQUIRES A
LICENSE TO ENGAGE IN THE
BUSINESS COULD BE IN.
DEVOTING TIME ATTENTION LABOR TO
DEVOTE TO DEALING A FIRE INTO
THE REGULAR COURSE OF TRADER
BUSINESS WITH THE PRINCIPLE
OBJECTIVE OF LIVELY HIDDEN
PROFIT TO THE REPETITIVE
PURCHASING RESELL FIREARMS.
LAW STATES THAT IT DOES NOT
APPLY TO SOMEONE ENGAGED IN ONLY
OCCASIONAL GUN CELLS ARE
COLLECTORS ARE HOBBIES ARE
ADDING TO OUR SELLING FROM THEIR
PERSONAL COLLECTIONS.
ON THE WEST COAST ONE OF THE
SPECIFIC EXAMPLES AND THE CASE
WAS A DOZEN FIREARMS ALL BY THE
MEMBERS OF THE FAMILY IN THE
WASHINGTON STATE TURNING UP AT
CRIME SCENES IN POLICE
INVESTIGATIONS SCATTERED AROUND
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA.
EACH THE FAMILY MEMBERS WERE
CHARGED WITH FELONY I'M LICENSED
GUN DEALING BUT THEY PLED GUILTY
TO LESSER MISDEMEANOR OFFENSES
AND WERE SENTENCED TO PROBATION.
NOW ALL THIS BILL HAS BEEN A
NUMBER OF MOVING PARTS REQUIRING
LICENSED.
DEALERS TO GET A LICENSE THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF EXCEPTIONS SO IF
AND WHEN THERE IS A BY OPERATION
OF LAW DEATH TO DIVORCE WHEN
SOMEONE BECOMES PROHIBITED THE
DEPARTMENT IS NOT LOOKING TO
MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT. FOR
PEOPLE TO OFFLOAD THEIR FIREARMS
AND THAT IS WHY THERE IS A LARGE
NUMBER OF EXCEPTIONS WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE MORE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
SECOND.
OR ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES NOT POSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
MOVEMENT SECONDED -- YOU MAY
CLOSE IN ON BUT BEFORE THEN CAN
WE GET ON A RECORD WHERE THE NOT.
BERMAN IS REALLY RETIRING.
JUST SAY I AM RETIRING.
I AM RETIRING AT ON OCTOBER IN
THE MIDDLE OR LATE OCTOBER
DEPENDS ON THE PERSON TUITION
AND HOW THAT WHOLE THING WORKS
OUT BUT I FELT THAT -- THE
SENATE WHICH IS YES OR NO YES --
THANK YOU.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- AND I
MAY BRING YOUR WHEN BACK IS A
RETIRED A NEW IT -- IF THIS BILL
DOESN'T PASS [inaudible]
UNDER.
BUT I I DO.
RESPECT COMMITTEE CHAIR AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AND I DO WANT TO GIVE OR WHEN
THAT THANKS FOR WORKING ON THIS
BILL AND MANY OTHERS SO
APPRECIATE AN AYE VOTE TODAY.
CHAIR OF RECOMMEND THE AYE AND
WE WANT TO THANK.
OUR WENT FOR HIS YEARS OF
SERVICE ALSO.
CALL THE ROLL ON SB THREE
SEVENTY SIX COMMISSION IS YOU
HAVE TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER ITEMS ARE
AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BARRICK [inaudible]
LACKEY.
SB THREE SEVENTY SIX LACKEY NO.
BAUER QUE HAN BARRICADE HAND I
DEEP.
DEEP I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE AYE QUIRK AYE
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WICKS WICKS I THAT
MEASURE PASSES THANK YOU.
EVEN NOW CENTER [inaudible]
SENATOR MITCHELL [inaudible]
THEY WERE.
YOU HAVE -- TO SB FIVE BY FIVE
THE CARE THAT IS INCORRECT AND
SB SEVEN ONE SIX MINUTE TAKE A
PARSER.
AT YOUR PLEASURE THANK YOU WILL
START. TO GO NUMERIC SB.
FIVE FIVE FIVE IF THAT WORKS FOR
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SENATE GOOD MORNING -- EVERYBODY
S. SENATE BILL FIVE FIVE FIVE
WILL REDUCE THE COST OF
COMMUNICATION SERVICES AND
COMMISSARY ITEMS SOLD IN COUNTY
JAILS.
AND YOU WILL FACILITIES THAT
WILL ALSO PROMOTE FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITY IN JAIL CONTRACTS
WITH SERVICE PROVIDERS WITH THIS
BILL WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ENABLE STRONGER FAMILY
CONNECTIONS WHICH PROMOTES
PUBLIC SAFETY IN REDUCES
RECIDIVISM FOR RATE RATES. FOR
PEOPLE FACE AN INCARCERATION.
LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND
CALIFORNIA ALLOWS EACH OF THE
FIFTY A COUNTY SHERIFF TO
NEGOTIATE CONTRACTS
INDEPENDENTLY WITH PRIVATE
COMPANIES THAT PROVIDE SERVICES
TO THE COUNTY JAILS IN JUVENILE
HALL.
THE CONTRACT AND SERVICES ARE
LARGELY UNREGULATED RESULTED IN
PRIVATE COMPANIES GAMING PROFITS
OFF THE BACKS OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED AND THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS.
THE INMATE WELFARE FUND THE I.
W. S. HAVE BEEN USED FOR
PURPOSES THAT DO NOT PROMOTE THE
REHABILITATION OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED.
WHICH WAS WHAT THEY WERE
ORIGINALLY DESIGNED TO DO.
I W. F. HAVE BEEN INSTEAD YOU
FOR SERVICES THAT PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS IN JAIL SHOULD
ALREADY PROVIDE FOR EXAMPLE THE
PURCHASE OF SECURITY CAMERAS AND
TRANSPORT BANDS. TO THIS IN THIS
BILL WILL DO THE FOLLOWING IT
WILL LIMIT THE CASA PHONE
ELECTRONIC AND OTHER FORMS OF
COMMUNICATIONS.
AND THE COST OF ITEM SOLD NGO
COMMISSARIES WE'VE ALREADY TAKEN
THIS ACT AT THE STATE LEVEL
WITHIN CDC ARE -- VERTICALLY
ROUND THE PHONE CONTRACTS A
NUMBER OF YEARS AGO IT WAS
HIGHLY CONTROVERSIAL THE THE PER
MINUTE COST FOR PHONE CALLS
WE'RE NOW TRYING TO DO THIS BILL
DO THE SAME THINGS AT THE COUNTY
JAIL LEVEL.
THE BILL ALSO PROHIBITS
CONTRACTS FROM INCLUDING
COMMISSIONS OR OTHER INCENTIVES
FOR THE PROCUREMENT OF CONTRACTS.
IT CLARIFIES THE PERMISSIBLE
EXPENDITURES OF COUNTY INMATE
WELFARE FUNDS AND IT REMAINS TO
COUNTY INMATE WILL FOR FUN TO
QUOTE INCARCERATED PEOPLE'S
WELFARE FUNDS.
THE PURPOSE OF THE BILL IS THE
SIMILE REDUCE THE COST OF PHONE
CALLS AT THE COUNTY LEVEL AND TO
EXPAND THESE COST REDUCTIONS
OTHER FORMS OF COMMUNICATIONS.
PRIMARILY -- VIDEO AS WELL AS
THE COMMISSARY ITEMS SOLD NGL
SOURCE -- WE HAVE RECEIVED
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL -- I'LL
BE PREPARED TO RESPOND TO THOSE
QUESTIONS MEMBERS HABIT -- WE'VE
GOT A COUPLE WITNESSES HERE WHO
CAN TELL FIRSTHAND THEIR
EXPERIENCE WITH THE EXORBITANT
FEES -- THEY'VE EXPERIENCED IN
COMMISSARIES AS WELL AS THE
COMMUNICATIONS A WE KNOW THAT
ENCOURAGING PEOPLE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED TO HAVE REGULAR AND
CONSISTENT COMMUNICATION WITH
YOUR FAMILY MEMBERS.
HELPS WITH RE ENTRY AND HELPS
REDUCE RECIDIVISM THAT'S THE
FUNDAMENTAL GOAL OF THE BILL
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE ME CHAU
POLITO FROM THE TRANS LATINA
COALITION.
AND THE MAKE OF MOTOR WITH THE
YOUNG WOMEN'S FREEDOM CENTER WHO --
WAS FORMALLY INCARCERATED AND
EXPERIENCE DIFFICULTIES
CONNECTING WITH HER LOVED ONES I
APPRECIATE YOU ALL I'D BE
WILLING TO TELL YOUR PERSONAL
STORIES AND THE CHAIRMAN I ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU AND
YOU HAVE BY MEANS TOTAL.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY BEGIN
WRITING CHAIR MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS A MAKE A MALTA I'M A
POLICY DIRECTOR AT THE ON
WOMEN'S FREEDOM CENTER IN SAN
FRANCISCO I'M ALSO A FORMALLY
INCARCERATED MAMA -- AND
SOMEBODY THAT WAS DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY THE FINANCIAL
BURDENS OF INCARCERATION.
BOTH WHEN I WAS INCARCERATED AND
WHEN I WAS ON THE OTHER SIDE
SUPPORTING MY HUSBAND AND FAMILY
MEMBERS DURING THEIR
INCARCERATIONS.
ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON
SENATE BILL.
FIVE FIVE FIVE THE CURRENT JAIL
SYSTEM PLACES A HUGE FINANCIAL
BURDEN ON THE FAMILY MEMBERS AND
SUPPORT SYSTEMS OF INCARCERATED
PEOPLE.
WE TEND TO BE LOW INCOME --
WOMEN OF COLOR AND TEND TO BEAR
THE HEAVIEST BURDENS OF THE
EXISTING SYSTEM -- WHEN I WAS
INCARCERATED MY CHILDREN'S
GRANDPARENTS CARED FOR THEM
[inaudible]
AND THEY OFTEN HAVE A CHOICE OF
ACCEPTING THE PHONE CALL HOME
FOR MOM OR PUTTING FOOD ON THE
TABLE LITERALLY -- MY PHONE
CALLS HOME FOR A FIFTEEN MINUTE
PHONE CALL AVERAGE SEVENTEEN
DOLLARS -- MY KIDS WOULD OFTEN
SET A TIMER FIVE MINUTES A PIECE
TO GET.
A TIME TO SPEAK WITH ME AND IT
ALWAYS PUZZLED ME I KNEW I WAS
BEING PUNISHED FOR A CRIME THAT
I HAD COMMITTED.
BUT MY FAMILY WAS BEING PUNISHED
AS WELL BECAUSE THEY COULD NOT
AFFORD TO RECEIVE PHONE CALLS
HOME FROM MOM -- WITHIN THE
PHONE CALLS HOME AND IS THE
NUMBER ONE WAY THAT WE STAY
CONNECTED WITH OUR LOVED ONES
DURING THEIR INCARCERATION --
THIS THE BILL ALSO ADDRESSES
VIDEO CALLS WHICH IS ANOTHER WAY
WE STAY CONNECTED.
I OFTEN HAD TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
CALLING HOME ON MY DAUGHTER'S
BIRTHDAY -- CHOOSING TO CALL
HOME WHEN IN YOUR LOVED ONE HAD
PASSED AWAY -- IT WAS ALWAYS A
CHOICE BECAUSE IT WAS A
FINANCIAL -- A CHOICE THAT MY
THAT MY FAMILY CARRIED -- I
COULDN'T PARTICIPATE OR ENGAGE
AS A MAMA THE WAY I KNEW I
SHOULD EVEN THOUGH I WAS BEHIND
BARS I SHOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
PARENT MY MY CHILDREN AND IT WAS
A AN ISSUE OF COST FOR THAT
MISSING MY PHONE CALLS.
THE OTHER THING THAT'S A HUGE
BURDEN ON OUR FAMILIES AS A COST
OF COMMISSARY WHEN WE'RE
INCARCERATED WE DON'T HAVE THE
OPTION TO WORK WHEN WE'RE IN THE
COUNTY JAIL.
SO WE ARE A FINANCIAL BURDEN ON
OUR FAMILIES WE CAN'T SEND MONEY
HOME TO THEM TO SUPPORT THEM.
AND WE ALSO CAN'T AFFORD TO PAY
FOR BASIC HYGIENE THAT WE NEED
ONE WEARING HER SERRATED -- WE
LIVE IN A REALLY SMALLQUARTERS
DEODORANT SOAP THOSE THINGS ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT TO US IN THERE.
AND WE TURN TO OUR FAMILIES TO
ALSO PAY THOSE BILLS -- I I ASK
THAT YOU SUPPORT FIVE FIVE FIVE
AND RELIEVE THE FINANCIAL
BURDENS ON THE FAMILIES OF
INCARCERATED LOVED ONES THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS MACHE PULLEY THOUGH I
AM THE POLICY COORDINATOR WITH
THE TRANSIT THE IN A COALITION --
AND ON THE FLIP SIDE I AM ONE OF
THOSE LOVE ONES THAT'S
CONSTANTLY TRYING -- TO CALL MY
SIBLINGS -- CA TALK ABOUT IN
A LITTLE BIT -- BUT AS A MAKE A
MENTION AND THE ABILITY TO
MAINTAIN CONNECTION WITH LOVED
ONES WHEN INCARCERATED IS A LOT
OF THE TIME BASED ON YOUR WEALTH.
OFTEN CAN ONLY SPEAK WHEN THEY
MAKE A LITTLE EXTRA MONEY AND
WHEN PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO AFFORD
BECAUSE THEY'RE REMINDERS OF
WHAT YOU ARE PAYING.
AND THE LITTLE TIME ACTUALLY
HAVE LEFT ON YOUR CALL.
THAT'S THE CASE OF MY SIBLINGS
JOEY WHO IS CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY MEN'S CENTRAL JAIL.
I OFTEN HEAR YOUR MEANING
BALANCE IS ONE DOLLAR AND SIXTY
FOUR CENTS.
YOU HAVE SIXTY SECONDS REMAINING.
AS I TRY TO RUSSIAN MY FINAL I
LOVE USE.
AS WE KNOW PEOPLE WHO ARE BLACK
BROWN QUEER TRANSPORT AND PEOPLE
WITH MENTAL HEALTH DISABILITIES
ARE CRIMINALIZED.
AT SEVERELY HIGH RATES THIS
LEADS TO CONTACT WITH THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM WITH FOR
IT WHICH FURTHER MARGINALIZES
AND PUSHES OUR PEOPLE TOWARDS
ECONOMIC INSTABILITY.
THE COST OF COMMUNICATIONS
ESPECIALLY PHONE CARDS AND
COMMISSARY ITEMS IS INCONSISTENT
IN COUNTY JAILS ACROSS THE STATE
DUE TO THE FLEXIBILITY COUNTIES
HAVE IN CHOOSING THEIR PHONE
SERVICE AND COMMISSARY PROVIDERS.
FOR EXAMPLE A FIFTEEN MINUTE
CALL CAN RANGE FROM SIXTY EIGHT
CENTS IN A PLACE LIKE SAN MATEO
COUNTY.
VERY SAYS SEVENTEEN DOLLARS AND
EIGHTY CENTS IN LASSEN COUNTY.
ALL THE PROFITS FROM BECAUSE AND
GIO COMMISSARIES ARE PLACED INTO
THE AND MAY WELL FOR FUNDS AS
SENATOR MITCHELL MENTIONED AND
IT'S BEEN FOUND IN ANNUAL
REPORTS THAT THESE.
THAT THIS MONEY IS BEING USED
FOR THINGS LIKE SURVEILLANCE
CAMERAS BODY ARMOR AND TRANSPORT
BANDS TO CHOIR.
SO ESSENTIALLY LOW INCOME
FAMILIES IN THE ONES PAYING FOR
CALLS ARE THE ONES PAYING FOR
EXPENSES OF THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT.
THEIR POTENTIAL SOLUTIONS THAT
ARE GAINING MOMENTUM IN VARIOUS
PLACES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
LIKE IN TEXAS WHICH CUT PHONE
CALL COST FROM TWENTY SIX CENTS
PER MINUTE TO SIX CENTS
PERMANENT.
IN NEW YORK CITY THEY ELIMINATED
THEIR COSTS ALL TOGETHER.
AND THEN MOST RECENTLY AND SAN
FRANCISCO THEY JUST MADE THEIR
PHONE CALLS FREE WHICH WILL GO
INTO EFFECT NEXT YEAR.
ULTIMATELY WE WANT TO AND THE
BILL ABILITY FOR PRIVATE
COMPANIES TO PROFIT FOR PROFIT
OFF OF INCARCERATED PEOPLE THEIR
LOVED ONES AND THEIR SUPPORT
SYSTEMS WHILE MAINTAINING THE
ABILITY. FOR INCARCERATED PEOPLE
ON THEIR SUPPORT SYSTEM TO
MAINTAIN CONTACTS.
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME AND I HOPE YOU VOTE YES ON
SB FIVE BY.
FIVE THANK YOU ARE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES TO SUPPORT.
NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
THAT MEDI HIRED CALIFORNIA CIVIL
LIBERTIES ADVOCACY IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING GLENN BACK IS FOR
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
JIM LIMBURG FOR THE FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA PROD CO SPONSOR AND
CHEN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING TRACY CRESCENT
BURKE I'M FROM MEDIA ALLIANCE
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ALVIN ANG WITH ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE CALIFORNIA AND
WE SUPPORT.
MARGOT GEORGE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
MIKE A DOCTOR OFF ON BEHALF OF
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT.
DANNECKER O'DONNELL FROM LAWYERS
COMMITTEE FOR CIVIL RIGHTS OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA PROUD
CO SPONSOR IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING DOMINIQUE NONE OF
THE CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA PROUD CO SPONSOR IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MACKENZIE HOLDER
I'M A LAWSUIT IN IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THE NICER HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TERMS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE A STATEWIDE
ASSOCIATION COMPLUTENSE
ATTORNEYS IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING THE ANGEL MAC WITH
PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES IN
STRONG SUPPORT [inaudible]
YOU.
HAVEN'T HAD A MIGRAINE WITH THE
ELEVATOR CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ARE THERE.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
COULD YOU.
COULD YOU GIVE THEM SOME ROOM
SAY.
THANK YOU.
IF WE DO HAVE QUESTIONS WILL
CALL YOU BACK -- I THOUGHT THERE
WAS MORE PEOPLE SORRY.
GIVE ME A COMPLEX MISTER TRY NOT.
LEX IS JUST YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CHORUS ALSO HERE ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION.
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL -- WE HAVE SEVERAL
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL THEY
LARGELY CENTER AROUND THE FACT
THAT.
UNDER CURRENT CALIFORNIA PENAL
CODE SECTION FOUR ZERO TWO FIVE
THE PROCEEDS OF ANY PAYMENTS
THAT ARE AT ISSUE HERE FROM A
PROVIDER OF THESE PHONE SERVICES
ARE REQUIRED. TO GO INTO THE
INMATE WELFARE FUND AND THOSE
FUNDS ARE REQUIRED TO BE SPENT
PRIMARILY FOR THE BENEFIT.
OF INMATES -- AND INCARCERATED
PERSONS SO -- THAT'S THE SORT OF
THEME THAT UNDERLIES ALL OF THIS
THAT.
TAKING AWAY THOSE PAYMENTS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE PAYMENTS
TO BE PAID BY THE PHONE
COMPANIES ARE BY THE SERVICE
PROVIDERS.
THOSE WILL HARM THE INMATES.
WE WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PROVISION OF THE BILL THAT'S OF
THE CONTRACT MUST BE AWARDED TO
THE PROVIDER.
THAT MEETS THE TECHNICAL
SPECIFICATIONS BUT ALSO OFFERS
THE LOWEST COST APPEAR TO OF
SERVICE TO THE PAIR OF THE
SERVICE.
WHAT THAT MEANS IS THAT YOU
COULD HAVE TWO CONTRACTS ON THE
TABLE ONE THAT OFFERS A RATE OF
EIGHT CENTS A MINIMUM ONE THAT
OFFERS A RATE OF SEVEN CENTS A
MINUTE?
THE EIGHT CENTS A MINUTE
CONTRACT OFFERS FORMER SERVICES
AND BENEFITS THE SEVEN CENTS A
MINUTE IS BARE BONES BUT MEETS
THE TECHNICAL SPECS.
THIS STATUTE WOULD REQUIRE THAT
THE SEVEN CENTS A MINUTE
CONTRACT BE THE ONE THAT
SELECTED -- THERE ARE ADDITIONAL --
RECENT AMENDMENTS THAT MICRO
MANAGE THE PROCESS BY WHICH
THESE CONTRACTS MUST BE LET --
BE INCLUDE A PROVISION THAT SAYS --
THE SHERIFF MUST BE ALLOWED IN
THE CONTRACT TO RENEGOTIATE THE
TERMS OF THE CONTRACT AT ANY
TIME NOT SURE WHY A PRIVATE
ENTITY WOULD AGREE TO THAT --
BUT THEN THERE THE SHERIFF IS
PUT IN A BOX BY STATUTE AGAIN
STATE LAW REQUIRES THIS MONTH
GOING TO BE A MEANWHILE FOR FUN
IT PAYS FOR THINGS LIKE IN MEET
EDUCATION VOCATIONAL TRAINING
RECREATIONAL EQUIPMENT.
CLOTHING AND SUPPLIES FOR
INDIGENT INMATES ABOUT TO BE
RELEASED -- WE HAVE FISCAL
NUMBERS FROM COUNTIES ACROSS THE
STATE OF WHAT THIS WILL MEAN IN
TERMS OF MONEY THAT IS TAKEN
AWAY FROM INCARCERATED PERSONS --
I THINK WE MAY HEAR SOME OF THAT
IN THE UPCOMING TESTIMONY -- BUT
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT -- AS I
SAID THAT THIS WILL RESULT IN IN
FEWER DOLLARS BEING AVAILABLE
FOR INMATES SERVICES -- I DON'T
BELIEVE THE PRIVATE COMPANIES
WILL -- SEE AN IMPACT FROM THIS
THEY'RE BEING TOLD BY THIS BILL
YOU NO LONGER PAY THESE FEES ARE
PAID THESE -- THESE THESE
PAYMENTS -- I'D IT JUST AGAIN
IT'S IT'S THE INMATES WHO ARE
GOING TO SUFFER FROM THIS AND I
KNOW THAT'S NOT THE AUTHOR'S
INTENT.
AND I UNDERSTAND THERE'S CONCERN
ABOUT THE FAMILIES AND INMATES
PAYING FOR THE SERVICES -- BUT
THE BOTTOM LINE IS WITHOUT A
BACK FILL THESE FUNDS ARE GOING
AWAY AND NO SERVICES ARE GOING
TO BE IN JEOPARDY SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WITH US FOR AN OVER.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PRINTED UP
THE LA COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT -- IT RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION GOING OUT FIVE YEARS
IN THE FUTURE WE'VE GOT --
CONTRACTS EDUCATION CONTRACTS.
WITH VARIOUS PROVIDERS TOTALING
ABOUT FORTY MILLION DOLLARS THAT --
THIS WILL AFFECT SO RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON MARLON MARSHALL
REPRESENTING THE SAN DIEGO
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT AND AT THE
IMPACT ON US IS ABOUT TEN
MILLION DOLLARS.
AND THAT INCLUDES PROGRAMS
EVERYTHING FROM -- PROVIDING
ASSOCIATE ART DEGREES TO
CULINARY TRAINING. TO ENGLISH AS
A SECOND LANGUAGE -- AT THAT ARE
ALL GOING TO BE JEOPARDIZED
BECAUSE MY SHARES.
GOAL IS TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
WHO ARE INCARCERATED COME OUT IN
A BETTER PLACE THAN THEY WERE
BEFORE WE ALSO HAVE A
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION AND IN OUR CULINARY
ARTS PROGRAM.
THE RESTAURANT OWNERS ACTUALLY
COME INTO OUR FACILITY TEACH
THEM HOW TO INTERVIEW AND
PROVIDE JOBS FOR THEM AND THAT'S
HOW WE USE OUR IN THE WELFARE
FUNDS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AS CHAIRMAN MEMBERS POLIO -- ON
BEHALF OF THE BUTTE COUNTY
BORDERS WHO WRITES FOR THE
REASONS STATED BY STATE SHARES
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS MR QUIRK.
I HAVE A SIMILAR BILL TO THIS --
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO AND GOT
CAUGHT APPROPRIATIONS -- I WILL
SAY THIS AT THE TIME I LOOKED AT
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY USE.
OF THE IN THE IN.
INMATE WELFARE FUND I FOUND VERY
LITTLE OF IT ACTUALLY WENT TO
WELFARE THE INMATES IT WAS
LARGELY USED. TO PAY FOR MORE
DEPUTIES -- FURTHER WHAT YOU'RE
DOING HERE IS CHARGING PEOPLE
FOR BEING IN JAIL AND MOST OF
THEM CAN'T AFFORD ANYTHING THEY
ARE BY AND LARGE POOL WHERE --
AND I JUST FIND THE WHOLE
PROCESS DISGUSTING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS WICKS WHICH YES
IT WAS KAMLAGER-DOVE.
I'M A SO I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD AYE I THINK PEOPLE --
GENERALLY DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
COST OF NOT BEING OF PRIVILEGE
AND HOW PERVERSELY EVIDENT IT IS
WITH REGARDS TO THE PENAL CODE.
AND THE REALITY IS.
OFTEN TIMES.
EVEN IF YOU HAVE DONE SOMETHING
WRONG YOU MAY NOT BE
INCARCERATED IF YOU ARE ABLE TO
AFFORD.
A GOOD DEFENSE.
AND SO THESE THINGS DON'T EVEN
AREN'T EVEN TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION AND SO THIS IS
REALLY A CONVERSATION.
ABOUT.
SEGMENTS OF OUR POPULATION THAT
ARE OVER MONITORED.
OVER CHARGED OVER PROSECUTED
OVER INCARCERATED IN BECAUSE
THEY'RE POOR THAN THEIR OVER
CHARGED AGAIN FINANCIALLY. FOR
ME I WANT TO ECHO THE SENTIMENTS
OF MISTER DOCTOR QUIRK IT'S
DISGUSTING AVIDIN OF LIKE A
TWENTY NINETEEN JANE GAME.
YOU KNOW AND PEOPLE DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW HARD IT IS TO GET
AND TO KEEP MONEY ON THE BOOKS
AND HOW QUICKLY THOSE DOLLARS.
AND CENTS GO AWAY AND HOW OFTEN
THEY CAN BE LEVERAGED.
AND I CERTAINLY AGREE WITH MANY
OF WHAT THE OPPONENTS SAID ABOUT
THESE REALLY GOOD AND IMPORTANT.
AND REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS THAT
ARE BEING OFFERED AND THAT WE
SHOULD CONTINUE TO OFFER THEM I
WOULD HOPE THAT PASSING THIS
BILL DOES NOT MEAN.
THAT WE WILL GET RID OF THOSE
PROGRAMS WE SHOULD NOT HAVE
BINARY CONVERSATIONS.
BUT WE ALSO SHOULDN'T PAY FOR
THOSE PROGRAMS ON THE BACKS OR
PAY FOR A SYSTEM RATHER ON THE
BACKS OF THE POOR AND WE MUST BE
ABLE OF FOR THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD. TO BE ABLE
TO AFFORD TO PAY FOR THOSE KINDS
OF SERVICES.
I DO -- IT DOES MAKE ME THINK
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THE
OPPOSITION TALK ABOUT IS YOU
KNOW CHEAP THIS DOESN'T ALWAYS
MEAN BEST.
AND SO YOU KNOW BEST VALUE YOU
KNOW BECAUSE YOU CERTAINLY DON'T
WANT TO GET LIKE THE CHEAPEST
CONTRACT AND THEN THAT MEANS YOU
KNOW YOU'RE ON A CRICKET OR
METRO PCS KIND OF SYSTEM.
NO OFFENSE -- YOU KNOW.
SHE JUST SLAMMED THE WHOLE I DID
NOT I TELL A PHONE COMPANY.
MY GRANDMOTHER HAD A JUNE BUG SO.
BUT I'M JUST I'M SAYING I ALSO
HOPE THAT NOT HAVING THE
CHEAPEST CONTRACT.
DOESN'T LIMIT THE VALUE YOU KNOW
INVEST VALUE IS ALSO IMPORTANT
TO BECAUSE NOT ONLY IS A FAMILY
AND FRIENDS BUT IT'S ALSO
COUNSEL.
IT'S COUNCIL THAT ARE TALKING TO
INCARCERATED PEOPLE'S AND
FIGURING OUT A WAY TO ELIMINATE
FOLKS IS ABILITY TO HAVE THEIR
DUE PROCESS AND THEY HAVE
COUNSEL DR THEM BECAUSE THEY'RE
POOR.
IS.
IN MY OPINION UNCONSCIONABLE SO
THAT IS A VERY LONG WAY OF
SAYING THAT I'M GOING TO BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL.
AND IF I MAY REFER THIS BURKE
REPLIED TO COME WITH ME THAT BY
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THANK YOU
BOTH VERY MUCH AND I WANT TO BE
CLEAR THIS BILL DOESN'T
ELIMINATE.
THE INMATE WELFARE FUND WHAT
WE'RE SAYING IS -- I AM ASKING
THE SHERIFF'S INDIVIDUALLY AND
COLLECTIVELY TO DO THE SAME DUE
DILIGENCE WE ALL DO PERSONALLY.
IF TARGET HAS.
DEODORANT FOR TWENTY DOLLARS THE
TWO WHEN I CAN GET IT ON AMAZON
PRIME OR COSCO.
FOR FIVE I'M GOING FOR THE FIVE
DOLLAR OPTION NO ONE HERE WOULD
WILLINGLY PAY TWENTY DOLLARS.
FOR TWO BUT DEODORANT WHEN YOU
COULD HAVE A COMPETITIVE OPTION
AND IF YOU'RE IN COUNTY JAIL YOU
DON'T HAVE THAT OPTION.
AS AN INCARCERATED PERSON.
THE SHARE OF DOES HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DO THOSE NEGOTIATIONS
IN THE CONTRACT.
WITH REGARD TO THE INMATE
WELFARE FUND AND HOW THE FUNDS
ARE USED.
AT THE END OF FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN ALAMEDA COUNTY
HAD A BALANCE OF EIGHT POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS IN THEIR INMATE
WELFARE FUND.
LA COUNTY THE IN THE FISCAL YEAR
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN HAD A BALANCE OF
TWENTY NINE POINT NINE MILLION
DOLLARS.
AT THE END OF FISCAL YEAR
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN SAN FRANCISCO
HAD A BALANCE OF TWO POINT ONE
MILLION.
HOW THE MONIES HAVE BEEN SPENT
FOR FISCAL YEAR FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
ALAMEDA COUNTY -- TOLD
EXPENDITURES WERE EIGHT POINT
ONE MILLION OF WHICH THREE POINT
TWO WAS SPENT ON QUOTE
ADMINISTRATION.
INCLUDING SALARIES VEHICLES
OFFICE SUPPLIES BANK FEES
VOLUNTEER TRAINING CELLPHONES
AND NETWORK.
IN MAKES SERVICE EXPENDITURES
FROM THE FUN WERE ONE HUNDRED
AND THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS. FOR
FISCAL YEAR FIFTEEN FIXING THE
SAN FRANCISCO IDEA VIA.
TOLD EXPENDITURES WERE ONE POINT
TWO OF WHICH SIX HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND WERE FOR QUOTE
PERMANENT SALARIES AND FRINGE
BENEFITS.
SO I FULLY APPRECIATE THE
EXAMPLES THAT WERE HERE IN TERMS
OF THE GOOD WORK BEING DONE BY
IN MIGHT WELL FOR FUNDS.
BUT I DON'T BELIEVE [inaudible]
I SHOULD.
AS THE MOTHER LET'S SAY IF
INCARCERATED PERSON.
PUT MONEY ON THEIR BOOKS.
WEEKLY BECAUSE THEY CAN'T WORK
TO EARN.
IN AN ATTEMPT TO MAINTAIN
COMMUNICATION WITH MY CHILD OR
MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE TO PACE
TOOTHBRUSH DEODORANT.
AND SOAP.
AND THE BILL AND THE PROFIT FROM
THOSE EXPENDITURES EXPENDITURES
GO TO PAY FOR SALARIES THAT'S
WHAT BUDGETS ARE FOR IN GENERAL
FUND IS FOR TO PAY FOR CORPS
OPERATING COSTS FOR GOVERNMENT
SERVICES.
AGAIN EVEN WITH ALL OF THAT THIS
BILL DOES ELIMINATE THE FUN IT
JUST ASKS THAT SHARE US ON OUR
PRUDENT IN THEIR CONTRACTING
[inaudible]
MS WORKS.
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRING IN THE BILL AND THANK
YOUR WITNESSES WHO TESTIFIED --
TO THE WITH A PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE AND I THINK.
WHAT WE NEED TO BE DOING NOW IS
DOING EVERYTHING TO ENCOURAGE
CONNECTIVITY THE FOLKS WHO ARE
SERVING TIME WITH THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS AND THOSE THAT CARE
ABOUT THEM?
THAT'S HOW WE ULTIMATELY REDUCE
RECIDIVISM THAT'S HOW WE CREATE
SAFER COMMUNITIES I THINK THIS
BILL IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION THERE'S STILL A LOT
MORE TO DO IN THAT VEIN -- ALL
THE SUPPORTING AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK TO BE A CO
AUTHOR AS WELL.
THANK YOU ARE DEALING IN A
BACKUP POWER CAME.
YEAH I THINK I WOULD ASK A
COUPLE OF THE COMMENTS THAT MY
COLLEAGUES MADE BECAUSE AS AN
ATTORNEY MY CLIENTS USED TO THE
SYSTEM WHEN THEY NEED TO GET A
HOLD OF ME AND CAN USE THE OTHER
SYSTEMS.
AND YOU KNOW I THINK THAT IT'S
CRUCIAL THAT CAN ACTIVITY TO
BOTH COUNCIL WHICH IS A RIGHT
THESE FOLKS HAVE.
AS WELL AS CONNECTIVITY TO THEIR
FAMILIES IS CRUCIAL THAT THING
THAT WE TALK ABOUT IN THIS
COMMITTEE THE MOST IS HOW DO WE
REDUCE RECIDIVISM HOW DO WE GET
PEOPLE TO NOT COMMIT CRIMES TO
MAKE OUR COMMUNITIES SAFER TO
REDUCE THE AMOUNT WE AS A STATE
OR SPENDING.
ON INCARCERATING CALIFORNIANS
AND WE KNOW THE EVIDENCE SHOWS
THAT CONNECTIVITY TO THEIR
FAMILIES REDUCES RECIDIVISM WE
DON'T KNOW THAT ANY OF THE
THINGS THAT WERE MENTIONED IN
THESE FUNDS REDUCE RECIDIVISM
BECAUSE WE CAN'T GET THAT DATA.
SO THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT THIS
WILL REDUCE RECIDIVISM AND THAT
WE SHOULD DO IT AND THAT WE
SHOULD CONTINUE TO MOVE FOR IT
ANYTHING THAT MAKES OUR
COMMUNITY SAVERS AND REDUCES THE
AMOUNT WE ARE SPENDING ON
PRISONS.
THANK YOU OR ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
OF SENATOR YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH HAVE A SAY IN
CLOSING YOU KNOW.
WE SHOULD TALK ABOUT THIS
POPULATION IN OUR EFFORTS TO
SUPPORT THEM.
YOU KNOW NOT NECESSARILY A BILL
AT A TIME BUT IN TOTALITY THE
SHERIFFS AND OTHERS WERE
SUCCESSFUL IN KILLING AN EFFORT
A NUMBER OF YEARS AGO WHEN WE
WERE TRYING TO MAKE SURE THE
PEOPLE IN COUNTY JAILS HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE IN PERSON
VISITS -- THE THEY WERE
SUCCESSFUL ALONG WITH TO BE A
FIFTY IN CONVINCING THE GOVERNOR
THAT THAT WOULD BE -- I'LL DO --
FINANCIAL -- OUT LIABILITY IN
THAT MANY COUNTY JAILS NOW ARE
BEING BUILT WITHOUT IN PERSON
VISITATION ACCOMMODATIONS SO NOW
PEOPLE ARE BE LIMITED TO EVEN
HOW THEY CAN HAVE CONTACT WITH
THEIR LOVED ONES.
AND IT'S THROUGH PHONE OR
COMPUTER SERVICES NONE OF US
HERE WOULD KEEP A PHONE PLAN
THAT CHARGED US SEVENTEEN
DOLLARS FOR A FIFTEEN MINUTE
CALL.
NOBODY WOULD.
AND SO WHY THESE CONTRACTS ARE
ACCEPTABLE.
IN COUNTY FACILITIES IS BEYOND
ME.
SINCE WE HAVE ALREADY TAKEN
ACTION TO LIMIT THE WAY PEOPLE
COULD HAVE HUMAN CONTACT WITH
FAMILY MEMBERS.
WE LIMIT THEIR OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK IN JAIL TO EARN MONEY.
WE ARE NOW.
CHARGING THEM EXORBITANT FEES TO
TRY TO LIVE HUMANELY WHILE
INCARCERATED AND TO HAVE PHONE
CONTACT WITH THEIR CHILDREN.
WHAT MORE CAN WE ASK FROM THEM?
I THINK SB FIVE FIVE FIVE IS A
REASONABLE APPROACH.
WE ARE NOT ELIMINATING THE
WEALTH IN MAY WELL FOR FUN WE
ARE WE NAY MINUTES WHAT'S MORE
APPROPRIATE -- TO THOSE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED AND WE'RE GOING TO
LIMIT HOW IT CAN BE USE AND
WE'RE GOING TO ASK THE SHERIFF'S%
THE MIND THE CONTRACTS THAT THEY
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR FACILITATING.
JUST AS THEY WOULD THEIR OWN
CELL PHONE SERVICE OR COMPUTER
SERVICE OR WHAT THEY WOULD PAY
FOR DEODORANT AT HOME.
I THINK THAT'S A REASONABLE
EXPECTATION HAVING BEEN AN
EMPLOYER AND RUN ORGANIZATION TO
MANAGE BUDGETS.
WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
SENATOR I ENTER TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS AND LET ME.
JUST FOR FOR THE OPPOSITION TO
TO HOPEFULLY.
MAKE YOU UNDERSTAND.
WHAT WHAT WHAT A LOT OF MEMBERS
HERE SEE ON IS A TERM CALLED A
[inaudible]
INDENTURED SERVANTS.
ON THAT WAS USED.
WHEN YOU DO ACTUALLY PAY SOMEONE
BUT?
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO GO TO THE
COMPANY STORE BECAUSE THEY HAVE
TO PAY TO USE THE LAND BECAUSE
THEY HAVE TO RENT.
THE HOUSING AT THEIR AND THEY
CAN NEVER GET OUT OF INDENTURED
SERVITUDE.
AFTER SLAVERY DO A LOT OF SLAVE
TO COULDN'T LEAVE THE PLANTATION
BECAUSE OF INDENTURED SERVITUDE.
AND I THINK A LOT OF THIS IS
THIS FEEL OF JUSTICE PRISON
SYSTEM THAT JUST KEEPS YOU DARE
FINANCIALLY ECONOMICALLY.
AND SO WHAT YOU'RE HEARING FROM
A LOT OF MEMBERS IS IT WE DON'T
NEED TO PERPETUATE THAT AND AND
WHAT YOU'RE HEARING FROM THE
SENATOR -- I USED TO DO
COMPETITIVE BIDDING [inaudible]
TO AND LOWEST COMPETITIVE BID
DOESN'T MEAN DOES THE LOWEST
NUMBER IT MEANS COMPETITIVE.
AND YOU SHOULD GET YOU SHOULD
THE BOSS BANG FOR YOUR BUCK WHEN
IT COMES. TO TO TO WHAT YOU GET
FOR FOR ANY SERVICE.
I THINK WHAT THE PROBLEM IS IT'S
THE SAME WITH A COMPANY STORE.
THEY BY THE SOAP. FOR FIVE
DOLLARS BUT G. [inaudible]
FOR SIXTY THAT'S NOT.
THAT'S NOT GOOD AND THAT'S
WHAT'S THAT'S WHAT IT'S LOOKING
LIKE RIGHT NOW AND THEN USE THAT
MONEY -- IN THIS INTIMATE
WELFARE FUND FOR WHAT I THINK
THE LEGISLATURE BELIEVE YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO USE A CERTAINWAY.
AND MAY WE DIDN'T PUT ENOUGH --
SPECIFIC.
REQUIRED WHO JUSTICE MAYBE JUST
ASSUME.
THAT YOU WOULD KNOW WHAT TO DO
THAT IT WOULD GO DIRECTLY TO THE
FOR THE INMATES AND NOT FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE OTHER THINGS AND
SO HOPEFULLY THIS HELPS CLARIFY
THAT.
SUCH YOU CAN GO AHEAD AND
CONTINUE TO HAVE THESE CONTRACTS
WHICH NO ONE'S TRYING TO STOP IT
BUT YOU'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO MAKE
A PROFIT OFF OF IT -- I GUESS IS
WHAT WE'RE SAYING.
GO AHEAD AND GET THE BEST
PROVIDERS SO THAT YOU CAN
PROVIDE THE SERVICES TO THE IN
MAY -- AND YOU SHOULDN'T HAVE A
MARKUP OF A 1000% NINETY THAT'S
WHERE WE'RE GOING WITH THIS AND
AND SAID SHE ULTIMATELY DIDN'T
GET THAT MONEY BACK TO HELP.
WITH THE WELFARE AS I HEARD SOME
OF YOUR COLLEAGUES TALK ABOUT --
TRAINING.
LANGUAGE TRAINING GETTING BETTER
EDUCATION AND OTHER THINGS SO
THAT WE DO THAT BECAUSE THAT I
THINK THAT'S WHAT.
ULTIMATELY BOTH THE SHERIFF'S
AND WHAT WE ALL WANT TO DO.
AND SO CHAIRED RECOMMENDING AN
AYE.
VOTE.
ON SB FIVE FIVE FIVE THE MISSION
IS TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER CHEN SIR
I LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BARRICADE HAND
BARRICADE HAD I'D DEEP
[inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WICKS HI WICKS I THE
MEASURE PASSES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ARE SB SEVEN ONE SIX JUVENILE
DELINQUENCY POST SECONDARY
ACADEMIC AND CAREER TECHNICAL
TRAINING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THIS BILL
CAME ABOUT AS A RESULT OF SENATE
DEMOCRATIC.
POLICY RETREAT COUPLE YEARS AGO
WE HAD A YOUNG MAN COME FOR TO
TALK ABOUT HIS EXPERIENCE -- IN
JUVENILE HALL OVER A PROLONGED
PERIOD OF TIME IT WAS UPON HIS
RELEASE AND ENTERING COMMUNITY
COLLEGE THAT HE REALLY.
FULLY BEGAN TO EMBRACE -- THE
HOW.
FAR SHORT HE HAD FALLEN IN TERMS
OF HIS OWN ACADEMIC PURSUITS --
WE SPEND A YEAR WE PUT TOGETHER
A TASK FORCE LOOK DID JUVENILE
HALLS AND YOU LOOK CAPS REALLY
ACROSS THE STATE TO REALLY BEGIN
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT.
THE EXPERIENCE YOUNG PEOPLE WERE
HAVING VERTICALLY WITH REGARD TO
THERE ARE -- EDUCATIONAL
ATTAINMENT -- WHILE INCARCERATED --
A THOUGHTFUL HELPFUL EXPERIENCE
FOR ME TO SEE THE VARIOUS MODELS
ACROSS THE STATE BILL THAT ARE
WORKING THOSE THAT ARE NOT.
AND FROM THAT EXPERIENCE WE'VE
HAD A COUPLE OF BILLS -- COME TO
US -- AND THIS IS ONE OF THEM
SENATE BILL SEVEN SIXTEEN WILL
TAKE A CORRECTIVE STEPS TOWARDS
ENSURING THAT INCARCERATED YOUTH
WHO ALREADY HOLD A HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA HAVE ACCESS TO A COLLEGE
EDUCATION AND CAREER VOCATIONAL
TRAINING.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA LAW DOES
NOT REQUIRED YOU WILL FACILITIES
TO PROVIDE POST SECONDARY
PROGRAMS FOR THESE YOU.
STATUTES ONLY REQUIRES COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND THE
DIVISION OF JUVENILE FACILITY TO
PROVIDE A FULL HIGH SCHOOL
CURRICULUM TO YOUTH IN CUSTODY.
WHO HAVE NOT COMPLETED HIGH
SCHOOL SO FOR THOSE OF COMPLETED
HIGH SCHOOL LITERALLY HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH THEIR TIME
ALL DAY WHILE THEY'RE
INCARCERATED?
ALTHOUGH THERE IS NO STATUTORY
OBLIGATION FOR THE CO WITH
PROVIDE POST SECONDARY EDUCATION
PROGRAM FOR HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES IN CUSTODY.
STATE REGULATIONS DO REQUIRE
COUNTY PROBATION TO ENSURE THAT
ALL YOUTH IN THEIR FACILITIES.
ARE TREATED EQUALLY WITH REGARD
TO EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS
ADDITIONALLY THE YOUTH BILL OF
RIGHTS STATES THAT YOU IN D. J.
F. THE STILL THESE HAVE THE
RIGHT TO RECEIVE A QUALITY
EDUCATION.
THE YOUTH BILL OF RIGHTS DOES
NOT PLACE AT AGE OR GRADE LEVEL
LIMITATION ON THESE RIGHTS.
WE'VE HEARD VARIOUS CONCERNS
FROM THE CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICERS REGARDING TIMING OF
SEMESTER SCHEDULES UNFUNDED
INFRASTRUCTURE IN STAFFING COSTS
OF THE SHORT LENGTH OF STAY WE
BELIEVE -- WITH THE HELP -- OF
THE COMMITTEES TECHNICAL MEMBERS
THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING TODAY AND
WORK THAT WE'VE DONE THAT WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO ADDRESS STYLES --
WE'VE MINUTE THE BILL TO
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS COURSE
ELIGIBILITY AND COURSE
SCHEDULING CONCERNS -- WE
UNDERSTAND THAT WITH REGARD TO
THE UNFUNDED INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
THERE IS A ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FOUR FORTY EIGHT THAT ALREADY
MANDATES THE COUNTY FACILITIES
PROVIDE ACCESS TO INTERNET AND
COMPUTER TECHNOLOGY. FOR
PURPOSES OF EDUCATION SO THESE
YOU COULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR
TUITION WAIVERS THEREFORE THERE
SHOULDN'T BE ANY ADDITIONAL
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH TUITION
THEY COULD TAKE THE CLASSES ON
LAKE ONLINE IN.
TUITION HAS BEEN WAY.
I WITH REGARD TO THEIR THE
RELATIVE INCONSISTENT YOU KNOW
SENTENCING LENGTH OF STAY IN
VERY FUEL FACILITIES.
THAT'S WHY MAKING SURE THAT
THESE CAN AUG COURSES ARE
AVAILABLE ONLINE SO THE YOUTH
WITHOUT THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CONTINUE THEIR EDUCATION ONCE
THEIR RELEASE -- WE AGREE THAT
THE BILL SHOULD -- REQUIRE A
POSTSECONDARY AND VOCATIONAL
PLAN -- AND WE WOULD LOVE TO BE
ABLE TO BOLSTER KIND OF THE THE
BREADTH AND SCOPE OF THIS BILL
WITH THE INCLUSION OF SUCH A
PLAN BUT IT SHOULD NOT BE TAKEN
IN LIEU OF ACTUALLY PROVIDING
PROGRAMMING.
IT SHOULD NOT BE EITHER OR
IDEALLY BOTH BUT MINIMALLY WE'RE
AXE IN THROUGH THIS BILL THAT
PROGRAM MAY BE MADE AVAILABLE WE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH C. P.
L. C. AS WE HAVE. TO TALK ABOUT --
HOW WE COULD BOLSTER THE BILL TO
INCLUDE THE PROVISION OF THE
PLAN?
A QUALITY EDUCATION HAS THE
POWER TO READ THE LETTER RE
DIRECT THE LIVES OF ANYBODY
YOUTH OR ADULT ESPECIALLY THOSE.
TOUCHED BY THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM EDUCATION AND VOCATIONAL
TRAINING DEVELOPS OCCUPATIONAL
SKILLS AT LEAST THE PRODUCTIVE
CAREER PATH WHICH IN TURN
REDUCES RECIDIVISM.
AND FUTURE INVOLVEMENT WITH ANY
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
SOME LOCALITIES ALREADY HAVE
THESE TYPES OF PARTNERSHIPS AND
PROGRAMS IN PLACE ONE OF THOSE
PROJECTS IS PROJECT CHANGE IN
THE COLLEGE OF SAN MATTEO.
DID CHANGES THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SUPPORT A PROGRAM THAT
PROVIDES A WRAPAROUND STUDENT
SUPPORT SERVICES DIRECT ACCESS
TO POST SECONDARY EDUCATION FOR
INCARCERATED YOUTH AND ACTUALLY
IN PERSON COLLEGE INSTRUCTION.
INSIDE YOU WILL YOU FACILITIES
WITH ME TODAY IS KATIE BLISS
PROJECT DIRECTOR OF PROJECT
CHANGE.
AND LUCY CARTER.
POLICY ADVOCATE FOR USE
LAWCENTERI ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
YES.
GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE. TWENTY
ONE YEARS AGO I SAT IN A DIMLY
LIT CELL ON A PAPER THIN
MATTRESS IN JUVENILE HALL.
AND I FRANTICALLY WROTE A LETTER
TO THE JUDGE TO ADVOCATE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMPLETE MY HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA.
I SPENT THE MAJORITY OF MY HIGH
SCHOOL EDUCATION IN AND OUT OF
JUVENILE HALL AND WAS
INCARCERATED FOR THE MOST
CRITICAL YEARS WHEN I WOULD HAVE
BEEN GOING TO A PROM.
OR WALKING ACROSS THE STAGE FOR
MY HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION
INSTEAD I WAS LOCKED UP AND
LOCKED OUT OF THE FUTURE.
I COULD BARELY SEE A WAY OUT AT
THAT TIME IN MY LIFE.
AT THAT TIME THE PRIORITY FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE AND THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM WAS NOT EDUCATION.
AND THERE CERTAINLY WAS A DIRECT
SUPPORT FOR GOING TO COLLEGE
I'VE FOUGHT HARD TO COMPLETE MY
HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA AND WHEN I
WAS RELEASED FROM CUSTODY THE
IDEA OF COLLEGE WAS THE FURTHEST
THING FROM MY MIND.
HOWEVER AFTER A SERIES OF
UNFORTUNATE EVENTS POST RELEASE
IT BECAME CRYSTAL CLEAR THAT
DESPITE NEVER IMAGINING MYSELF
TO BE COLLEGE MATERIAL.
I WOULD NEED TO ENROLL IN MY
LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGE IF I
WERE TO EVER HAVE A SHOT AT A
SUCCESSFUL FUTURE.
NAVIGATING COLLEGES DIFFICULT
FOR ANYBODY -- WHEN YOU'RE
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCES
DISJOINTED FROM BEING INVOLVED
IN THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM
THE PATH IS PAVED WITH WHAT CAN
SEEM LIKE INSURMOUNTABLE
OBSTACLES?
I WAS REALLY LUCKY THAT I FOUND
SUPPORTIVE PROFESSORS COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND PEERS
COMING FROM OTHER CHALLENGING
EXPERIENCES HE WOULD HELP ME TO
MAKE IT THROUGH COLLEGE.
I ENDED UP TRANSFERRING TO THE
UNIVERSITY OBTAINING MY
BACHELOR'S DEGREE AND WENT ON TO
COMPLETE GRADUATE WORK WITH THE
GOAL TO TEACH AND BE OF SERVICE
TO OTHER YOUNG PEOPLE WOULD
STRUGGLE TO OBTAIN AN EDUCATION.
BUT MY EXPERIENCE MAKING IT OUT
OF THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM
AND GRADUATING FROM COLLEGE IS A
RARE WHEN AS STATISTICS TELL US
MOST YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED AND IN THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM GOING TO ENTER
THE ADULT PRISON SYSTEM AND
RARELY DO THOSE WHO MAKE IT OUR
EARN.
A COLLEGE DEGREE IT'S
OPPORTUNITIES TO PURSUE COLLEGE
WHILE STILL IN CUSTODY THAT WILL
GIVE YOUNG PEOPLE IN THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM A
PIPELINE TO HIGHER EDUCATION
RATHER THAN TO PRESS THEM.
AFTER GRADUATE SCHOOL I RETURNED
TO MY FORMER COMMUNITY COLLEGE
TO TEACH ENGLISH.
I DID THIS FOR EIGHT YEARS
BEFORE CREATING PROJECT CHANGE
WHICH IS A COMPREHENSIVE COLLEGE
PROGRAM THAT ASSIST YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN IN THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM ACCESS HIGHER
EDUCATION.
THIS PROGRAM IS THAT THE SAME
JUVENILE HALL WHERE I WAS ONCE
INCARCERATED.
AND INCREDIBLY AND THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THIS PROGRAM I
WORKED ALONGSIDE MY OLD
PROBATION OFFICER WHO WOULD
BECOME THE DEPUTY CHIEF OF THESE
DECADES LATER.
ALL OF US IN THIS ROOM KNOW THAT
COLLEGE IS THE POWER TO CHANGE
LIVES A COLLEGE EDUCATION
CREATES JOB OPPORTUNITIES IF
AUTHORS LEADERSHIP.
AND IMPROVE THE SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC WELL BEING OF STUDENTS
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES SENATE
BILL SEVEN SIXTEEN IS THE RIGHT
NEXT MOVE TO CREATE ACCESS FOR
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE AND THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM TO
ACHIEVE A HIGHER EDUCATION.
AND THIS ACCESS IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT FOR YOUNG PEOPLE IN
CUSTODY WHO HAVE FOUGHT SO HARD
TO COMPLETE HIGH SCHOOL.
THE STUDENTS IN PROJECT CHANGE
TAKE COLLEGE COURSES FOR CREDIT
FROM COLLEGE PROFESSORS WHILE
THEY'RE INCARCERATED AT THE
JUVENILE HALL AND ONCE THEY'RE
RELEASED THEY TAKE COURSES ON
CAMPUS AT THE COLLEGE.
THESE STUDENTS ARE LEADERS IN
THE COMMUNITY AND ON CAMPUS THEY
SPEAK AT CONFERENCES THEY GO
BACK TO THE JUVENILE HALL TO
SHARE THEIR STORIES TO HELP
OTHER YOUNG PEOPLE FIND THEIR
WAY TO COLLEGE.
WE HAVE STUDENTS THIS YEAR
GRADUATING.
GOING TO SAN FRANCISCO STATE SAN
JOSE STATE AND UCLA.
COLLEGE LEVEL EDUCATION FOR
INCARCERATED YOUTH AS DESCRIBED
IN SENATE BILL SEVEN SIXTEEN
WILL NOT BE COSTLY WE PROVIDE
THIS SERVICE AND PROJECT CHANGE
IN A COMPRISES ONLY A SMALL
PORTION OF OUR OVERALL BUDGET.
MORE IMPORTANTLY THE SECONDARY
COST SAVINGS FROM CHANGING THE
PATH OF THESE YOUNG PEOPLE TO
PREVENT FUTURE CRIMINAL ACTIVITY
AND INCARCERATION AS ADULTS IS
PROFOUND.
COLLEGE CAN BREAK THE CYCLE OF
RECIDIVISM AND TRANSFORM
FORMALLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS IN THE COMMUNITY
LEADERS THE AND ROLE MODELS.
WHEN A STUDENT OBTAINS A COLLEGE
EDUCATION IT THIS DOESN'T JUST
IMPACT THEM AS AN INDIVIDUAL AND
AS A RIPPLE EFFECT?
THAT POSITIVELY ALTERS PATHWAYS
FOR THEIR FAMILY FRIENDS AND
COMMUNITY SUMMARILY NOT ONLY ARE
THE UP FRONT COST OF SENATE BILL
SEVEN SIXTEEN LOW BUT THE
FINANCIAL SAVINGS THAT WILL BE
IMPARTED UPON OUR STATE AND
SOCIETY WILL BE SUBSTANTIAL.
OUR SUCCESSFUL EXPERIENCE
SETTING UP COLLEGE PROGRAMMING
INSIDE A JUVENILE HALL
ILLUSTRATES THIS IS A VERY CHEAP
A BALL AND PRACTICAL TASK.
IT'S JUST A FEW SHORT YEARS OUR
COLLEGE PROGRAMMING HAS ASSISTED
HUNDREDS OF STUDENTS IN JUVENILE
DETENTION AND TO ACHIEVE THEIR
POST SECONDARY EDUCATIONAL GOALS
WITH MINIMAL FINANCIAL
INVESTMENT.
AS A RESULT OF USING ALREADY
EXISTING RESOURCES THROUGH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM MOST OF
THE STUDENTS ENROLLED IN OUR
PROGRAM AND IN THE TYPES OF
SERVICES SENATE BILL SEVEN
SIXTEEN PROPOSES ARE STILL IN
HIGH SCHOOL.
AND THEREFORE QUALIFY FOR FEE
WAIVERS FOR CREE CURRENTLY
ENROLLED STUDENTS THEY'RE
GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL AT THE
VAST MAJORITY OF STUDENTS
QUALIFY FOR FINANCIAL AID AND I
TUITION AND BOOKS COVERED.
THE COST OFFER COURSES INSIDE
DETENTION FACILITIES ARE VERY
SMALL BUT THE RESULT IS HUGE AND
POSITIVE AND PACKS.
ACCESS TO HIGHER EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE SO WHEN FOR ALL AND FOR
THESE REASONS I ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT SENATE BILL SEVEN
SIXTEEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THE WITNESSES.
YOU'RE OUT ONE MINUTE THIS IS
LUCY SALCEDO CARTER I'M THE
POLICY ADVOCATE WITH THE YOUTH
LAWCENTER WERE SPONSORING THE
BILL AND I'M JUST AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WHEN I PUT
IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF HIS
SOLUTION BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
RESIDENTS ALSO BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS WE STAND STRONG SUPPORT.
AT MADDY HIGHER THE CALIFORNIA
CIVIL LIBERTIES ADVOCACY IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
SAM MEASURE WITH THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
SUPPORT.
MARCO GEORGE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
MIKE A DOCTOR OFF ON BEHALF OF
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
I MIGHT IS LEBRON ON BEHALF OF
THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ARE ANY WITNESSES NOT POSITION.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS --
DANIEL SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA I FIRST WANT TO START
BY.
THANKING SENATOR MITCHELL AND
AND HER STAFF IMMENSELY -- FOR
HAVING AN OPEN DOOR AND FOR
HAVING A DIALOGUE WITH US OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE -- WHILE WE ARE
NOTED -- IT IN OPPOSITION IT IS
IN PART DUE TO SOME OF THE I
TECHNICAL LANGUAGE IN ASPECTS
THAT WE ARE CONTINUING TO TALK
ABOUT WE ABSOLUTELY IN VERY MUCH
AGREE WITH THE SPIRIT OF THE
BILL ARE SUPPORTIVE OF WHAT TO
CHECK IT'S TRYING TO DO -- THERE
ARE SOME THINGS THAT WERE NOTED
IN THE OPENING AS TO HOW TO
OPERATIONALIZE SOME OF THE
SCHEDULING -- IMPACTS --
INVOLVED IN THE BILL -- WE ALSO
WANT TO FURTHER EXPLORE WE HAVE
HEARD AS OF LATE THAT -- GETTING
ACCESS TO SOME OF THE TECHNOLOGY
THAT ALREADY EXISTS IN OUR HALL
VIA OUR EDUCATIONAL PARTNERSHIPS
WITH COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION --
IS SOMETHING THAT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE UNDERSTAND HOW BEST
TO DO THAT AND BUILD UPON THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT EXISTS IN
THAT REGARD IN SO -- AGAIN WHILE
WE ARE OPPOSED TODAY WE VERY
MUCH LOOK FORWARD TO FOR THE
CONVERSATIONS AND SITTING DOWN
THEY'VE BEEN VERY PRODUCTIVE --
WE ARE VERY HOPEFUL AND WANT TO
GET TO A GOOD PLACE ON THIS BILL --
AND SO -- WE LOOK FORWARD TO
THOSE THOSE CONVERSATIONS AND I
APPRECIATE AGAIN THE THE OPEN
DOOR AND WILLINGNESS TO HEAR US
OUT THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
AND ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
AS SEEN ON ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
CNN YOU MAY CLOSE.
UP MISS BLISS IS A LIVING
EXAMPLE OF WHY WE ALL COME TO
WORK EVERY DAY TO TRY TO MAKE
SURE GOVERNMENT WORKS FOR THE
PEOPLE IN A CONSTRUCTIVE HELPFUL
WAY.
I THINK COLLEGE ALSO CAN BREAK
THE CYCLE OF POVERTY ON AND FOR
THOSE REASONS I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
ABOUT.
THANK YOU IN THE CHAIR RECOMMEND
TONIGHT -- CALL THE ROLL.
ON SB SEVEN SIXTEEN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER.
HI GEN SIR HI LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BARRICADE CAN
BARRICADE HAND I DEEP
[inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE HI [inaudible]
QUIRK.
WORK I SAN DIEGO SAN DIEGO HI
WICKS WICKS HI.
YOU HAVE UNANIMOUS I AM ONE A
MAN.
GRADUATION I GOT ALL.
CREATE YOUR PATIENT [inaudible]
CENTRE BELL. FIVE ZERO ONE I SEE
[inaudible]
DID YOU [inaudible] TWO ZERO
ITEM NUMBER.
TEN OUR SB -- FOUR EIGHT FIVE
DRIVING PRIVILEGE SUSPENSION OR
DELAY.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU -- FOR
ALLOW ME TO PRESENT SB -- FORTY
FIVE THIS BILL PROHIBITS THE
SUSPENSION OF DRIVER'S LICENSE
FOR A NON VEHICLE RELATED CRIME.
AND SUSPENDING A DRIVER'S
LICENSE -- KIND OF BECAME A
POPULAR.
METHOD OF PUNISHMENT IN THE
NINETEEN NINETIES WHETHER OR NOT
A CRIME HAD ANYTHING DO WITH
OPERATING A VEHICLE -- AND IT'S
REALLYSTRANGE BECAUSE SOME
CRIMES HAVE THIS IN SOME KIND
STONE IS IT'S COMMA HAPHAZARDLY --
BEEN APPLIED -- IT DOES NOT
INCREASE PUBLIC SAFETY IT ONLY
DETERS A PERSON'S ABILITY TO
CARE FOR THE CHILDREN WORK.
AND MAINTAIN EMPLOYMENT AND PAY
RESTITUTION WHEN I BECAME
CHAIRMAN OF THE SENATE --
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE.
OF ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS WE
DID IS WE WENT AND VISITED THE
HOMELESS SHELTER FOR WOMEN HERE
IN SACRAMENTO AND WE TALK TO THE
WOMEN IN THE SHELTER AND FOUND
THAT A LOT OF WEREN'T ABLE TO
FIND WORK BECAUSE THEY HAVE
THEIR CARS TAKEN AWAY FROM.
AND A LOT OF THEM HAVE CHILDREN
THAT WERE IN THE TAKEN AWAY FROM
ALSO BECAUSE THE CAR WAS TAKEN
AWAY FROM.
SO IF IT HURTS TO ME THAT --
THIS HAS -- A DEFINITE IMPACT ON
A LOT OF OTHER ISSUES AND AND
THEREFORE -- TONIGHT VOTE I
THINK THIS WOULD HELP -- PEOPLE
IT HAS NO IMPACT ON THE CRIMINAL.
OF CODE THAT ONLY DEALS WITH THE
VEHICLE CAUGHT.
SO -- TIME BUT WE HAVE WITNESSES.
GOOD MORNING -- MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS LAURIE DOYLE ABOUT THE
CONFERENCE A CALIFORNIA BAR
ASSOCIATIONS.
THE ANALYSIS -- GOES INTO A
GREAT DEAL ABOUT THE BENEFITS OF
THE BILL ON WHY IT'S A GOOD IDEA.
IT'S JUST LIKE TO REEMPHASIZE
ONE THING THAT.
ON THE BOTTOM OF PAGE FOR IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE HOWEVER.
THAT IRRESPECTIVE OF THE CHANGES
MADE BY THIS BILL RECORD WILL
RETAIN ITS AUTHORITY TO ORDER
THE PERSON'S LICENSE BE
SUSPENDED OR REVOKED.
AS A RESULT IN A CONVICTION FOR
A FELONY OFFENSE.
PROVIDED THAT THERE IS A NEXUS
BETWEEN THE COMMISSION OF THE
OFFENSE AND THE VEHICLE.
IN ORDER OTHER WORDS THE BILL
ALLOWS THE COURTS TO CONTINUE.
TO DISPENSE JUSTICE TO CRAFT --
SENTENCES THAT ARE APPROPRIATE
UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES BUT DO
NOT REFLECT JUST THE A ****
NILLY.
THIS IS A GOOD IDEA TO TAKE A
LICENSE AWAY EVEN THOUGH THE THE
UNDERLYING CRIME HAD ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE VEHICLE
AND THE VEHICLE WAS USED DURING
THE COMMISSION THEREOF.
AND OR A WITNESSES.
FOR ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT SECONDS ALL SOME
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS WE
STAND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MARCO GEORGE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MIKE A DOCTOR OFF ON BEHALF OF
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
CNN ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
ALL THIS COM LOG DOVE YOU GET TO
GO FIRST BEFORE MISTER QUICK
COURT DOES.
BILL AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR LAN PROBLEM GETTING HIM
WE HAD A HERE YOU.
WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK TO BE ADDED
AS A CO AUTHOR.
THANK YOU.
THAT THE DO SO [inaudible]
MOM.
THIS JUST BRINGS ME SORT OF FULL
CIRCLE BACK -- I ASKED TO BE ON
PUBLIC SAFETY WHEN I STARTED
THAT THIS IS MY SEVENTH YEAR ON
THE COMMITTEE.
AND I LOOK BACK AT THESE YEARS --
AT THE MITCHELL BILLS WE JUST
DID IT YOUR BILL.
AND WE'VE REALLY ACCOMPLISHED A
LOT WE'VE GOTTEN RID OF A NUMBER
OF SENTENCING ENHANCEMENTS.
WE'VE TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT THAT
PEOPLE IN THEIR EARLY TWENTIES
ARE NOT NECESSARILY FULLY
CAPABLE OF UNDERSTANDING WHAT
THEY'VE DONE.
UP WE'VE DâN WE'VE PREVENTED A
LOT OF BAD BILLS FROM COMING
FORWARD.
I REALLY THINK AS I LOOK BACK ON
MY SEVEN YEARS THAT THIS IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT COMMITTEE I'VE
BEEN ON AND YOUR BILL IS A GOOD
EXAMPLE OF WHY IT IS SO
IMPORTANT. FOR ME AND FOR THE
REST OF US TO DO THE GOOD WORK
WE DO HERE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENT.
YOU MAY CLOSE CENTER -- URGENT
AYE VOTE -- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
AND I I TO WANT TO BE ADDED ON
AS A CO AUTHOR -- I TO SIMILAR
BILL SO I DISS VERY COMMITTED TO
ME YEAH YOU GOT A BILL SIMILAR
TO THIS YEAH WE APPRECIATE THAT
[inaudible]
SO.
CHAIRS RECOMMENDED I VOTE.
SB FOUR EIGHTY FIVE THE MISSION
IS TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER AYE JONES
ARE AYE LACKEY.
BARRY CAM BARRICADE HAD I DEEP
[inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
HAMMACHER DOVE I IN AN AMEN
QUIRK.
QUIRK ICE SAN DIEGO.
SAN DIEGO HI WICKS.
WICKS I THANK YOU ALL TAKE THE
MINUTES MY ANNIVERSARY. THIRTY
SIX YEARS THANK YOU ALL RIGHT.
I GUESS WE'LL BE ADDING A MEN TO
ALL THE THAT ARE I A MEN.
ALSO LIKE TO MAKE AN
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT LIFE HILL
DRIVING UNDER THE INFLUENCE
IGNITION INTERLOCK DEVICES HAS
BEEN PULLED BY THE AUTHOR.
AND WE HAVE THREE MORE SENATORS
[inaudible]
GALGIANI HUESO [inaudible]
M. WILK [inaudible]
YEAH -- AT WE'RE NOW GOING TO DO
SOME ADD ONS SO THAT. FOR THE
MEMBERS WHO HAD TO GO TO
COMMITTEE TO PRESENT.
ON SB TWO SEVENTY THREE BY
SENATOR RUBIO KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK.
WORK I SANTIAGO [inaudible]
THANK YOU
.
ITEM NUMBER -- FIVE SB.
THREE THREE EIGHT OUR SENIOR AND
DISABILITY VICTIMIZATION LAW
ENFORCEMENT POLICIES.
FROM MY FAVORITE SENATOR DON'T
TELL ANYBODY ELSE STUFF.
MOVE THIS WONDERFUL L. RESTATED.
I JUST SIMPLY MUST CHAIR MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- I'M PROUD
TO PRESENT SB THREE THREE EIGHT
A BILL THAT.
SEEKS TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS FROM
HARMON ABUSE -- THIS BILL --
WOULD CREATE THIS -- CALIFORNIA
SENIOR DISABILITY JUSTICE ACT
WHICH WILL GIVE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TOOL TO
BETTER PROTECT SENIOR CITIZENS.
AND CALIFORNIANS LIVING WITH
DISABILITIES FROM ABUSE SEXUAL
ASSAULT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE HATE
CRIMES AND MURDER -- FOR THE
FIRST TIME ANYWHERE THIS BILL
LIST ALL CALIFORNIA LAWS
SPECIFICALLY PROTECTING -- THE
THESE OF A OF POPULATIONS -- IN
IN TRAINING MANUALS AND THERE
WILL BE -- SPECIFICALLY --
INFORMATION -- ON THESE LAWS
LISTED AS WELL AS BETTER
TRAINING -- FOR OUR OFFICERS ON
HOW DO I IDENTIFY -- INSTANCES
OF ABUSE AND HOW -- SPECIFICALLY --
THE OF PEOPLE -- OR OR A OF
ABOUT CRIMINAL ELEMENT TARGETS
ABUSE OF THESE INDIVIDUALS SO --
I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE TO
WITNESSES THAT WOULD I'D LIKE TO
OFFER THEIR TESTIMONY TODAY ON
THIS VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE WE
HAVE.
GRADE THIS YEAR REPRESENTING THE
ARK OF CALIFORNIA AND PHYLLIS
CALL BACK -- OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE RETIREES THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE AND IF YOU'LL ALLOW
ME GESTURE.
OKAY.
MY FATHER PHILIP SETTLES PASSED
AWAY IN SEPTEMBER OF TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN IN TENNESSEE.
HE AND HE HAD BEEN DIAGNOSED BY
THE VETERANS HOSPITAL.
AT MAY FOR CALIFORNIA WITH
SEVERE DEMENTIA HE WAS BLIND IN
ONE NIGHT GOING BLIND AND THE
OTHER HIT SUFFERED STROKES HE
COULD BARELY HEAR HIS BRAIN HAS
SHRUNK.
AND ACCORDING TO DOCTORS HE WAS
ONLY GOING TO GET WORSE.
WAR TWO AND KOREA [inaudible]
A WOMAN.
NAY MARGIE HOLD AND HER FAMILY
WHO AS IT TURNED OUT WERE
PROFESSIONAL THIEVES BEFRIENDED
HIM.
AND BEGAN STEALING FROM HIM.
AT ONE POINT MARGIE TOLD ME AND
I'M GOING TO QUOTE THIS.
SHE SAID TO ME PHYLLIS.
YOU REALLY DON'T UNDERSTAND I'M
TAKING EVERYTHING HE'S GOT.
ABSOLUTELY EVERYTHING AND
THERE'S NOTHING YOU CAN DO ABOUT
IT.
HE'S GOING TO GIVE IT TO ME.
WITH THE HELP OF A LAWYER IN A
FIDUCIARY.
I FIRST WANT TO SAY THEY KNEW
EXACTLY WHAT THEY WERE TALKING
ABOUT.
WITH THE HELP OF A LAWYER AND A
FIDUCIARY THEY TOOK HIM AWAY
FROM HIS HOME HERE IN RANCHO
CORDOVA.
FROM HIS LOVING FAMILY AND
CALIFORNIA TO TENNESSEE.
MY FAMILY WAS NOT TOLD ANYTHING
ABOUT THIS WE DID KNOW WHERE HE
WAS.
HE WAS ROBBED OF ABSOLUTELY
EVERYTHING HE OWNED WHICH
INCLUDED HOMES PROPERTY BANK
ACCOUNTS AND INVESTMENTS.
SINCE HE HAD NO BILLS THEY ALSO
TOOK OUT LOANS IN HIS NAME.
AND CHARGED UP HIS CREDIT CARDS.
THEN THEY LEFT HIM INJURED IN
THE STREET IN TENNESSEE TO DIE.
THE POLICE IN TENNESSEE PICKED
HIM UP AND AGAIN WHEN WE FOUND
OUT WHERE HE WAS EVENTUALLY HE
DIED.
MY SISTER AND BROTHER WERE
GETTING READY TO GO BACK THERE
AND HE DIED IN THE HOSPITAL.
HE DIED PENNILESS AND SURROUNDED
BY STRANGERS.
AFTER HE DIED BILL COLLECTOR
STARTED CALLING MY FAMILY AND
WANTING MONEY.
THAT WAS THAT THEY HAD CHARGED
UP HE IS BURIED IN TENNESSEE
EVEN THOUGH HE HAD PREPAID A
BURIAL SITE OUT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA NEXT TO MY MOTHER MY
DECEASED MOTHER.
ON HE HAD EVEN PURCHASED A
HEADSTONE.
WITH HIS NAME ON IT.
MY FATHER WAS TARGETED ISOLATED
ROBBED AND LEFT IN THE STREET TO
DIE BY THESE PROFESSIONAL
CRIMINALS AND THEY KNEW EXACTLY
WHAT THEY WERE DOING.
THIS IS WHAT THEY DO FOR A
LIVING.
MY FAMILY WENT TO THE POLICE TO
THE BANK SOCIAL SERVICES THE
VETERANS HOSPITAL LAWYERS AND
THE COURTS AND TO THE NEWSPAPERS.
NO ONE WOULD HELP US THE REASONS
FOR NOT HELPING RANGE FROM THE
ABSURD TO THE OUTRAGEOUS.
NOT OUR AGENCIES RESPONSIBILITY
NOT OUR PROBLEM I CAN'T TALK TO
YOU CAN'T SHOW MEDICAL RECORDS
TO THE COURT.
TOP SECRET.
NOT OUR PROBLEM FAMILY SQUABBLE
NOBODY CARES ANYMORE NOT
INTERESTING ENOUGH FOR THE PRESS
BORING.
MY FATHER DISAPPEARED AND SO DID
HIS PROPERTY NO ONE WAS COMING
TO HELP US TO FIGHT.
WE WERE ALONE.
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN I SPOKE
ON THE SUBJECT OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC STATE CONVENTION.
AFTER I SPOKEN THROUGHOUT THE
REST OF THE CONVENTION.
PEOPLE STARTED APPROACHING ME.
AND THEY SAID IN SORT OF HUSHED
WHISPERED VOICES.
THAT HAPPENED TO ME THAT
HAPPENED TO ME TO MY NEIGHBOR TO
MY MOTHER.
I'M SO ASHAMED THEY WERE COMING
TO ME LIKE RAPE VICTIMS.
TALKING ABOUT SOMETHING FOR THE
FIRST TIME.
THEY SAID TO ME.
TELL EVERYBODY PLEASE PLEASE I'M
SO ASHAMED.
AND I REALIZED AT THAT POINT
THAT WHAT HAPPENED TO MY FAMILY.
WAS NOT AN ISOLATED CRIME.
I SOON JOINED OF EVER ADVOCACY
GROUPS THAT ARE NOW FORMING ALL
ACROSS OUR COUNTRY.
AND THESE GROUPS ARE FORMING TO
FILL THE VOID TO HELP THE
VICTIMS AND TO EDUCATE AS TO
WHAT IS HAPPENING OUT THERE.
OUR LAURA OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
ABSOLUTELY DEVOTED TO PROTECTING
OUR VULNERABLE CITIZENS.
HOWEVER THEY ARE LACKING THE UP
TO DATE LEGAL AND ORGANIZATIONAL
TOOLS TO PROTECT OUR CITIZENS.
TODAY WE ARE EXPERIENCING
SOMETHING THAT HAS NEVER
HAPPENED IN THE HISTORY.
OF OUR OF OUR WORLD.
WE HAVE MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE LIVING DECADES AND
DECADES LONGER.
AND WE HAVE ACCUMULATED SOME
SORT OF WEALTH.
MAYBE IT'S A SOCIAL SECURITY
CHECK MAYBE IT'S A SMALL HOUSE.
THIS IS NEVER HAPPENED IN
HISTORY WE USUALLY HAVE A A VERY
A VERY SMALL GROUP OF VERY
WEALTHY PEOPLE AND EVERYBODY
ELSE HAS BEEN PEASANTS.
THESE ARE PREPARED TO TAKE IT
THEIR HEAD OF US.
THE WORLD HAS CHANGED AND OUR
LAWS ARE LACKING BEHIND.
WE MUST WE HAVE TO MOVE OUR LOSS
INTO THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY.
EDUCATION AND TRAINING
CONCERNING OUR AGED INVULNERABLE
FAMILY MEMBERS MUST BE MADE
AVAILABLE TO OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND TWO OTHER PROFESSIONALS IN
CALIFORNIA WE'VE GOT TO BE
BROUGHT UP TO WHERE WE ARE.
TODAY PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL
WHICH WILL GIVE OUR LORD LAW
ENFORCEMENT A TOOL NEEDED. TO
FIGHT THIS EGREGIOUS PROBLEM
THAT MAY.
AM VERY WELL WILL EMBRACE
ABSOLUTELY EVERYBODY IN THIS
ROOM.
NO MATTER HOW SMART YOU ARE HOW
EDUCATED YOU ARE [inaudible]
BELIEVE ME.
IT CAN HAPPEN TO YOU SO WE'VE
GOT TO GET ON TOP OF THAT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
OR ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT GREG HERE REPRESENTING
TED TWO WORKING DAYS TODAY THE
TO TO THE THREE CO CO SPONSORS
THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR
RETIRED AMERICANS AND THEY ARE
CAN UNITED CEREBRAL PALSY OF
CALIFORNIA.
THANK SENATOR HUESO FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS THIS VITAL
ISSUE -- YOU HAVE ABOUT A MINUTE
CAN OUT.
OKAY I JUST ONE EXAMPLE -- WHEN
AND -- I'VE BEEN DOING RESEARCH
ON THIS AS EVER I WAS IT HAS OR
UNTIL I EVENTUALLY CAME ACROSS
SOMEONE WHO ACTUALLY TALKED TO
WHO IS A ELDERLY WOMAN WITH
DISABILITIES ICAL DISABILITY.
WHO HAVE BEEN ABUSED IN SOME WAY
I DON'T REMEMBER WHETHER SHE
SAID IT WAS SEXUAL ABUSE OR WHAT
IT WAS?
WHO CALLED THE POLICE AND
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING HAPPENED HAD
NO RESPONSE -- AND BEEN ABLE TO
FIND OUT ANECDOTALLY AT LEAST
AND NOT JUST AND RELEASE --
RESEARCH SINCE THEN THERE WAS A
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE A NATIONAL
SURVEY.
OF VICTIMS AND THEIR FAMILIES
WHO REPORTED THAT AFTER THEY
WERE WHO WERE TOLD THE SURVEY
THAT AFTER THEY REPORTED.
THE ABUSE THE CRIME TO ABOUT
PLEASE 48% SAID NOTHING HAPPENED--
I'LL STOP THERE'D BE AVAILABLE
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
THOSE IN FAVOR MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MILLIE BYNUM ET W. ASKED
ME LOCAL THIRTY NINE THIRTY HERE
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
NUMBERS JOE RODRIGUEZ AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
STEPPING CHAVEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
MCGEORGE ELDER AND HEALTH CLINIC
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ARE ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
APOLOGIES IN SUPPORT NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ARE ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE MISTER SENATE AND
PLEA.
YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN MY PLEASURE
TO SERVE IN THIS LEGISLATURE AND
SEE.
LEGISLATORS FIGHTING TO PROTECT
SENIORS AND VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS THROUGH VARIOUS
LEGISLATIONS -- AND I AND I HAVE
SEEN.
A LOT OF THIS LEGISLATION COME
EVERY YEAR.
BUT THE LAWS ARE ONLY AS GOOD AS
WE CAN ENFORCE.
AND THIS BILL IS AN ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM TO MAKE SURE THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS.
EDUCATED ABOUT THESE LAWS THAT
THEY UNDERSTAND HOW TO ENFORCE
THESE LAWS AND HOW TO IDENTIFY
INSTANCES WHERE PEOPLE.
ARE ARE.
ABUSING OTHERS FOR THEIR OWN
PERSONAL GAIN.
SO -- I WANT TO THANK -- THE
THIS COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH
MY OFFICE TO ADVANCE BILL
FORWARD AND AND SIMPLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU CENTER
HUESO.
THANK YOU WITNESSES FOR FOR
BEING HERE TODAY.
AND YOUR TESTIMONY WAS VERY
IMPORTANT TODAY THANK YOU --
JUST CHAIRED RECOMMENDED AYE
VOTE.
ON SB THREE THREE EIGHT THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED JONES
SAWYER.
CHEN SIR I LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BARRICADE HAND BACK
HE HAD I DEEP.
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK.
QUIRK I SANTIAGO.
WICKS WICKS I THAT MEASURE
PASSES [inaudible]
SENATOR GALGIANI.
AND SENATOR WILL.
ARE THE LAST
--
TWO SO WORK --
PROBABLY HERE TILL NOON.
AND WE WON'T BE BACK
[inaudible]
UNTIL.
NEXT [inaudible]
YEAR.
SO I WOULD RECOMMEND
[inaudible]
THAT ARE.
FINAL TO EITHER IT KNOWLEDGE.
THAT THESE ARE TO YOUR BILL.
GET DOWN HERE FOR PRESENTATION
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
.
ALSO WOULD LIKE TO THANK --
LORRAINE BLACK THIS IS OUR LAST
DAY IN HER VERY WELL -- BEFORE
WE ADJOURN -- THE RAIN BLACK FOR
YOU. FOR ALL HER CONTRIBUTION TO
COMMITTEE.
MAYES WORK THIS SPRING AND
SUMMER.
RAIN JOINED US AS AN INTERN
AFTER COMPLETING HER FIRST YEAR
LAW SCHOOL AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
WISCONSIN MADISON.
RITA PRECIADO CONTRIBUTION TO
THE COMMITTEE'S WORK AND HELP
SHE HAD A VALUABLE EXPERIENCE.
RAIN LEAVES US ON FRIDAY AND
WILL BEGIN THE SECOND HALF OF
FOR SUMMER INTERNSHIP.
IN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE RAIN I
HOPE YOU WILL STAY IN TOUCH WITH
US THANK YOU FOR JOINING US THIS
SUMMER.
AND I WILL LET EVERYBODY CLAP.
THERE WELCOME HERE THAT IS --
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN SB. FIVE
EIGHT ZERO ANIMAL ABUSE
PROBATION TREATMENT.
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS PAULA
JONES FOR BEING LATE BUT I HAD A
MEETING WITH DOCTOR WEBER AND
YOU DO NOT MAKE DOCTOR WEBER WAY.
SO -- PROGRAM PRESENTING SB FIVE
EIGHTY WHICH YOU'RE NOT JUST
TRYING TO MAKE A CHANGE IN OUR
PENAL SYSTEM BUT WE'RE ALSO
TRYING TO SAVE LIVES.
IT'S BEEN PROVEN THAT ANIMAL
ABUSE IS LINKED TO VIOLENCE
TOWARDS PEOPLE.
THOSE WHO ABUSE ANIMALS WILL
OFTEN END UP COMMITTING MUCH
GREATER OFFENSES ACCORDING TO
STUDIES 31% OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
OFFENDERS HAVE ABUSED ANIMALS AT
SOME POINT IN THEIR PAST. 70% OF
THE MOST VIOLENT PRISON INMATES
HAVE A HISTORY OF ANIMAL ABUSE.
GIVEN THIS KNOWLEDGE IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO ACT TO PREVENT
THIS FROM HAPPENING IN THE
FUTURE.
IT SEEMS CLEAR THAT WILL THAT
WHAT WE HAVE IN PLACE ISN'T
WORKING RECIDIVISM RATES FOR
ANIMAL CRUELTY CRIMES ARE HIGH
IN OFFENDERS ARE ALL OFTEN
ELEVATE.
TO MORE SERIOUS CRIMES SB FIVE
EIGHTY WOULD REQUIRE MENTAL
HEALTH EVALUATIONS FOR ANIMAL
CRUELTY OFFENSES INSURING THAT
DEFENDANTS GET THE HELP THEY
NEED.
I UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS WITH
pPRINT AND I DO WANT TO DRESS
THEM.
IF WE GET THIS OUT TODAY WE'D
LIKE TO MAKE A NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS TO GET THIS TO A
BETTER PLACE.
WE PLAN TO DROP THE THE MAIN
EDUCATION PROVISION WELL I STILL
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS GOOD POLICY
BUT WE'LL TAKE A LOOK AT THAT IN
THE FUTURE.
AND I RESPECT THAT THIS MAY NOT
BE THE PROPER TIME TO PURSUE
THAT.
WILL ALSO WERE ALSO WILLING TO
LIMIT THE AMOUNT OF CRIMES THAT
TRIGGER MANDATORY EVALUATION TO
ONLY THOSE THAT HAVE THE
ABSOLUTE MOST SERIOUS MENTAL
HEALTH IMPLICATIONS.
AND HIGHEST POTENTIAL FOR
RECIDIVISM THIS WOULD INCLUDE
**** ANIMAL HOARDING AND
INTENTIONALLY MAIMING OR
TORTURING AN ANIMAL.
WE WANT THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CONTINUE WORKING ON THIS --
PROTECTING ANIMALS IN PEOPLE'S
IS TOO IMPORTANT NOT TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE AND WITH ME TODAY IS
LINDSEY LARISA WITH THE ANIMAL
LEGAL DEFENSE FUND TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU SENATOR -- MY NAME IS
LINDSAY LARSON HERE ON BEHALF
FAMILY -- DEFENSE FUND THE
SPONSOR SENATE BILL.
FIVE EIGHTY YEAH I'M THE ANIMAL
CRUELTY AND VIOLENCE
INTERVENTION ACT EMPOWERS COURTS
WITH KEY TOOL TO HELP
REHABILITATE CONVICTED ANIMAL
ABUSERS.
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THE BEHAVIOR
AND ACTUALLY PREVENT FUTURE
VIOLENCE BOTH ANIMALS AND HUMANS.
A CENTER WELCOME NOTED OVER THE
COURSE OF THE PAST TWO DECADES
NUMEROUS STUDIES HAVE
DEMONSTRATED A STRONG LINK
BETWEEN VIOLENCE ANIMALS AND
BALANCE OF PEOPLE.
WITHOUT INTERVENTION THOSE WHO
USE ANIMALS OFTEN GO TO BE USE
THEIR CHILDREN OR THEIR SPOUSES
OR TO COMMIT OTHER FORMS OF
VIOLENCE.
THIS LINK AREAS OF ANIMAL ABUSE
ARE -- CHILD ABUSE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AS WELL AS AND ELDER
ABUSE ALL OF WHAT YOU'VE HEARD
ABOUT THIS MORNING.
THEY ALL OF VULNERABLE VICTIMS
IN FACT MOST WOMEN ENTERING
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SHELTERS
REPORT THAT THEIR ABUSER ALSO
KILLED HARMED OR THREATENED TO
CAL PAT.
RECOGNIZING THAT THIS LINK
EXISTS THERE'S CURRENTLY
THIRTIES TO STATE THAT HAVE
LEGISLATION EITHER PERMITS
REQUIRE SOME LEVEL OF MENTAL
HEALTH COUNSELING.
AS PER PROBATION UNDER
SENTENCING IN CASE OF AN OBVIOUS
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THEM.
MANY OF THESE SAME STATES EITHER
HAVE MANDATORY -- PERMISSIVE
MENTAL HEALTH EVALUATION
HAPPENING POST CONVICTION AND
PRE SENTENCE WITH THE EXPLICIT
PURPOSE OF ADVISING JUDGES ON
THE BEST COURSE OF TREATMENT TO
REHABILITATE THE OFFENDER. TO
THE STATE'S INCLUDE ILLINOIS IN
COLORADO WHICH ARE HIGHLY RANKED
AS PROTECTIVE OF ANIMALS.
ACCORDING TO THE LG LDF.
SB FIVE EIGHTY IS IMPORTANT
EXCEPT FOR CALIFORNIA IN COMBAT
IN THE CYCLE OF VIOLENCE WHILE
PROVIDING NECESSARY
REHABILITATIVE SERVICES TO
OFFENDERS.
SB FIVE EIGHTY PROVIDES JUDGES
WITH INVALUABLE TOOL A REPORT
FROM MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONAL.
THE PROVIDES INDIVIDUALIZED
RECOMMENDATION AS TO TREATMENT
WHILE LEAVING JUDGES WITH THE
DISCRETION TO MAKE THE ULTIMATE
DECISION AS TO WHAT TREATMENT IF
ANY.
IS TO BE ORDER AS A CONDITION OF
PAROLE.
AS CENTER WILL MENTION TAKING
CONCERNS OF STAKEHOLDERS AND
THIS COMMITTEE INTO ACCOUNT
WE'RE PREPARED TO MAKE
AMENDMENTS NARROWING DOWN THE
CATEGORIES OF FENCES TRIGGERING
MENTAL HEALTH EVALUATION. TO
ENSURE THAT ONLY OFFENDERS OF
ANIMAL CRUELTY CRIMES OF HIGH
CORRELATION UNDERLYING MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES MOST OF WHOM WERE
ALREADY REQUIRE MENTAL HEALTH
COUNSELING UNDER THE CURRENT LAW.
THEY RECEIVE THE EVALUATION TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE ACTUAL
COUNSELING IS NARROWLY TAILORED
FITS THE INDIVIDUAL AND PROVIDES
THE BEST CHANCE FOR MEANINGFUL
THERAPEUTIC REHABILITATION.
MISSIONS WORK IN THE FIELD A
MENTAL HEALTH CLINICIAN IS KEY
IN MAKING THE RECOMMENDATION ON
THE MOST APPROPRIATE TYPE OF
THERAPY THAT WOULD BE AVAILABLE.
THE RESULT OF THIS EVALUATION
ARE CRUCIAL IN PROVIDING THE
CORRECT DIAGNOSTIC TOOL AND
THEREFORE HAVE TARGETED PLANNING.
RESEARCH IN THE FIELD HIS SHOULD
PROMISING RESULTS WITH THE TYPE
OF COUNSELING KNOWN AS MORAL
RECOGNITION RECOGNITION THERAPY
AND MARTY.
WHICH SPECIFICALLY SEEKS TO
DECREASE RECIDIVISM AMONG BUT
BOTH JUVENILE AND ADULT CRIMINAL
OFFENDERS BY INCREASING MORAL
REASONING FOR VARIATION OF THE
WELL KNOWN COGNITIVE BEHAVIOR
APPROACH.
WHAT'S A RELATIVELY NEW FIELD OF
STUDY THERE'S BEEN EVIDENCE THIS
TYPE OF THERAPY REDUCES
RECIDIVISM IN JUVENILE AND ADULT
POPULATIONS.
IT'S ONE TYPE OF TREATMENT
AVAILABLE BUT ANIMAL ABUSE CAN
BE CONNECTED TO A WIDE RANGE OF
MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEMS.
AND THERE ARE A WIDE VARIETY OF
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS THAT
CAN HELP ADDRESS THIS.
WITH THE RANGE OF UNDERLYING
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
A MANIFESTING THE KIND OF ANIMAL
ABUSE IT'S LOGICALFOR
REHABILITATION OF THE OFFENDER.
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC PUBLIC AND
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS INVOLVED IN
THAT RECOMMENDATION.
ALSO NOTABLY AT FIVE EIGHTY SO
LEAVE THE ULTIMATE DISCRETION
THE HANDS OF THE JUDGE WHO CAN
BALANCE THAT RECOMMENDATION WITH
ISSUES OF JUSTICE AND ANY UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCES AFFECTING THE
OFFENDER.
THE GOAL OF SUCH EVALUATION AND
POTENTIALLY TREATMENT IS NOT TO
PUNISH THE READ THE OFFENDER BUT
TO PROVIDE HIM OR HER AT THE
NECESSARY TOOLS TO CHANGE
BEHAVIOR.
AND AVOID RE OFFENDING MANDATORY
COUNSELING PROGRAMS RELATED
CRIME SUCH AS BATTERIES PROGRAMS
OR PARENTING PROGRAMS HAVE NOT
BEEN CREATED FOR ANIMAL ABUSE
OFFENSES.
INSTEAD THE COURTS SENTENCED
MOST OF THESE OFFENDERS TO THE
MANDATORY COUNCIL REQUIREMENTS
IN GENERAL ANGER MANAGEMENT.
UNDER THE CURRENT LAW THIS CAN
BE PART OF THE PROBLEM BUT IT'S
NOT ALWAYS SUFFICIENT ACTUALLY
ADDRESS UNDERLYING ISSUES.
SB FIVE EIGHTY WILL BE IMPORTANT
AND ADDRESS THE ISSUE AND
HELPING NUMEROUS PEOPLE.
CALIFORNIA HAS THE OPPORTUNITY
RIGHT NOW TO TAKE STEPS TO
PROTECT ANIMALS AND THE PUBLIC
FROM FUTURE VIOLENCE.
THE BIPARTISAN SUPPORTED AND OF
HOUSE AND SENATE UNANIMOUSLY.
SO WE COMMEND CENTER WELL FOR
INTRODUCING THIS HOLISTIC
APPROACH.
AND IS RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ORDER ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ALMOST GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS SHARON RILEY
ON BEHALF OF THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL AS IT IS CURRENTLY.
IN PRINT -- BEFORE YOU START AND
DISCUSS OUR OUR CONCERNS I WOULD
LIKE TO THINK THE AUTHORS OFFICE
AND THE SPONSORS -- FOR ENGAGING
WITH US SENATE BUT UNFORTUNATELY
AT THIS POINT -- WE HAVEN'T SEEN
A NAFF -- WE DID RECEIVE THE
DRAFT AMENDMENTS LATE LAST NIGHT.
OR LATE AFTERNOON WE HAVEN'T
REALLY HAD A CHANCE.
TO DIGEST THEM SO I AM GOING TO
GO AHEAD AND JUST.
RAISE THE CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE
AS THE BILL IS A CURRENTLY IN
PRINT.
SO WHATEVER FIRST CONCERNS IS
THAT IT REQUIRES JUDGES TO ORDER
THE MENTAL HEALTH EVALUATIONS.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT IT SHOULD BE
PERMISSIVE IN THAT IT SHOULD BE
DISCRETIONARY.
ON BEHALF OF THE COURTS AT THE
PARTICULARLY BECAUSE AS
CURRENTLY WRITTEN.
THERE'S A VERY BROAD RANGE OF OF
CRIMES THAT WOULD BE SUBJECT TO
THE MENTAL HEALTH OF VALUE
MANDATORY MENTAL HEALTH
EVALUATIONS.
ANOTHER CONCERN AND I I KNOW
THAT MY MY COLLEAGUE HERE WILL
GET INTO IT MORE.
IS THAT IT WOULD REQUIRE A
PSYCHIATRIST OR A CYCLE
PSYCHOLOGIST TO THE REVIEW.
AND AN ONGOING -- CHALLENGE THE
COURTS HAVE ENCOUNTERED IS THE
AVAILABILITY OF THOSE RESOURCES --
SO WITH THAT SAID -- WITH THAT
IN OUR VIEW OF THE FACT THAT NOT
ALL OF THE NEW MARRIED AND
CRIMES WOULD.
LEND THEMSELVES TO A MENTAL
HEALTH EVALUATION WE THINK THAT
WOULD BE AN UNFORTUNATE -- USE
OF COURT RESOURCES TO GO DOWN
THIS PATH PARTICULARLY BECAUSE
UNDER EXISTING LAW IF A COURT
ORDERS THE MENTAL HEALTH
EVALUATION THE COURT MUST PAY
FOR IT -- WE ARE ALSO CONCERNED
ABOUT THE WAY IT'S CURRENTLY
WRITTEN.
IT APPEARS THAT IT WOULD REQUIRE
THE EVALUATION TO BE ORDERED
AFTER CONVICTION AND SENTENCE
SCENE -- ORDINARILY WE WOULD SEE
SOMETHING LIKE THIS PERHAPS.
AFTER CONVICTION BUT PRIOR TO
CERTAIN SCENES WHAT COULD BE
PART OF THE PROBATION.
REPORT AND THEN FINALLY -- THE
PROVISIONS RELATING TO ABILITY
TO PAY AND WHEN SOMEBODY IS NOT
ABLE TO PAY WHO IS GOING TO STEP
IN AND PAY FOR THE COUNSELING --
WE BELIEVE ARE UNCLEAR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
AND THEN GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- BUT IT'S STILL
MORNING -- TYLER IN THE WITH THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION WHILE WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS INTENT TO ADDRESS THE
LINK BETWEEN ANIMAL CRUELTY AND
THEN THE POTENTIAL.
FOR VIOLENCE TOWARDS ON HUMANS
WE ARE REGRETFULLY OPPOSED TO SB
FIVE EIGHTY WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
UNDULY TIES THE HAND OF COURTS
AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PRACTITIONERS.
I'D LIKE TO ALIGN MY COMMENTS
WITHOUT AROUND BACK CALL THAT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM JUDICIAL COUNCIL
MEN OUT A LITTLE BIT MORE TO YOU --
WHILE IT SEVERAL STUDIES HAVE
THE LINKED A UNDERLYING MENTAL
HEALTH DIAGNOSIS -- TO VIOLENCE
TOWARD ANIMALS NOT ALL OF THE
CRIMES ENUMERATED WITH IN THIS
BILL A FOLK THE SAME -- MENTAL
HEALTH CONCERNS ADDS THAT SOME
OF THE OTHERS SPECIFICALLY
CRIMES RELATED TO IMPROPERLY
CARING FOR ANY ANIMAL OVER
WORKING AN ANIMAL OR EVEN
INJURING A POLICE DOG MAY NOT BE
LINKED TO AN UNDERLYING MENTAL
ILLNESS.
INTO THE MANDATORY NATURE OF
THIS WOULD AND UP UTILIZING
COURT RESOURCES TO FIND THAT
THERE WAS NOT AN UNDERMINE
MENTAL ILLNESS -- ALSO
ADDITIONALLY WHEN I'VE BEEN
TALKING WITH SOME OF OUR FOLKS
ON MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
THEY WERE SAYING THAT MOST
LIKELY WHAT THE UNDERLYING CAUSE
OF THIS -- IF IT IS A MENTAL
HEALTH DIAGNOSIS IS A
PERSONALITY DISORDER
PARTICULARLY ANTISOCIAL
PERSONALITY DISORDER.
AND IN CASES WHERE -- MENTAL
HEALTH IS SUSPECTED AS THE CAUSE
OF THE CRIME AND AB EIGHTEEN TEN
LAST YEAR MAN HOW TO VERSION LAW
WAS PASSED WITH X. -- THE STATE
HAS EXPRESSIVELY EXCLUDED --
ANTISOCIAL PERSONALITY DISORDER
AND SO IF THE PERSON'S NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR THE VERSION THAN IN
THEIR CONVICTED UNDER THIS PSALM
ONE OF THESE OFFENSES THEY WOULD
HAVE TO GO UNDERGO ANOTHER
PSYCHIATRIC EVALUATION -- WHICH
WOULD BE DUPLICATIVE OF WHAT
THEY'D ALREADY RECEIVED.
WE ALSO -- LIKE TO MENTION THAT
THERE IS A CURRENTLY A SHORTAGE
OF INDIVIDUALS ABLE TO CONDUCT
MENTAL HEALTH OR PSYCHIATRIC
EVALUATIONS ACROSS THE STATE.
ESPECIALLY IN SMALLER COUNTIES
WHERE -- THAT APARTMENTS I
REPRESENT ARE THE ONES THAT
NORMALLY CONDUCT THE EVALUATIONS.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL
WOULD ADD AN UNDUE WORKLOAD --
TO WHAT IS ALREADY AN
OVERBURDENED SYSTEM IT WITH THE
AMOUNT OF COMPETENCY EVALUATIONS
THAT -- THE COURTS ARE SEEN AND
THE COUNTIES ARE CONDUCTING AN
AND WE ARE AS I'M SURE OF THE
COMMITTEE AS WELL WHERE YOU KNOW
WE HAVE A SIGNIFICANT POPULATION
WAITING TO GET INTO THE STATE
HOSPITALS THAT ARE BEEN DECLARED
INCOMPETENT STAND TRIAL.
SO WE DID RECEIVE THE AMENDMENTS
WILL BE READING THROUGH THEM BUT
WE LIKELY WOULD REMAIN OPPOSED
AND WE WE APPRECIATE THE ATTEND
BUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD I AM I THINK WE'RE AN
AFTERNOON NOW GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT -- LIKE A DOCTOR OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE ALSO OPPOSE THE BILL I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS -- FOR THE DISCUSSIONS
THAT WE'VE HAD -- WE WILL ALSO
BE REVIEWING THE AMENDMENTS --
AND ARE HAPPY TO CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS SHOULD THE BILL MOVE
FORWARD THANK YOU.
MR COURSE MR CHURKIN.
LET ME -- LET ME SAY SOMETHING
HERE.
FIRST OF ALL.
I THINK THAT YOU HAVE -- MOVE
THE BILL IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
I HAD COME PREPARED TO VOTE NO.
I THINK YOU MOVED IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BUT I CAN'T MAKE AN
EVALUATION -- RIGHT NOW BASED ON
WHAT YOU'VE SAID.
AND I WOULD JUST SUGGEST YOU
MAKE THIS A TO YOUR BILL AND TRY
AND WORK OUT THE DETAILS -- WITH --
STAFF WITH THE OPPOSITION --
DETAILS LIKE -- HOW?
WHAT AT WHAT TIME?
DOES A PSYCHOLOGIST BECOME
INVOLVED -- THEY THE OPPOSITION
IS SAYING IT'S BEST TO HAPPEN
BEFORE SENTENCING -- YOU OF
CERTAINLY REDUCED BY FAR AND
THAT WAS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CONCERNS THE NUMBER OF OF
OFFENSES.
ARE ON THE OTHER HAND I DON'T
KNOW HOW.
HOW MANY THAT IS WHAT THE COST
WOULD BE I THINK THERE'S JUST A
LOT I THINK YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S
FANTASTIC WHAT YOU'VE DONE?
I JUST THINK IT'S VERY HARD FOR
ME TO EVALUATE IT.
AND IF YOU COULD MAKE THIS A TO
YOUR BILL I JUST THINK IT AS A
MUCH -- YOU KNOW RATHER THAN
HAVE US VOTE NO.
ASK FOR RECONSIDERATION WHATEVER --
I JUST THINK MAKING THE TO YOUR
BILL WOULD WORK SO THAT'S MY
THAT'S MY OFFER.
IS THE CHAIR OPEN TO THAT.
EXTREMELY OPEN TO THAT.
THEN THE BILL BE TESTIMONY ONLY.
YEAH I'M FINE WITH A LOT OF A
LOT OF THE JUDICIAL COUNCILS
CONCERNS ARE ADDRESSED IN THE
AMENDMENTS AND I FOR ONE
UNDERSTAND WHERE PEOPLE ARE
LIKELY TO SIGN OFF ON SOMETHING
WHEN THEY WHEN IT JUST COMES
ACROSS OR DOWN SO -- WE'RE MORE
THAN HAPPY TO MAKE IT TO YOUR
BILL TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE OPPONENTS AND WORK WITH YOUR
STAFF AND YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AND GET THIS BILL EXACTLY WHERE
WE NEEDED TO BE SO IT BENEFITS --
ANIMALS AND PEOPLE RAINY ONLY
OTHER THING I WOULD ADD AS YOU
AS YOU MOVE FORWARD TO CHAIRS
CONCERN IS THE MANDATORY.
THANKS AND NOT GIVING JUDGES
ENOUGH DISCRETION BUT I THINK.
GIVEN TIME WE MAY BE ABLE TO WE
GOT THIS FAR BY.
TALKING WITH LOW MORE TIME WE
PROBABLY GETTING FURTHER.
AND WHICH IS WHAT.
OUR STEAM KALI HIS SAID THAT WE
SHOULD DO THAT.
SO I AM I WOULD DISCARDED AS
COMMITTEE REALLY APPRECIATE
UNLESS MISS COMEDY WHAT.
SO IN AND I SUPPORT THIS --
OFFER AND SUPPORT YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF IT GEN DID THE
LACK OF JUDICIAL DISCRETION WILL
PROBABLY BE AN ONGOING
CONVERSATION.
JUST AS KIND OF LOOKING AT
DEGREES OF NEGLECT AND I
CERTAINLY THINK PEOPLE WOULD.
QUESTION IF MUTILATING AND
TORTURING AND SODOMIZING AN
ANIMAL IS THE SAME IS NOT
LEAVING THE WINDOW CRACKED IN A
RED DRESS HANDS -- AND THEN OVER
BURDENING AN ALREADY BROKEN
JUDICIAL SYSTEM WITH SOME OF THE
MANDATORY ELEMENTS -- AS WELL AS
FIGURING OUT A WAY TO KIND OF
SHARE WHAT THE METRICS WOULD BE
FOR EVALUATING YOU KNOW WHEN AN
ANIMAL IS OVERWORKED OVERLOADED
OVER DRIVEN YOU KNOW I WOULD
ARGUE PEOPLE TAKEN AT THE
ANIMALS. TO THE BATHROOM IN THE
RESTAURANT ALL THAT COULD KIND
OF BE CONSIDERED TORTURE BUT I
KNOW THAT'S NOT.
PART OF THIS.
BUT I THINK IF THERE CAN BE WAY
IT'S A KIND OF TWEAK THAT WE CAN
GET TO THE HEART OF WHAT THIS.
IS ABOUT WHICH IS WHEN FOLKS ARE.
USING ANIMALS IN DOG FIGHTS IN
TORTURING THEM [inaudible]
THEY ARE MORE LIKELY THAN NOT
GOING TO HARM AND AND A HUMAN
AND THAT IS JUST LET JET -- BUT
I WOULD ASK THAT SOME OF THOSE
THINGS ALSO BE GREAT AND WE WILL
DELVE INTO THAT.
OKAY THANK THANK YOU SENATOR FOR
RECONSIDERATION MEMBERS.
SHARE TIME -- SO SB FIVE EIGHT
OH IS BEING WITHDRAWN BY.
AUTHORED BOOK IS JUST.
JUST TESTIMONY ON THAT'S RIGHT
TESTIMONIALS I APOLOGIZE.
AND THIS MISS SENATOR GALGIANI
OUR LAST. ONE FOR THE YEAR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBER SP
MOVE FOR DEL.
NINE ADDS CONSISTENCY TO THE
PENAL CODE BY APPLYING THE
EXISTING FIVE YEAR SENTENCE
ENHANCEMENT FOR THE INFLICTION
OF GREAT BODILY INJURY DURING A
RAPE TO INCLUDE ALL SPOUSAL RAPE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
MISTER FIELDS ANA.
FROM THE LA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE [inaudible]
IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
MARCO GEORGE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION WE
THANK THE AUTHOR AND THE STAFF
FIRM NARROWING THE BILL BUT WE
STILL REMAIN IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE FAIRS
RECOMMENDED AYE VOTE.
ON SB FOUR FIFTY NINE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER HI JOHN
SO AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY HI BARRICADE HAN
BARRICADE HAD I'D DEEP.
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK.
QUIRK I SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WICKS [inaudible]
WICKS I THAT MEASURE PASSES.
AND WE NEED MISTER DEEP AND
SANTIAGO. TO ADD ON OTHERWISE WE
WILL BE.
AND I WANNA MAKE SURE.
I WANT THANK YOU TO ALL OF OUR
STE PUBLIC SAFETY STAFF. FOR A
WONDERFUL YEAR DEALING BOTH WITH
BOTH THE ASSEMBLY BILLS AND THE
SENATE BILL.
YES YOU'RE ALLOWED TO CLAP FOR
THAT.
ON ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY S. BEFORE
THIRTY NINE LACKEY [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
YEAH HI.
HONESTY FOR THIRTY NINE LACKEY I
ON ITEM NUMBER TEN SB FORTY FIVE
BY SENATOR BELT LACKEY.
NO LACKEY NO
[inaudible]
I
AN ITEM NUMBER ONE WAS PULLED
BY THE AUTHOR.
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB ONE FORTY
FIVE DEEP.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I I DON'T
NUMBER THREE SB TWO SIXTEEN I
WAS ON CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER FOR SB TO SEVENTY
THREE BY SENATOR RUBIO SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO AYE.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB THREE THREE
EIGHT DEEP.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I ITEM NUMBER
SIX SB THREE SIXTY WAS PULLED BY
THE AUTHOR.
AT A NUMBER SEVEN SB THREE
SEVENTY SIX HAS BEEN DISPENSED
WITH.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB FOUR THIRTY
NINE BY SENATOR UMBERG SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I ITEM NUMBER NINE AS
BEFORE FIFTY NINE BY SENATOR
GALGIANI DEEP.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I ITEM NUMBER
TEN SB FOUR EIGHTY FIVE DEEP.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN SB FIVE FORTY
FIVE WAS PULLED BY THE AUTHOR.
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE SB FIVE BY
FIVE BY SENATOR MITCHELL DEEP.
ITEM NUMBER. THREE THIRTEEN
EXCUSE ME SB FIVE EIGHTY WITH
TESTIMONY ONLY.
I DON'T NUMBER FOURTEEN SB SEVEN
SIXTEEN BY SENATOR MITCHELL
[inaudible]
DEEP
.
WHERE CLOSER ROLE IN PUBLIC
SAFETY IN TWO MINUTES AND IT
WILL BE NO MORE FURTHER ADD ONS
?
I DON'T NUMBER ONE WAS PULLED BY
THE OUT THEIR LIVES.
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB ONE FORTY
FIVE DEEP [inaudible]
DEEP NOW.
ITEM NUMBER THREE WAS ON CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR HAS BEEN
DISPENSED WITH.
I DON'T NUMBER FIVE SB THREE
THREE EIGHT BY SENATOR HUESO
DEEP DEEP I ITEM NUMBER SIX WAS
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN HAS BEEN
DISPENSED WITH.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT HAS BEEN
ITEM NUMBER NINE S. BEFORE FIFTY
NINE BY SENATOR GALGIANI DEEP
[inaudible]
I I THE NUMBER TEN S. BEFORE
EIGHTY FIVE BY SENATOR BELL DEEP
[inaudible]
DEEP NOW.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN WAS PULLED BY
THE AUTHOR.
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE SB FIVE BY
FIVE BY SENATOR MITCHELL DEEP
[inaudible]
DEEP NO.
AT A NUMBER THIRTEEN WAS
TESTIMONY OWNING.
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN SB SEVEN
SIXTEEN BY SENATOR MITCHELL DEEP.
DEEP I AND THAT CONCLUDES THE
BUSINESS A PUBLIC SAFETY